Hast du schon Richard David Precht's neuen Podcast gehört?
Nein, den hab ich ja aufgegeben im Podcast.
Also es ist so. Richard David Brecht hat heute morgen, als ich dich gerade abgeholt hab, in seinem Podcast mit Lanz gesagt, ich referiere nur grob, ich würde nie ein Kind U12 impfen, denn das Immunsystem ist ja noch im Aufbau begriffen und darf durch diese Manipulation nicht gestört werden.
Und das bezog sich auf Corona.
Das ist unklar. Ich nehme an, da er Corona als Podcastthema hat, aber in diesem Satz nicht verwendet hat, dass er das schon so meint, dass er das grundsätzlich so sieht. Und das finde ich, das verschlägt uns ein bisschen die Sprache. Wir warten mal die Diskussion heute noch ab, aber ich finde es hochinteressant, denn wir haben ja in Salon über die neue Immunologie, oder wie auch immer, Immuniologie von Sloterdijk gesprochen, der genau die richtige Fassung hat, nämlich angelehnt an Niklas Luhmann und so weiter. Es gibt Immunsysteme der Gesellschaft, die nämlich genau die Grenzüberschreitung absolvieren sollen oder Grenzüberschreitung von außen in Systeme hinein abfangen sollen. Und eine Idee von Immunsystemen, die ungehindert von äußeren Einflüssen sich erst mal aufbauen soll, ist grotesk und eines deutschen Philosophen nicht würdig, würde ich sagen.
Würde ich auch sagen. Es wundert mich aber auch nicht allzu sehr. Denn wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit diesen Theoretikern da auseinandersetzt, die irgendwie sagen, wir steigen jetzt mal aus dem Kapitalismus aus, denn wir müssen doch mal wieder näher zu uns selbst, zur Natur und sonst was, dann ist man auch nur noch einen Schritt entfernt von solchen Theorien. Das muss man leider so sagen. Also das ist sehr, sehr esoterisch dann. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da Precht in diesen Kreisen nicht nur geliebt wird, sondern dass er auch diese Kreise rezipiert. Insofern mich wundert dabei Precht gar nicht mehr so viel.
Wollen wir das noch klassifizieren? Ist das irgendwie Wohlstandsphilosophie?
Ich glaube schon, das ist, wenn es einem ein bisschen zu gut geht, dann kann man sich dann auf so was kaprizieren.
Ja, Dekadentologie.
Dekadentologie, ja.
Brauchen wir hier mal, um das zu analysieren.
Ja, vielleicht ist das dann so was.
Es ist grotesk und damit sind wir auch gleich beim ersten Thema, das du mitgebracht hast, Heidenreich. Ich gucke üblicherweise jedes Fernsehprogramm, aber auch Lanz, aber in dem Falle bin ich jetzt, erwischte mich gleich kalt.
Das wundert mich sehr, weil es ja so viral ging, alles was da in dieser Sendung vorgefallen ist, dass du das überhaupt ausblenden konntest. Ist ja ein Wunder. Ich wollte es schon fast gar nicht mitbringen, weil ich dachte, das ist ein bisschen Eulen nach Athen tragen und ich möchte auch jetzt nicht diese Sendung groß referieren, nur so viel dazu sagen, Ecke Heidenreich, die nicht nur von Literatur keine Ahnung hat, fühlte sich auch noch bemüßigt in den Fall, Sarah Lee Heinrich einzusteigen und sich da sehr despektierlich über Sarah Lee Heinrich zu äußern. Ich will das gar nicht auch kommentieren, was Sarah Lee da gepostet hat. Für mich ist das so, wie meine Großmutter immer sagte, als wir Kinder waren, taten wir wie Kinder. Mich interessiert das Geschwätz von 13-Jährigen, 14-Jährigen einfach überhaupt nicht. Und das ist nichts, was ich rezipieren möchte. Und deswegen ist es auch jetzt für den Diskurs vollkommen irrelevant und sollte auch keine Rolle spielen jetzt. Entscheidend ist, was sie jetzt tut, was sie jetzt sagt, was sie da politisch bewegen wird als Sprecherin der Grünen, als Vorsitzende da der Jungen Grünen. Aber was erstaunlich ist, weil wir hier ja schon über Identität ein bisschen gesprochen haben mit Bezug auf die transsexuellen Gesetze und die Frage, wie spricht man jemanden an, Herr oder Frau, und kann man sich das aussuchen? Und da waren wir ja uns völlig einig, dass man das selbst wählen kann und dass das auch endlich rechtlich so sein sollte. Und ich finde, wir sollten auch einfach anerkennen, dass wir das ethnisch so begreifen, dass wir also sagen, wir können ja nicht jetzt wieder anfangen, in ein biologistisches oder rassistisches Weltbild zurückzufallen. Wir können jetzt auch nicht sagen, jetzt machen wir mal wieder Ahnenforschung. Wo kommt man denn eigentlich her und so weiter? Das ist aber etwas, was Elke Heidenreich offenbar sehr wichtig findet, dass man die Identität, die ethnische immer wieder herleitet, statt einfach mal ein modernes Staatsbürgertum anzuerkennen, wo man sagt, ja, lebt jetzt hier und jetzt weiß man nicht bei jedem, ob er die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft hat. Aber es scheint so zu sein, dass man nicht die Frage laufen stellen muss, wo kommst du her? Ich will jetzt nicht so weit gehen, dass ich sage, dass diese Frage grundsätzlich rassistisch motiviert ist oder so. Und es gibt auch manchmal natürlich aus einem Gespräch heraus diese Frage, wo kommst du her? Ich hatte sie kürzlich tatsächlich auch im Taxi. Ich nenne das, weil sie auch gleich ein Taxibeispiel bringen. Und zwar fuhr ich da durch Berlin mit dem Taxi und der Taxifahrer erzählte mir, dass das in Spanien ganz anders sei mit dem Taxifahren. Er erzählte, dass er da zehn Jahre zuvor Taxifahrer war. Und ich fragte, ach, kommen Sie aus Spanien? Worauf er sagte, nein, ich komme aus Rumänien. Dann habe ich natürlich noch mal der Hütlichkeit halber schon nachgefragt, weil ich wusste, der Mann will mir jetzt offenbar auch was erzählen von sich. Und das tat er dann auch. Aber jetzt hören wir uns mal an, wie Heidenreich ins Taxi steigt. Also sie sagt dann jetzt erst mal, nachdem sie diesen Ausschnitt von Sara Lee Heinrich gesehen hat, die jetzt keine Weiße ist, da ist also für Heidenreich vollkommen klar, was für ein Ausschnitt? Was wollte er auslernen? Also es wurde dieser Ausschnitt nochmal gezeigt von dieser Talkrunde, in der Sara Lee Heinrich mal war und dann sich dispektierlich über die deutsche Mehrheitsgesellschaft äußerte. Alles eigentlich jetzt irrelevant für den Clip, der jetzt kommt, nämlich Heidenreich. Für sie ist die Sache jetzt klar, wie man da reagiert, wenn man jetzt eine Frau zum Beispiel vor sich sieht, die nicht weiß ist.
Wenn einer aussieht wie sie, frage ich natürlich, wo kommst du her oder wo kommen sie her?
Nee, da würde ich sagen, da fragt man nicht erstmal, wo kommst du her. Da würde ich einfach sagen, ah, guten Tag.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man völlig Kontext befreit, jemanden sieht und man will gerne das Eis brechen und man sucht nach einem Thema, um irgendwie die Konversation zu beginnen und beginnt dann aber mit, wo kommst du her? Dann ist ja völlig klar, man bezieht sich auf die Hautfarbe. Also das geht ja gar nicht anders. Diese Frage, ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass sie grundsätzlich rassistisch ist, sondern es kann durchaus einfach persönliches Interesse sein. Nur man muss sich dann eben sicher sein, das ist eine ziemlich dumme Frage, weil sie auf Augenhöhe ist mit, was hast du mit zehn Jahren im Fernsehen gesehen, worüber könnten wir uns unterhalten? Oder eben das Wetter, was ansonsten hast du es trocken hierher geschafft und so. Ja, auf der Ebene. Also entweder ist es eine rassistische oder eine ziemlich plumpe Art und Weise. Also in beiden Fällen eigentlich nicht für Frau Heidenreich würdig, würde ich sagen.
Und man nötigt jemanden dann noch auf, etwas Privates zu erzählen direkt. Also man möchte vielleicht ja auch gar nicht jetzt erstmal vielleicht eine traumatische Fluchtgeschichte erzählen. Oder man möchte ja auch nicht, wenn man selbst ins Taxi geht, vom Taxifahrer gefahren wird. Und ihre Großeltern waren die etwa auch Nazis. Ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so angenehm.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, denn für mich ist es absolut zwingende Höflichkeit am Anfang. Und ich weiß, dass es in Deutschland total anders ist, nicht über den Beruf zu reden. Was machst du denn? Und so, diese typische Frage. Das ist irgendwie, alle haben sich dran gewöhnt. Ich beantworte diese Frage nie und ich käme nie auf den Gedanken. Alle, die mich schon mal bei Hörer treffen oder so getroffen haben, wissen das. Ich würde niemals so in den Beruf einsteigen, zum Beispiel. Weil das überschreitet einfach so ein paar Grenzen. Das muss man dann schon vorbereiten und auch irgendwie rechtfertigen, wenn man dann mal über Berufe sprechen will. Also Fall aus Tarantak, da muss man dann schon in Jülich am Atomkraftzentrum arbeiten. Und es muss gerade in Europa eine Atomkraftdebatte laufen, um dann mal sozusagen das Thema, was machst du eigentlich beruflich? Ach so, du arbeitest da in Jülich und so.
Bei Beruf würde ich das anders sehen, weil es ja eine freie Berufswahl gibt und die ja doch etwas aussagen kann. Also klar ist das jetzt nicht die Frage, die ich zu immer Leuten stelle, aber es ist doch zum Beispiel, wenn ich, wie jetzt auch geschehen, zum Beispiel in Frankfurt, Kürz dich, Hörerinnen und Hörer hier unseres Podcasts traf, dass ich dann frage, was sie beruflich machen oder studieren oder so. Das ist ja schon etwas, weil ich zum Beispiel wissen will, beschäftigen die sich vielleicht auch sonst mit dem Thema Film oder dem Thema Wirtschaft.
Ja klar, also ich habe eine persönliche Marotte von mir geschildert. Ich würde niemals so einsteigen. Die Frage nach dem Beruf wäre für mich immer eine Anschlussfrage. Und du fragst als erstes? Ich versuche es so offen wie möglich zu gestalten. Okay. Also ich vermeide möglichst auch das Wetter, aber mir geht es erstmal um alles außer um diese persönlichen Sachen.
Ich bin ein Smalltalk Desaster. Insofern muss ich mir am liebsten gleich was Thematisches suchen. Das funktioniert ganz gut.
Dann fragt Wolfgang immer nach seinem Schnitzel. So was. Das ist immer ein guter Einstieg.
Ja, wir hören mal weiter Heidenreich.
Und zwar nicht, um sie zu diskriminieren. Alle sind immer sofort diskriminiert und beleidigt. Sondern weil ich sofort sehe, die kommt nicht aus Wanne-Eickel oder Wuppertal, sondern die hat Eltern, die von woanders kommen.
Das ist ja noch plumper.
Das wird jetzt immer schlimmer. Wir haben noch zwei Clips vor uns und das wird jetzt immer schlimmer. Denn sie so gerät jetzt einfach mal, ne, das ist ja klar, die kann gar nicht von hier kommen, weil die sieht ja nicht so aus wie ich.
Wenn du aus Wanne-Eickel käme, würde ich nicht danach fragen, weil das fände ich dann total normal. Alles andere interessiert mich.
Ja, es ist absurd und wird noch absurder.
Und ich finde das keine diskriminierende Frage, wenn ich einen netten, dunkelhäutigen Taxifahrer habe, der perfekt Kölsch spricht und ich sage, wo kommen sie eigentlich her? Und er sagt, nein, sonst sind sie aus Marokko. Ich finde da kein Problem, dass man fragt, weil man sieht es ja.
Nein, wenn der Taxifahrer auch noch Kölsch kann, dann ist auch einfach mal gut. Dann kann man nämlich daraus Schluss folgern, der scheint Kölnern zu sein. In der Regel niemand Kölsch.
Oh Gott, das ist ganz schlimm. Vor allem, was erklärt sie uns, dass sie damit kein Problem hat? Also das ist doch nun wirklich angekommen, dass wir uns natürlich auf das Gegenüber besinnen in dieser Diskussion und fragen, wie geht es dem denn damit? Und das ist ein Recht, damit kein Problem hat, muss sie doch nicht bei Lanz nochmal erklären. Also das ist doch wohl klar.
Sie erzählt auch dann noch, das habe ich jetzt nicht noch mitgebracht, dass sie doch auch im Ägypten Urlaub gefragt wird, woher sie kommt. Ja klar, wenn ich mit einer touristischen Gruppe unterwegs bin, wenn ich in irgendeinem Ferienparadies sitze mit Swimmingpool und allem, dann kann ich davon ausgehen, man wohnt jetzt offenbar nicht da. Also man macht ja nicht Urlaub am eigenen Platze. Und dann wird man vermutlich gefragt, auch auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen wird es so sein, dass man gefragt wird, da niemand auf dem Meer wohnt. Aber das ist doch nicht die Situation, die sie hier beschreibt.
Vor allem der Status eines Touristen ist nun wirklich der privilegierteste auf der ganzen Welt. Das ist noch mal das Top 1% der Top 10% auf der Welt. Und dass man da natürlich die Frage bekommt, sind sie hier, schauen sie sich das an. Was wollen sie eigentlich hier? Oder auch in Ägypten, wenn man angesprochen wird, auf der Straße, wie viel Geld haben sie mitgebracht? Wie viele Runden extra dürfen wir sie rumfahren, bevor sie merken, dass wir sie verarschen und ausnehmen wollen? Also unglaublich.
So, und der letzte Clip.
Das gehört doch zu uns dazu. Ich finde das wunderbar, dass wir so viele Menschen aus anderen Ländern hier haben, die bei uns leben und sich auch...
Ja, sie will eigentlich den anderen Menschen nur so ein Gaststatus zugestehen. Und das ist doch schön, dass wir hier so viele Gäste zulassen. Aber die gehören nicht eigentlich zu uns. Also wir sehen hier in 35 Sekunden, wie dumm man überhaupt argumentieren kann. Es ist der reine Wahnsinn. Und es wurde dann nicht besser. Also es ist jetzt nicht ein Clip, den ich mir zurechtgesucht habe, weil sie sonst hervorragend argumentiert hat, sondern es war eine große Peinlichkeit. Und ich würde auch sagen, Elke Heidenreich muss auch nicht laufend jetzt im Fernsehen sitzen.
Ja, aber das macht sie ja gar nicht so oft.
Ja, sie ist jetzt doch sehr häufig da gewesen, auch so bei Meilsberg und so. Sie ist ja auch noch im Schweizer Literaturclub. Das war ja damals auch schon so ein Skandal, dass sie Stefan Zweifel daraus gemobbt hat, obwohl er Recht hatte. Sie haben sich da über Heidegger gestritten. Sie hatte es überhaupt nicht gelesen. Er hatte es gelesen. Sie hat irgendwas behauptet, was nicht bei Heidegger steht. Er hat sie korrigiert. Er musste dafür gehen. Sie durfte bleiben. Also es ist schon eine sehr unangenehme Person.
Wohlstandsphilosophie. Wir brauchen hier eine Dekadentologie, die uns das nochmal aufzeigt, was mit den alten Menschen hier in Deutschland los ist. Okay, kommen wir zu den Jungen.
Wir kommen zu den Jungen. Wir haben uns beide was angesehen oder das ist falsch gesagt. Also ich habe es mir angesehen und du hast, glaube ich, den Sinn des Dokumentarfilms nicht so begreifen wollen und hast gedacht, ich höre mir das mal an.
Es kommen immer wieder verrückte Ideen auf von Filmemachern, also jetzt so im politischen Fernsehfilm, die glauben, sie müssten nicht selber nochmal dazu sagen, sie könnten die Protagonisten für sich sprechen lassen und am Ende ginge das schon irgendwie auf. Das Problem ist dann aber, wenn sie so Szenenbilder kreieren und darstellen und ich lade mir das runterwandeln, das in mp3 um und lade das in meinem Podcast-Player und höre das in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit, der dann noch die Pausen zwischen dem Sprechen rausnimmt, dann bleibt da echt nicht viel übrig. Und ich habe die großen Feierlichkeiten auf Twitter mitbekommen. Was für ein offenherziges Dokument Kevin Kühnert mal richtig erleben, so nah dran, dass sich schon andere beschweren, dass es aber zu viele Kameras hier gerade da sind, während er weiter die Politik macht für Deutschland. Nur, wenn man es nur hört, bleibt wirklich wenig davon übrig. Also ich kenne die Szenen so ein bisschen, in denen das abspielte seit diesen Parteitagen 2019 und so. Aber 18, 19. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, was du jetzt da besprechen willst. Weil ich hätte jetzt gedacht...
Du hast es ja nur der Informationsgewinnung dir angesehen. Also du hattest jetzt gedacht, findest du da jetzt Sätze, die fallen Clips wie in der Talkshow, die die etwa bei Maischberger fallen könnten. Das ist ja selbstverständlich nicht der Fall, weil wir es mit einem Dokumentarfilm zu tun haben, der ja auch eine filmische Qualität hat. Also es geht tatsächlich darum, dieses politische Leben von Kevin Kühnert zu beschreiben, das vor allem daran besteht, dass man permanent auf das Smartphone guckt. Also diese Smartphone-Sucht unter Politikern ist ja Wahnsinn. Also auch wenn man sich diese Parteitage ansieht. Irgendjemand spricht davon und das kann auch der Chef sein. Und alle blicken runter, sitzen dort und sind irgendwie am Scrawlen, sind Tweets am Absetzen. Und das sehen wir hier auch. Also wir sehen hier nur Politiker mit dem Smartphone bewaffnet. Bei Kevin Kühnert wurde jetzt so bei Twitter ein bisschen geschrieben, ja der rauchte aber zu viel. Würde ich sagen, Rauchen ist glaube ich nicht so ein Problem. Der raucht hin und wieder mal eine Zigarette. Aber da ist eine andere Sucht, nämlich eine ganz, ganz schlimme Smartphone-Sucht.
Davon kriegt man nichts mit, wenn man es so hört.
Und du hörst auch so eine kleine Sache da, unterhalten sich Kühnert und Amthor miteinander über das Schlafen, dass sie so wenig schlafen, fünf Stunden oder so. Und ich würde sagen, klar, wer die ganze Zeit in einem solchen Smartphone-Modus ist, kann nur wenig schlafen und glaubt aber, dass er damit ganz geschäftig ist und dass das ganz wichtig sei, so wenig zu schlafen. Damit zeigt man halt, was man so alles tolles leistet. Ich würde sagen, das Smartphone weggelegt und man könnte wahrscheinlich acht Stunden schlafen und wäre viel leistungsfähiger und würde auch mehr zu Wege bringen. Und so etwas sieht man da. Und man sieht diese Alltäglichkeit und man stellt erst mal fest, das ist ein unglaublich langweiliges Leben. Also ich möchte es überhaupt nicht machen. Und wir gehen jetzt auch mal ein bisschen anders vor. Also ich habe ein paar Clips rausgeschnitten aus dieser sechsteiligen Doku-Serie vom NDR. Und wir beginnen aber mit dem Ende der sechsten Folge, nämlich die Bundestagswahl ist vorbei. Wir kennen das Ergebnis. Die SPD hat zu einer gewissen Stärke zurückgefunden. Niemand hätte geglaubt, dass die SPD das schafft. Jetzt stehen draußen mit Bier in der Hand Hubertus Heil und Kevin Kühnert. Und Kevin Kühnert sagt jetzt Folgendes.
Ich will nicht behaupten, dass es alles unser Genie war, dass wir das alles so haben kommen zu sehen. Aber ein bisschen gut haben wir es schon gemacht.
Ja, unser Genie war es nicht, aber ein bisschen gut haben wir es schon gemacht. Und ich habe mir jetzt folgende Frage gestellt. Kann man das in dieser Doku nachvollziehen oder kann man es überhaupt nachvollziehen? Hat das etwas strategisch Gelenktes in der Form, dass man sagen kann, wir haben jetzt hier diesen Kanzlermacher, wir haben den, der die SPD entscheidend bewegt hat. Wer hat hier eigentlich wen bewegt oder sind die innerparteilichen Dynamiken so kontingent, dass man jetzt im Nachhinein so eine Schlussfolgerung daraus ziehen kann? Bisschen bescheiden natürlich von ihm, dann sagen, ein bisschen gut haben wir es gemacht, aber dass man doch suggeriert, aha, ich habe hier am Hebel gesessen. Stellt sich die Frage, ist das überhaupt gegeben in einer Partei wie der SPD oder generellen Parteien? Du beobachtest ja, dass Tagespolitische noch viel stärker als ich.
Also es ist eine ganz komplizierte Frage, denn alle alle in der Politik stecken in der Bedeutungsfalle. Nämlich, wir haben 700 Abgeordnete und wir haben jetzt unglaublich viele neue. Also die SPD-Fraktion besteht zur Hälfte aus Leuten, die jetzt gerade in den Bundestag eingezogen sind. Also zu mehr als der Hälfte. Und für alle dreht sich die Welt natürlich erst mal nur um die. Weil die müssen jetzt nach Berlin ziehen, Wohnung aussuchen, Personal und so weiter. Also die haben so viel mit sich erst mal zu tun, dass das nachvollziehbar ist. Und am Ende von so politischen Karrieren, Horst Seehofer und so weiter, die sagen dann schon, naja, im Grunde sitzt man so da und versucht so ein bisschen mitzusteuern, aber im Grunde reitet der Zeitgeist so von alleine und man muss mal gucken, dass man vielleicht das eine oder andere an Raumgewinn noch rausholt. Und es ist ganz verrückt, dass man bei den Jungen zu viel Bedeutung in die eigene Wirkmächtigkeit sieht und bei den Alten dann wieder zu wenig. Dass Horst Seehofer selber irgendwann ausgeblendet hat, wie viel Macht er wirklich hat. Oder Peter Altmaier, der einfach schon mal vom Bundestag 9 Milliarden bewilligt hat für den Stahl-Dings und dann kommt es halt darauf an, dass ihn ein Lobbyist gut überredet und dann macht er halt 400 Millionen für Saarstahl locker oder so, von heute auf morgen. Und das ist total verrückt. Bei Kevin Kühnert ist es eine besonders schwere Frage, da er als kontrolliert, selbstreflexiv, also irgendwie unter Kontrolle beobachtet wird. Nicht so wie alle anderen jungen 48, 49 Jusos, die da jetzt so reingestoppert sind durch Glück und jetzt erst mal durchatmen, puh, ich hab's geschafft. Sondern bei Kühnert sieht man irgendwie, nö, der hat ja vorher schon das Europaparlament ausgeschlagen, hat dann jetzt auch die Wahl zugesteuert und jetzt kann er halt aufgrund eigener Entscheidungspfade so sagen, ich sitze jetzt hier im Bundestag. Und dann ist es halt schon, finde ich so ein bisschen, also du hast ja eben schon gesagt, es ist ein sehr langweiliges Leben und ich fand es sehr beklemmend, Kevin Kühnert bei Lanz zu sehen, wie er so da saß. Auf der einen Seite wird er von der Welt und Robin Alexander und so abgefeiert, weil er hat jetzt 49 Jusos da im Parlament. Das heißt ja, laut Robin Alexander, eine Sperrminorität. Also er könnte jetzt irgendwie Veto-Rechte, kommt schon mal dran, wie gut die organisiert sind, die Jungen, wobei die Jungen der SPD immer super organisiert sind, die Parlamentarier. Und auf der anderen Seite sitzt er eben bei Lanz und weiß das, dass so über ihn geredet wird, sagt dann aber gleichzeitig, also ich habe mit der Sondierung gerade nichts zu tun. Ich könnte jetzt irgendwen anrufen, und den könnte mir dann sagen, was ich Ihnen jetzt hier sagen könnte, Herr Lanz, wie die Stimmung so ist, aber das interessiert mich ja gerade gar nicht. Also er spielt so ein bisschen damit, wo ich dachte, ja okay, dieses Game beherrscht wahrscheinlich unfassbar gut, Lanz so zu teasen und zu wissen, was Robin Alexander da als Kulisse für ihn bedeutet und so. Aber es ist, vielleicht kann ich es mal, weil wir jetzt sehr persönlich über diese Person Kühnert sagen, diese Woche hat sich der Bundestag ja konstituiert. Das heißt, wir haben sie alle mal versammelt gesehen. Und es ist ja ein Tag, das muss man echt mal sich klar machen, wenn in Frankreich die Macht wechselt, oder in England, oder in Tschechien, oder in Polen, oder in Amerika, dann sind das Tage, wo man immer nicht genau weiß, stürmt jetzt irgendwer das Parlament? Brauchen wir jetzt irgendwo die Armee, weil so die Polizei nicht mehr ausreicht, irgendwas, ja? Und in Deutschland ist das so, alle treffen sich, alle wissen, worum es geht, alle sind in Feierstürmung, alle machen nur Selfies. Wolfgang Schäuble hält noch mal eine tolle Rede, dass er jetzt geht, hat jetzt genug geleistet und so, lässt sich da noch mal feiern. Die neue Bundestagspräsidentin kommt. Das ist der einzige Tagesordnungspunkt in drei Stunden. Diese fünf Minuten Verkündung der Wahlergebnisse. Und den Rest der Zeit sitzt man im Grunde in diesen Fraktionssitzen rum. Da gibt es ja dieses ganz tolle Bild, wie die FDP, die immer noch neben der AfD sitzt, zu fünft da irgendwie Wissing, Buschmann, Lindner und dann auf einem AfD-Stuhl an die Fraktion angrenzend Olaf Scholz. Und die sitzen einfach so zehn Minuten, eine Viertelstunde, Halligalli. Alle haben gute Laune. Irgendwer kommt immer mal vorbei, will von Lindner ein Selfie haben und so weiter. Und das ist so, wo ich mir denke, da wäre ich gerne dabei. Das ist der einzige Tag in vier Jahren Parlamentsarbeit, wo ich Politiker sehe, wo ich denke, jetzt wäre ich gerne mal auf der Seite. Einfach so nach zwei Jahren Wahlkampf, alles ist geregelt, alle sind mit allem einverstanden, alle haben sich mit allem abgefunden und machen dann für eine Stunde lang fraktionsübergreifendes Happening einfach so im Bundestag, schon mal in den Stühlen, wo es ansonsten heiß hergeht und so. Das ist aber wirklich der einzige Moment, wo ich das sehe und denke, da wäre ich gerne dabei. Diese Stimmung alle zusammen, das würde ich gerne mitmachen. Alles andere, was ich in der Politik sehe, stößt mich unglaublich ab. Und dazu gehört eigentlich alles, was ich von Kühnert sehe. Und ich sehe aber gleichzeitig, wie virtuos er sich da bewegt und wie toll er das findet, aber...
Also, man kann ihm definitiv ein politisches Talent attestieren. Aber es ist auch dann eine gewisse... Wie soll man sagen? Es ist ein Opportunismus, den man, glaube ich, professionalisieren muss und mit dem man zurechtkommen muss. Und das dauerhaft. Und das war ja bei ihm sehr erstaunlich zu sehen, dass er für Enteignung plädierte. Dass er dieses Sozialismus-Interview in der Zeit gab. Und da ging es ja sogar um die Leute, die sagen, ich hab da noch zwei Wohnungen, die vermiete ich, um mir die Rente zu finanzieren. Also selbst da, sagte er, da greife ich jetzt mal an. Wohl wissend, dass das SPD-Klientel natürlich ist, dass er da angreift. Aber dann, wenn es zu Bundestagswahl kommt, wenn er dann plötzlich der Kandidat ist, dann schlägt er sogar Deutsche Wohnen, Enteignungen und Co. ins Gesicht und so weiter und so fort. Also man sieht da schon, zu was man bereit sein muss. Und ja, also für mich wäre das entsetzlich, das zu machen. Also ich wäre aber auch viel zu undiplomatisch.
Die großen Erfolge von Merkel die letzten 16 Jahre und die kommenden mehr als vier Jahre auch von Olaf Scholz werden ja der oder auch von Markus Söder werden ja einem persönlichen, also einem Persönlichkeitsmerkmal zugeschrieben, zu sagen, ist super politisch engagiert, aber die inhaltliche Ausprägung kann immer wieder neu sein. Also die leidenschaftslose thematische Behandlung und Mehrheitsbeschaffung. Und das ist eben bei Kühnert auch. Also dieses opportunistische ist dieses völlige Austreiben von Leidenschaft. Und das sieht man wieder im Kontrapunkt, wie jetzt auf die jungen Grünen eingeschlagen wird, wenn sie bei Land sitzen.
Wenn da irgendwas Idealistisches aufblitzt, dann wird sofort daraus ein Skandal gemacht. Im Übrigen ganz interessant, dass wenn immer eine Frau irgendwo sitzt und was sagt, dann wird der Shitstorm besonders heftig. Und auch interessant, dass dann nicht einfach der Nachname bei Twitter zum Trend wird, sondern auch immer noch das Frau davor. Also Frau Kök-Türk jetzt in diesem Fall bei Transing Kök-Türk. Also das ist ganz erstaunlich, dass man immer so eine Markierung nochmal vornehmen muss. Also gerade von Leuten auch, die sagen, gendern ist nicht wichtig, das spielt auch eigentlich gar keine Rolle. Aber sobald sie dann ein Angriffsziel haben, nehmen sie wieder so eine Markierung des Weiblichen vor, indem sie so ein Frau davor setzen. Das machen übrigens nicht jetzt nur Rechte und so weiter, sondern das ist generell sehr stark verbreitet, dass man häufig hört, auch wenn so gesprochen wird, ja, Frau Merkel hat gesagt, während man nie sagt, Herr Laschet, Herr Lindner. Es ist immer Lindner, Laschet, Frau Merkel. Also dieses nochmal so ganz darauf abzielen, zeigt sich dann besonders schön in den Twitter-Trends, wo dann Frau Köktürk der Twitter-Trend war.
Kann natürlich sein, dass man, so wie ich eben hier Vornamen vergessen habe, Kanzin heißt sie.
Nein, man würde einfach den Nachnamen bei jedem Mann kennen.
Genau, man lässt einfach den Nachnamen. Das kennt man im beruflichen Umfeld. Man geht ans Telefon und sagt, habe ich mit Dings schon besprochen und sagt einfach den Nachnamen.
Und bei der FAZ ist es doch so gewesen, dass man sich immer nur mit Nachnamen anspricht, oder? Wie war das?
Also man hat auf jeden Fall den Sing-Sang, dass man, ich kenne noch eine Szene, da stehe ich bei Jürgen Kaube im Büro, gehe ans Telefon und sage, ich bin gerade bei Kaube. Und das ist völlig normal, das genau so zu machen. Ich kenne wenige andere Kontexte aus beruflichen Großorganisationen. Aber da fand ich das schon, da habe ich mich auch schnell dran gewöhnt, fand das irgendwie auch lässig, weil das hat so eine gewisse Effizienz. Und an dem, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, dass das in der Politik sich so ein bisschen niederschlägt, in dem man immer wieder von Frau Merkel oder dann auch Frau Güktürk sagt, da hängt ja so eine Konnotation dran, die auch sehr bedeutsam ist, die einfach Philipp Amthor nicht passiert. Er war ja genauso jung und, ich meine, sie ist jetzt nicht im Bundestag, und er war nicht idealistisch, aber er war zumindest jemand, der nach vorne gesprungen ist mit seinen Positionen. Tritt so neben die Spur, fällt irgendwie auf als kleiner Deviantat usw. Tauge nichts oder nur selbst bereicherungsmäßig. Aber da steckt genau diese Konnotation nicht drin, die bei den jungen Frauen immer wieder drinsteckt. Ich verstehe das auch nicht. Auch bei Wieb gewinnt da, der CDU zum Beispiel. Das ist dann immer wieder hier so, da kommt auch noch mal so die Klima Union irgendwie um die Ecke und kriegt dann gleich mal so einen krassen Beschluss dabei. Deutschlandtag der Jungen Union vorgesetzt und so. Also ja, das ist auf jeden Fall auch mal ein großes Thema eigentlich.
Jetzt haben wir schon ein bisschen gelästert über Kevin Kühnert. Aber er sagt, es gibt eigentlich gar keine andere Möglichkeit. Wir gehen jetzt in die erste Folge. Und nun hat man sehr schlecht abgeschnitten. Nahles wankt bereits. Was soll man da eigentlich so machen?
Wir haben zwei Scheißoptionen gehabt. Und wir haben uns jetzt mal für eine davon entschieden. Die eine Scheißoption war, der dumme Papagei von der SPD zu sein, der genau einen Satz im Angebot hat, nämlich raus aus der GroKo und deshalb nicht mehr gehört wird. Und die andere Option ist halt zu sagen, einen taktischen Weg einzuschlagen, um Ergebnis zu kriegen, was wir eigentlich wollen, der aber so intelligent klingt, dass man dem noch irgendwie folgen kann und dass man uns nicht damit abqualifizieren kann, dass die ja sowieso nur das sagen, was sie schon immer sagen und was man von ihnen erwartet und so weiter. Es ist beides Scheiße.
Naja, also das kleinste Übel-Argumentation in der Politik kann ich nicht mehr hören, weder von Politikern noch von Wählern. Ja. So als hätten wir in Deutschland kein Angebot, was Konstruktives zu machen. Das ist natürlich, würde ich sagen, reine interne Legitimations- und Mobilisierungsstrategien. Einfach allen zu sagen, es ist super scheiße, wir müssen jetzt aber den kleineren Scheißhaufen wählen. Und das auch genau so zu sagen.
Ganz richtig. Und er beschreibt dann hier nochmal die neue Strategie. Da steht er vor Journalisten.
Unsere Strategie gehört jetzt für die sozialdemokratische Partei, inhaltliche Konflikte vorzubereiten, die den Unterschied zur Union herausarbeiten und die gleichzeitig die Grundlage für eine neue Wahlkampagne wann auch immer genau bilden können. Denn darauf sind wir im Moment nicht vorbereitet.
Unterschiede herausarbeiten, wenn man sich das Wahlprogramm der SPD ansieht, das jetzige und das davor, dann gibt es da einige Unterschiede, aber keine allzu großen. Die Frage ist immer, setzt sich die SPD mit diesen Punkten durch? Also das war ja bei der großen Koalition jetzt nicht die Frage, dass die SPD keine Ideen hatte und keine Unterscheidungsmerkmale hatte. Die Sache war nur, dass man sie immer, sobald man diesen Koalitionsvertrag nur witterte, sofort sagte, gut, wir werfen das alles über Bord. Oder sogar wenn wir schon der Koalition sind, dann machen wir da noch Zugeständnisse, die wir jetzt gar nicht machen müssten, weil sie gar nicht im Koalitionsvertrag stehen. Also selbst dann auch so Geschichten von Einzelpolitikern, von denen man enttäuscht ist, dass die dann nicht wenigstens für sich noch mal reinen Tisch gemacht haben. Also gerade was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder so was anbelangt, ist dann auch so jemand wie Saskia Esken, die dann immer als eigentlich die Frau aufstand, gegen solche Überwachungsmechanismen und so, die dann sofort bereit ist, da auch ihr Stimmkerzchen abzugeben entsprechend.
Ja, also Saskia Esken, wenn man bedenkt, wie sie angekündigt wurde als die Digitalpolitikern, die alles versteht und so weiter. Und dann ist es ja dann doch so ein Tigersprung und ein bettvolliger Landung gewesen. Ich finde hier bei diesen zwei Clips, das ist ja ganz wunderbar, wenn man die beiden, die letzten beiden mal zusammen nimmt. Zum einen die scheiße Option. Da ist ja Kevin Kühnert jetzt krass inkonsequent, wenn er sagt, wir wollen schon mal Debatten vorbereiten für wenn dann ein Wahlkampf ist. Da kann man ja auch sagen, er wartet auch nicht auf einen Wahlkampf. Es ist alle vier Jahre Wahl. Wahlkampf ist immer, man muss es ja nicht übertreiben wie in Amerika, dass man das so dauerhaft kontrovers macht. Aber wenn Kevin Kühnert hier konsequent wäre und nicht inkonsequent und wirklich mal den sauren Apfel beißen würde, hätte er auch 2018, 2019 entscheiden können, okay, wir haben jetzt dieses Team an der Spitze und jetzt machen wir wieder eine Sammlungsbewegung draus und nehmen alle Assets, um mal so ein Wort zu benutzen, Kevin Kühnert guckt ja vor allem auf Zahlen in seinem Handy, wie stehen wir gerade und so weiter. Dieser Assetgedanke ist ja nicht ganz falsch. Und dann hätte er wirklich in den sauren Apfel beißen müssen und die beiden Politiker, die er am meisten verachtet, nämlich Olaf Scholz und Hubertus Heil, das kommt ja gut raus in der Serie, dass man da sagt, Kevin, reiß dich zusammen. Olavs Thema ist diese internationale Mindeststeuer für Unternehmen. Klemm dich da dahinter, positionier dich auch, mach das sichtbar vor deinen Leuten. Und Hubertus Heil Thema ist Lieferkettengesetz. Und es sind zwei Themen gewesen, an denen diese beiden Politiker aufs Blut fast gekämpft haben, vor allem Hubertus Heil und einfach in schämtlicher Art und Weise von Peter Altmaier und aus der CDU Olaf Scholz auch einfach feilen gelassen worden, obwohl es da Koalitionsverpflichtung gibt. Und da hätte er natürlich krassen Boden gut machen können, um dann für eine Bundestagswahl wirklich gewappnet zu sein. Und das hat aber beides nicht gemacht, weil er wahrscheinlich diese Politiker nicht mag, oder wie auch immer. Ich habe ihm nie zum Lieferkettengesetz und auch nie zu den globalen Mindeststellen gehört.
Beziehungsweise habe ich den Eindruck, dass das nicht seine Themen sind. Er bezieht sich, was als letzte Substanz geblieben ist, er bezieht sich immer wieder auf Hartz IV. Man will es sanktionsfrei machen. Das ist gleich etwas, da kommen wir noch zu. Aber diese anderen Themen spielen keine Rolle. Es ist sowieso eine interessante Doku, insofern als sie uns keine politischen Themen präsentiert. Es geht wirklich nur darum, wie man vielleicht so familiär umgeht, wenn es ganz viele Streitigkeiten gibt. Man hat eine größere Familienfeier. Und man weiß, es treffen diese beiden Onkels aufeinander, die sich nicht mögen. Da kommt diese Schwiegermutter, und da kommt auch noch der Geschiedene und und und. Und dann weiß man schon, es könnte problematisch werden, wo platziert man wen? Und wer sagt doch ab, wer kommt zum Abendessen? Und wer ist nur mittags da? Und so ist das eher wahrzunehmen, wie hier Politik gemacht wird. Es gibt dann mal so den ein oder anderen erhellenden Moment, erhellend aber nicht im positiven Sinne für Kevin Kühnert, wenn er auf Andrea Nahles trifft. Die ist schon angeschlagen. Und er will sie jetzt nochmal dann bei so einer Rede ins Gebet nehmen. Aber zuvor sprechen sie dann in dem Vorzimmer miteinander. Und dann geht es darum, wie jetzt gerade die SPD abgestimmt hat. Wir wissen, es gab im Bundestag Abstimmung zur Ferkelkastration. Das ist ja ein Thema, das Klöckner auch immer wieder verschleppte. Da wird viel Tierleid produziert. Und auch die SPD wollte da treu der Union zur Seite stehen. Aber da haben tatsächlich mal einige Abgeordnete nicht mitgemacht. Und jetzt hören wir uns mal an, wie Kevin Kühnert und unsere gute Frau Nahles, die hoffentlich nicht wiederkommt, darüber sprechen.
Ich bin ja auch nicht für Ferkelkastration, Leute. Aber es ist wirklich so eine gewisse Entscheidung und so weiter.
Ich habe mir die namentliche Abstimmung angeguckt und war echt platt, wie viele Leute von uns abweichend gestimmt haben. Und auch Leute, die sonst nie abweichend stimmen. Wenn ihr euer Gewissen mal entdecken wollt, muss es jetzt bei der Ferkelkastration... Ute Vogt, hat die in ihrem Leben irgendwann mal gegen die Fraktionslinie gestimmt?
Sie war in der letzten Legislatur die Tierschutzbeauftragte.
Ja, das ist für sie alles ein großer Witz. Man kann doch auch einfach mal sagen, ja, offenbar haben sich da Leute auf ihr Gewissen berufen und haben deshalb so abgestimmt. Also klar kann man sich das häufiger wünschen, aber ich glaube, die beiden wünschen sich das ja gar nicht, dass abgewichen wird. Sie finden das jetzt nur kurios, dass es gerade in diesem Fall so ist. Aber eigentlich wollen sie gar nicht, dass jemand je mal abweicht.
Ja, das gehört halt dazu, diese leidenschaftslose Politik, die man da einfach organisieren muss, also wie man vor hundert Jahren schon sagte, wenn man die Gesellschaft demokratisieren möchte, muss man die Parteien wie Armen aufstellen. Und dann ist da krasse Hierarchie. Und dann muss man sich nach oben arbeiten. Und der Königsmord muss dann am Ende auch irgendwie und so. Also das kommt in den sechs Folgen glaube ich gut drüber, wie diese Kühle dazu gehört, alles immer auf diese politische Abrechnung runterzubrechen. Und sich dann vielleicht gar nicht mal darüber zu freuen, dass in irgendeiner Partei dann doch mal nach Gewissen entschieden wurde. Sondern dann hätte man lieber eine Entscheidung klar gegen einen, die dann klar auch schade für die Tiere und so, dass sie damit unterleiden müssen. Aber Hauptsache, man hat ein Thema, an dem man eine Kontroverse aufmachen kann oder so. Also das kommt, glaube ich, ganz super drüber.
Ja, das schlägt dann sogar um in Häme.
Also du glaubst gar nicht. Ute Funk hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, Jungs in der Fraktion, denkt an eure... Und dann... Ihr habt ein Bild gemacht, alle Jungs wurden glatt. Ich war schon bei einer Ferkelkastration, ich komme ja vom Lande dabei. Hey, das ist nicht zu vergleichen.
Ja, alles ein großes Spiel.
Das ist die Anspannung der Chirurgen nach 5 Stunden. Arbeit am lebenden Menschen, da kann man dann nicht den Patienten als Menschen mit Gefühlen sehen. Sondern das war dann einfach Material, an dem man gearbeitet hat.
Wahrscheinlich. Und die Kamera durfte anbleiben. Ich glaube, sie wurde sehr, sehr häufig ausgemacht. Also man sieht tatsächlich eigentlich nur Schnittbilder. Also es ist ganz gut gefilmt, das will ich gar nicht sagen. Aber es sind so klassische Schnittbilder. Also wir sehen halt Leute mit Kaffeetassen reinkommen, rausgehen, sich in Sätzen aufstehen. Aber das ist doch sehr redundant. Zeigt aber, glaube ich, diesen politischen Alltag sehr, sehr gut. In dieser Banalität ist es sehr gut eingefangen. Denn viel mehr ist es dann auch nicht. Ja, dann nach diesen fröhlichen Scherzen trifft man sich im Plenum wieder. Man hat da so einen kleinen Parteitag oder was. Ich glaube, das ist von den Jusos irgendeine Veranstaltung. Und jetzt ist Andrea Nahles da, die dann erst mal eine Rede hält, die wir vernachlässigen sollten. Und jetzt fordert Kevin Kühnert Folgendes von Nahles. Also das erwartet er jetzt von ihr, wenn sie noch bleiben will.
Diese Partei erwarten Antworten auf die großen Fragen unserer Zeit. Sie erwarten, dass unsere Parteispitze bereit ist, sich mit den Großen, den Mächtigen, den Reichen in dieser Gesellschaft anzulegen. Das ist die Erwartung, an der wir dich und die anderen messen werden.
Ich denke, das ist nur Rhetorik. Das ist nichts mehr, was Kevin Kühnert wirklich glaubt. Dass er sich noch mal mit den Reichen und Mächtigen anlegt.
Vor allem diese Parteitagsreden, auch die von Kühnert, sind immer abgesprochen. Dass er jetzt nicht Olaf Scholz den Text vorerschickt, aber mit Nahles und dieser Art von Angriffe, das habe ich auch noch mal selbst erlebt. Andrea Nahles führt das Arbeitsministerium, der DGB macht irgendwas, die CDU macht einen Aufschlag, bei dem Nahles erst mal nicht öffentlich dazu Stellung nehmen kann, weil Koalitionsfrieden, also kloppt da die IG Metall groß drauf, kündigt das Andrea Nahles vorher an, dann weiß sie Bescheid, okay, einen Tag wählt jetzt der Winter IG Metall, dann versuche ich die Wogen wieder zu kletten. Und so ist das hier auch. Also diese Parteitagsreden sind ein viel zu abgekatertes Ding dafür, dass da so unglaublich viele Journalisten so viel rausziehen wollen immer. Das ist wirklich Banane.
Die Europawahl stand an. Katharina Barley war ja die Spitzenkandidatin. Und du hast jetzt gerade schon zwei Sachen angesprochen. Einmal das Lieferkettengesetz, was für Heil sehr wichtig war. Und dann die Mindeststeuer, die globale, was für Scholz das große Thema war. Was ja beides auch europäische Themen sind. Und Kühnert greift sie nicht auf. Behauptet aber hier zur Europawahl Folgendes.
Nicht nur, weil wir dieses Jahr eine Europawahl haben, von der ich überzeugt bin, dass es die wichtigste Wahl ist, die wir mittlerweile so im Angebot von Wahlen haben. Und das merkt man auch. Das ist drei Monate vorher. Und wir reden über Europapolitik im Moment.
Nee, das merkt man nicht, dass das die wichtigste Wahl ist. Er wird wohl Recht haben. Aber das merkt man nicht. Und das merkt man bei ihm auch nicht. Und das merkt man eigentlich auch nicht bei der SPD.
Ja, vor allem er hat den Posten von Bali angeboten bekommen, hat ihn ausgeschlagen. Man hat nicht genau verstanden, warum. Er hat es auch nie erklärt. Und hier sowas zu sagen, ist einfach so.
Ja, Bali, aber dann noch mal.
Die Menschen begreifen, dass das eine Europawahl ist wie keine andere zuvor, dass es eine Richtungsentscheidung ist. Denn Europa ist kein Zustand.
Kennst du den Zeitpodcast Alles gesagt, wo man so lange miteinander spricht, bis der Interviewter irgendwann ein Codewort sagt und dann ist vorbei? Und da empfehle ich noch mal allen, das habe ich damals auch im Aufwarnpodcast ausführlich besprochen, das Gespräch mit Katharina Bali, wie sie da drei, vier Stunden lang und so weiter. Und die ganze Zeit geht es nur, ich habe so ein glückliches Leben. Ja, dann bin ich ja ganz früh Richterin geworden. Und dann habe ich da aber noch viel bessere Angebote ausgeschlagen, aus der privaten Juristerei und so weiter. Und dann wurde ich von der SPD gefragt, also sie hatte nie so einen Dauner drin irgendwie. Sie konnte also ihren Leidenschaftsakku, so wie man das jetzt bei Lanz gesehen hat, von den Jungen Grünen nie so richtig aufladen, sondern ist immer nur mitgeschleift worden. Und das ist das Ergebnis davon, solche Sätze. In dieser, wie soll man sagen, fast Leblosigkeit, das sozusagen, dass das alles ganz wichtig ist und so. Am Ende, ja, das ist kein Skin in the Game, würde man sagen.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und was ihr da sagt, ist auch eine solche Banalität, die auch noch nicht mal wahr ist. Also es ist einfach nicht so, dass die wichtigste Europawahl denn je ist. Also warum soll die das jetzt sein? Also man kann jetzt sagen, ja, das ist sie, aber dann müsstet ihr was ganz anderes machen, als das, was ihr da anbietet. Also das stimmt ja hinten und vorne nicht. Jetzt zwei politische Jugendtalente treffen aufeinander. Kevin Kühnert und Amthor, die sind in irgendeiner Sendung zu Gast, sollen sich da ein bisschen kappeln. Spielt auch jetzt keine Rolle, aber hier sehr verräterisch. Man muss es ein bisschen jetzt raushören. Amthor fragt Kühnert, warum jetzt da das Kamerateam dabei sei, ob da irgendwas porträtiert wird oder für einen Beitrag. Und jetzt ist aber Kühnert stolz und sagt, nee, hier ist eine Serie, wird das hier. Und dann die Reaktion von Amthor.
Was machst du mit dem NDR?
Das wird mir Langzeitdoku.
Ach so, ich hab die auch begangen, aber ich bin dann immer noch in der Herde.
Unsere Zielsetzung ist, bis nach deinem Bundestagswahl.
Ja, das wäre spannend, wenn wir uns dabei ausreifen, wenn du deine Erfahrungen ein bisschen auf der Kabel rumlaufen findest.
Du setzt selber die Grenzen. Also wenn ich sage, ist nicht, dann ist nicht.
Ach so, ich hab da auch mal so eine Anfrage. Also ich würde mal sagen, nee, da ist eher keine Anfrage gekommen.
Wenn er möchte jetzt Co-Protagonist sein da?
Nee, er würde gerne, wenn er mal eine Anfrage bekommt. Also er behauptet hier, er hätte auch schon eine Anfrage, aber er sei da noch nicht. Also er muss jetzt ja irgendwas entgegennehmen, weil er wurde bislang immer nur porträtiert und beitragen. Und er sagte, naja, das wird eine Langzeit-Doku und das wird noch bis zur Bundestagswahl und darüber hinaus und so. Und jetzt muss er natürlich sagen, ja, ich hab da auch Anfragen und jetzt müssen wir uns mal austauschen, wie das denn so ist, wenn man so gefilmt wird, mit dem Mikro immer rumläuft. Sehr, sehr schön. Wir sind jetzt auf dem SPD-Parteitag. Es geht um ein neues Programm und die Frage der Sanktionen, weil es immer noch Formulierungen da gibt, die doch so lesbar sind, dass man da ganz klar sagen kann, nee, Sanktionen werden nicht im Hartz-IV-Regime abgeschafft. Und das fällt jetzt Leuten im Umfeld von Kühnert auf. Und jetzt wird noch mal heftig gestritten mit Heil kurz. Und dann aber versucht man sich so informell zu einigen. Und zwar steht man da zusammen, man bleibt bei den Formulierungen weitgehend. Und dann gibt es da folgenden Moment.
Überlegt noch mal bitte.
Wir machen hier heute kein Gesetz. Das ist jetzt ein Vertrauensmoment. Einfach so, dass wir uns jetzt hier in die Augen gucken und sagen, wir meinen damit das Gleiche.
Mit jeder Zeit ist okay, glaube ich.
Mussten wir jederzeit sicher sein.
Also wir sind kommend von der Position, die die Partei vor zwei Jahren hatte. Wenn das null war, sind wir jetzt bei 90 angekommen.
Hm, der Vertrauensmoment. Also man schaut sich immer an die Augen und man meint was anderes als das, was vielleicht da steht oder auch interpretierbar wäre. Wir werden sehen, ob dieser Vertrauensmoment dann hält, wenn wir uns das Koalitionspapier ansehen. Man darf gespannt sein.
Als ich die Situation gehört habe, habe ich so gedacht. Und vor allem, weil da noch so die jungen Stimmen zu hören waren, die da irgendwie so mit dabei sein dürfen.
Auch mit der, das ist ja so, dass man jetzt immer den anderen bestätigt mit voll. Kennst du das?
Ja, das auch. Voll. Ja, es gibt ganz viele, da können wir auch mal drüber reden, wie man das Wort Halt mittlerweile benutzt und so weiter. Voll. Voll und Halt und Fette, vor allem Fette Probleme von Baerbock. Diese Szene, wenn die so zusammenstehen, es ist Parteitag, alle Umstehenden, die auch noch, weil sie so fachlich damit zu tun haben und sich schon immer dafür engagiert haben, dass dieser Sanktionsding jetzt fällt, sind dann durch Zufall irgendwie dabei, wenn man heilt gerade das mit dem Kühnert, und man spürt so ein bisschen, jetzt geht es gerade um was. Das ist jetzt die Situation, der Moment, der Macht irgendwie. Und irgendwie hört man aber bei Kühnert auch raus, kommt Leute, ich weiß, hier ist eine Kamera, und ich weiß, es ist Parteitag, und die sind gerade viele, die finden das so cool, dass wir gerade mit dem Bundesminister sprechen, aber es ist am Ende doch nur ein Parteitagsbeschluss. Und machen wir mal nicht zu viel jetzt, also wo Kühnert das auch so ein bisschen gerade reflektiert, dass es auch, man soll jetzt in der Albernheit nicht übertreiben. Sagen wir es mal so.
Sein Pressesprecher Benny Köster übt sich derweil in Dialektik. Jetzt wird mal gesagt, wie kann man denn eigentlich das jetzt rechtfertigen, dass man zum einen diese treuanischen Pferde da reingeschoben hat, also oder glaubte sie, reinzuschieben mit Esken und Nova Bo. Und jetzt aber hat man da einen Kanzlerkandidat, den man auf keinen Fall als Parteivorsitzenden wollte, nämlich Olaf Scholz. Folgende Argumentation.
Ich würde es auch ganz praktisch machen, warum ist es denn okay, ihn jetzt zu unterstützen? Weil er ja, du sprachst davon, er muss sich weit das Vertrauen erarbeiten. Er hat damit aber ja schon angefangen. Er hat seine Niederlage voll akzeptiert, hat sich ins Team reingestellt.
Die schwarze Null war sofort passé, als es notwendig war.
Die Erzählung muss sein, wir haben letztes Jahr im Dezember beim Parteitag diesen Laden verändert. Und zwar so doll verändert, wie die SPD sich seit wahrscheinlich Jahrzehnten nicht verändert hat. Und Teil dieser Veränderung ist auch, dass es eigentlich kein Widerspruch ist, mit der Parteispitze Norbert Walter-Borjans und Saskia Esken den Kanzlerkandidaten Olaf Scholz auszudrücken.
Mit Hegel gesagt, das Wahre ist das Ganze, oder? Wie deutest du das?
Ich verstehe nicht, warum die SPD sich so schwer tut damit. Nur weil die CDU auch immer Parteivorsitz und Regierungsamt in einer Hand haben will, weil denen das so wichtig ist, macht man das hier auch. Die Grünen haben eine ganz andere Tradition, und die finde ich auch viel schlüssiger. Und man muss ja auch ehrlich sagen, die Strategie, dass Kühnert dann bei Land sitzt und einfach auf den Vorwurf, der dann immer wieder kommt, also für die Partei nicht gut genug, aber für das Land schon, dann einfach zu sagen, ach, das haben sie jetzt schon tausendmal gefragt, sie reizen mich damit nicht mehr, statt einfach eine innerliche Antwort zu geben, die ja sein muss, da finde ich. Und es ist mir ein bisschen unklar, warum die SPD nicht einfach sagt, unsere Geschichte ist, dass wir hier für die Arbeiter kämpfen. Wir sind eigentlich ein Kampfapparat. Nur die Regierung ist halt einfach die Verwaltungsspitze Deutschlands. Dass wir da nicht unsere besten Kämpfer hinschicken, sondern Leute, die für dafür dann besonders qualifiziert sind. Und dann kann man ja herausarbeiten, was dann Albrecht von Lucke so schön dargestellt hat, mit das, was als Olaf Scholz Schwäche galt, war plötzlich seine Stärke. Nämlich dieses zurückhaltende, seriöse jetzt von Merkel lernen. Und das ist ja richtig so. Die SPD und die CDU sollen sich grundsätzlich verschieden sein. Die CDU ist so ein Karriere- und Rekrutierungsapparat, der dann am Ende irgendwie für alle politisch gescheiterten, immer noch ökonomische Möglichkeiten der Bereicherung bereithält. Und die SPD ist halt einfach mal so ein Kampfapparat. Und dass die sich dafür entscheiden, nicht ihren obersten Kämpfer in den Regierungsapparat zu schicken, das begegnet einem ja immer wieder, wenn man so denkt, soll Marcel Fratscher jetzt EZB-Bundesbank-Chef werden? Wo ich mir denke, von mir aus ist er qualifiziert, aber das wäre doch irgendwie schade. Wir haben ihn doch so als Kämpfer von so einer Institution, hoch angesehen, akademisch total drin. Warum sollten wir ihn jetzt an die Bundesbank abgeben? Das kann doch jemand machen, der eben Bundesbanker ist. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Warum sollte die SPD denn ihren größten Kämpfer an der Spitze, und da will man die großen Kämpfer haben, ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass Saskia Essen und Nova große Kämpfer sind, aber da wünscht man sich die Kampfmetallik.
Die könnten viel mehr machen.
Genau, die könnten da ja mal richtig reinkämpfen so im System. Und dann trotzdem sagen, als Kanzler eignen wir uns nicht, wir sind einfach zu leidenschaftlich, wir kämpfen zu sehr für die Arbeit. Wir wissen aber genau, in der Regierung muss ein Interessensausgleich zwischen allen stattfinden. So wie Schäuble ja wieder gesagt hat, ja wir repräsentieren hier unsere Partei, aber wir vertreten alle. Und das können wir als Kämpfer nicht. Dafür sind wir auch zu sehr SPD-Kämpfer und deswegen nominieren wir jetzt Olaf Scholz. Und sowas kann man doch einfach erklären. Und daraus gewinnt sich doch auch nochmal ein bisschen Unterstützung und so. Und das habe ich nicht verstanden, warum sie da so zaghaft waren und diese Frage immer lieber abgewehrt haben, als einfach zu sagen, ja, weil Norbert Waderborns ist halt einfach ein Kämpfer. Der wäre in der Regierung falsch. Dafür ist Olaf Scholz dann richtig. Der hat sich da bewährt. Das finde ich immer gut, wenn ich bei der Bundesbank auch. Man rekrutiert aus dem eigenen Hause. Das macht die Bundesregierung gerade. Der Kanzler kommt aus der vorherigen Regierung. Er war nämlich da Minister. Das ist den Deutschen sowieso immer super wichtig. Annalena Baerbock kann ja nicht Kanzlerin sein. Sie hat ja noch nie regiert. Das ist halt bei Olaf Scholz anders. Und es gibt halt die Kämpfer in der Partei. So war es ja früher eigentlich bei der SPD auch. Es gab immer den Kampfapparat SPD und daneben halt die Regierung. Und die standen sich dann selber immer ein bisschen auf den Füßen. Warum sie sich da so sehr in die Falle der CDU beteiligt?
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein bisschen so diese Falle, die Journalisten stellen, in die sie immer eintappen. Denn Journalisten fordern immer eine Geschlossenheit ein, die einfach nicht gegeben ist, sobald man es mit einer größeren Gruppe zu tun hat. Beziehungsweise nur faschistoide Gruppen sind ganz geschlossen. Also das kann gar nicht gegeben sein. Deshalb ist das eigentlich ein doch sehr wichtiges Merkmal von Parteien. Nicht abgeschlossen zu sein, unabgeschlossen zu sein, nicht für alles offen zu sein, dann ist man nicht ganz dicht. Aber zumindest doch, genau diese Debatten zu haben. Und die haben ja eigentlich dann doch zu wenig stattgefunden. Also da hatte man sich ja von Esken, gerade auf dem digitalen Sektor, viel mehr erwartet. Auch von Nuwabo. Ja, wir wissen, er will Steuerschlupflöcher schließen. Aber ist das jetzt die einzige Art, wie wir über Steuern noch nachdenken könnten, dass es diese Schlupflöcher gibt? Schön, gut. Das ist aber quasi jetzt Bekämpfung von Kriminalität. Aber auch sonst gibt es ja steuerlich einiges zu tun. Ich wäre zum Beispiel mal für eine Vereinfachung der Steuererklärung. Also die Sache ist ja die, dass offenbar Steuerberater eine sehr gute Lobby haben im Bundestag und auch bei den Parteien im bürgerlichen Lager wie im linken Lager. Dass da also nicht drüber nachgedacht wird, warum kann es dann nicht mal leicht gemacht werden. Ich finde, es ist ein großes Versäumnis von links. Also damit meine ich jetzt Linkspartei, Grüne und SPD. Damals diese Idee von März mit der Bierdeckelsteuererklärung. Meine Steuererklärung muss auf den Bierdeckel passen. Nicht aufzugreifen, sondern sich nur darüber lustig zu machen. Ja, der will natürlich hier die Reichen entlasten. Natürlich will der das. Aber die Idee, dass man die Steuererklärung arg vereinfachen könnte, die ist doch eine gute. Wie progressiv das dann angelegt ist, das ist ja wieder eine ganz andere Frage. Aber die Vereinfachung, die wäre gegeben. Und das ist nicht eine Frage jetzt von, weil das hört man jetzt schon dann, ja, wir müssen das erst mal digitalisieren. Nee, es sind einfach viel zu komplexe Steuersysteme, die geschaffen wurden, die vollkommen ineffizient auch sind, die extrem viel Zeit und Geld fressen für Angestellte, für Selbstständige und auch gerade für kleine Selbstständige. Und damit sind jetzt alle gemeint, vom Dönerbodenbesitzer über den Friseur bis zum Handwerk. Also da ist all das zu nennen, was man machen könnte. Und dass man diese Dinge nicht aufgegriffen hat und da auch mal ein bisschen für Trouble innerhalb der eigenen Reihen sorgt. Das ist das große Versäumnis. Und dann würde ich dir dazu stimmen, wäre Scholz gar nicht so die Frage gewesen.
Ja, deswegen, weil das du gerade beschrieben hast, deswegen habe ich 2005 Merkel gewählt. Um es hier zu gestehen, das einzige Mal, weil ich diese Idee mit den drei Stufen Einkommenssteuer und so weiter, ich habe es damals auch nicht geblickt, aber der Vorwurf aus der SPD, das macht ja der Professor aus Heidelberg und so mit dieser Idee, den fand ich so daneben, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ne und jetzt denke ich mir auch wieder, ja genau, klar, es war eine CDU-Vorschlag, was die Steuerbeträge angeht, aber die Idee ist keinerlei zu machen.
Ich hoffe, du sagst kein Linker, wie wir jetzt immer noch mehr wissen. Also der ist ja auch auf seinem eigenen Verschwörungsbund.
Aber die Idee ist einfach zu machen, liegt halt nahe. Und ich hätte zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt Kevin Kühnert gewesen wäre, der Norbert Walter Borjans, darauf vorbereitet, welche Idee schlägst du denn jetzt vor, um mich ja Parteivorstand zu werden? Ich sag, komm, ein innerliches Thema, mutest du dir zu. Wir wollen das deutsche Steuersystem umstellen von Arbeit auf Unternehmensgewinne. Wir bleiben dabei, Produktivität abzuschöpfen, aber eben nicht beim Arbeitnehmer, sondern beim Unternehmen am Ende. Und damit entlasten wir die Arbeitnehmer und schaffen trotzdem das Geld dran, nämlich bei den Unternehmen. Das steht ja eh an, gerade auch durch den demografischen Wandel. Sehr viel weniger Arbeiter, sehr viel mehr Automatisierung und so weiter die nächsten 20 Jahre. Das wäre doch ein Moment gewesen, um jetzt einfach zu sagen, das ist jetzt unsere Idee. Und damit gehen wir jetzt rein. Da kann man dann auch wieder Richard-David-Brecht-Podcasts der letzten 10 Jahre und so weiter nehmen, falls man da irgendwie Argumente braucht. Da wird ja sowas auch argumentiert. Also da so inhaltlich ideenlos zu sein und dass Kevin Kühnert später dann auch wieder sagte, ich habe die beiden ja nur in der Methode vorbereitet. Ich habe hier ja nichts Inhaltliches mitgegeben.
Genau, er sagte ihm ja auch dann, es gibt so einen kleinen Beratermoment, da ist er dann, bevor Esken und Nobobo raus müssen und sich präsentieren müssen, sagt er, ihr müsst Lust ausstrahlen. Es ist also keine inhaltliche Beratung. Man hätte auch mal das Thema Umsatzsteuer, Mehrwertsteuer aufgreifen können. Das ist eigentlich ganz wunderbar. Erstmal könnte man damit alle Haushalte entlasten und gerade die ärmeren Haushalte, wenn die alle weniger zahlen müssten, wenn das wegfallen würde. Und die Erhebung ist halt extrem kompliziert mit Vorsteuer und, und, und. Das ist so ein Unsinn, dass es auf diese Weise gemacht wird. Also da wäre viel zu tun, aber greift man nicht auf. Wir hören noch einen letzten Clip. Da geht es darum, dass Kühnert dann mal Scholzwoll treffen muss. Und wir hören hier, es stand tatsächlich mal dieses rot-rot-grüne Gespenst im Raum.
So, und dann brauche ich Anfang August ein Frühstück mit Olaf. Naja, also erstmal abschätzen, was will er. Also es ist die Koalitionsfrage, würde ich gerne noch mal mit ihm diskutieren. Also ich weiß tatsächlich gar nicht, was er darüber denkt. Ansonsten sagt er sein Umfeld immer, Only Nixon can go to China. Das ist dann immer ihr Augenzwinkermoment für Rot-Rot-Grün. Also ich glaube, er ist da wirklich so wenig ideologisch, dass er sich das grundsätzlich auch vorstellen kann.
Ja, das hat aus Gründen dann nicht stattfinden können. Ich bin da auch unsicher, ob das tatsächlich dann die Mächtigen in der SPD so mitgegangen wären. Also ja, bei Scholz kann das gut sein. Bei den anderen frage ich mich da mitunter. Gut, aber diese Sache ist dann schon passé, denn wir wissen, wie die Wahl ausgegangen ist. Und diese Koalition hätte keine Mehrheit gehabt.
Ich hätte ja gerne nochmal in einer alternativen Realität diese Reportage jetzt gesehen. Aber unter der Maßgabe, es wäre ein Wahlkampf zwischen Habeck und Söder geworden. Und die beiden hätten es deutschlandweit ausgefochten mit einem Feuerwerk, wie wir uns alle nicht vorstellen können. Weil auch Habeck festgestellt hat, ach so macht der Wahlkampf. Da muss ich mal mithalten. Und dann hätte er richtig tief in die Trickkiste greifen müssen. Und dann wäre nämlich nichts übrig geblieben von dieser SPD. Was ist jetzt wie es ist? Wir haben keine schwarz-grüne Koalition. Was bedeutet, und das hat Habeck auch nochmal ganz deutlich gesagt, das hören wir nachher, die Schuldenbremse bleibt im Grundgesetz. Denn die hätte man nur mit der CDU ändern können. Also diesen Eingriff ins Grundgesetz hätte man nur da machen können. Dann hätte es auch Sinn gehabt, darüber zu argumentieren. Jetzt ist die CDU nicht an der Regierung, wird sich da auch nicht breitschlagen lassen. Sondern die wird jetzt eher so zermetzelt von der FDP, die dann noch mal die Sitzordnung ändert und solche Kingerlizien. Aber die Grundgesetzänderung steht wohl nicht an. Was grundsätzlich jetzt die Frage stellt, wie kriegen dann die Grünen ihren sozial-ökologischen Wandel finanziert? Und das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an. Und da bin ich sehr froh, dass Jens Südekum mir auf Twitter gestern noch mal Hinweise gab, wo Ausführungen von ihm zu finden sind. Da hätte man fast ein Meme starten können, denn ich hatte so einen Tweet gemacht, wie ich bei YouTube suche, unsere Südekum-Transformationsfonds. Also die zentrale Idee gerade, die hinter verschlossenen Türen natürlich durchgediskutiert wird, wie finanzieren wir jetzt die, und die Beträge gehören mir gleich, 500, 800, 860 Milliarden Euro. Und man findet nichts dazu. Also wenn man auf YouTube Südekum und Transformationsfonds sucht, kriegt man als ersten Vorschlag, weil es keine Videos dazu gibt, irgendwas, was YouTube meint, passt zu dir selber als User. Und da hat einfach jeder einen anderen absurden Vorschlag gekriegt. Und das war ganz witzig, weil dann relativ viele auf Twitter so ihre Screenshots geschickt hatten. Also bei mir war es Studium abgebrochen, nach vier Jahren und so weiter. Und dann so ein ganz aufgelöstes Mädchen, das irgendwie im Screenshot da sitzt und halt zehn Minuten darüber redet, wie sie ihr Studium abgebrochen hat, wo der Südekum drunter schrieb. Also damit habe ich nichts zu tun. Hier, ich schlage dir dieses Video vor.
Lass mich da kurz einhaken, denn das ist auch meine Erfahrung jetzt mit YouTube. Und vielleicht geht es unserem Publikum ähnlich. Der Algorithmus wird schlechter oder hat irgendetwas vor, von dem ich noch nicht weiß, was es sein soll. Denn ich suche manchmal auch sehr gezielt Dinge, zum Beispiel Vorträge von irgendwelchen Ökonomen und bekomme vielleicht dann einen angezeigt, der gerade vor drei Tagen gehalten wurde. Und darunter aber bekomme ich dann Videos angezeigt, die auch nichts mit meiner sonstigen Suche zu tun habe. Also ich akzeptiere ja, wenn der Algorithmus sagt, aber hier haben wir schon wieder ein neues Video von Dolly Parton. Da würde ich ja auch draufklicken. Aber ich bekomme tatsächlich so Sachen angezeigt oder so randständig, so absurd, dass ich sagen würde, da würde ich ja in 100 Jahren nicht draufklicken. Und es ist doch irgendwas, was dahinterstecken muss. Also warum ist das so?
Sie haben ihre Algorithmen nicht mehr unter Kontrolle. Und der politische Druck, das hören wir auch nachher noch, ist unfassbar hoch auf diese Häuser. Also nicht nur Facebook stand jetzt vor Gericht im Kongress, sondern auch TikTok, auch YouTube, auch Snapchat. Und da geht es gerade richtig zur Sache. Aber das heben wir uns mal für später auf.
Sag noch gerade, wer ist Jens Südekum?
Jens Südekum ist ein VWL-Professor in Düsseldorf, der dort lehrt und forscht, mit relativ jungen Jahren Professor wurde, so in seinen 30ern. Und ganz verrückterweise immer wieder präsent ist in diesen ganzen journalistisch-publikistischen Ökonomiediskussionen heute, obwohl er gar nicht, was eigentlich typisch wäre für diese Protagonisten, so ein Institut leitet. IFO-Institut, Weltwirtschaftsinstitut, DIW oder so.
Was vielleicht ein großer Vorteil ist, dass man dann noch mal anders draufblickt. Und er ist ja auch sehr aktiv bei Twitter.
Genau, da ist er sehr aktiv. Das FAZ-Ökonomen-Ranking führt allerdings immer so einen Professor aus der Schweiz an, den auch niemand kennt, auch vom Namen her nicht. Und die machen ja immer so eine Gewichtung aus so und so viel akademischer Arbeit, publizistischer und politischer und so. Und entwichten die das immer. Und der Typ, das Namen ich jetzt auch nicht weiß, kann man mal gucken, das FAZ-Ökonomen-Ranking 2021 wird an einem angeführt, der zu 95% seine Punktzahl auf dem akademischen Feld herausholt. Und damit alle anderen, Fratscher, Hüter und so weiter, auf die Plätze verweist. Also das ist ganz komisch, wie die das da werten. Aber naja, also Südekum hat sich der jedenfalls präsent gemacht. Und mit ihm habe ich auch schon mal eine Stunde gesprochen vor einem Jahr, beispielsweise. Das ist die Nullnummer des Fernsehpodcasts. Eine Stunde mit Südekum. So, und bevor wir zu Südekum hören wir uns nur einen Clip an, der mal den Vlog setzt. Denn sehr viele fragen sich ja, was soll das überhaupt mit dieser Schuldenbremse? Und da gibt es von Fabio Di Masi, wir haben ja seinen Abschiedsbrief gelesen, nicht mehr MDB, nicht mehr bei der Linken da tätig, einen ganz guten Tweet dazu. Er antwortet nämlich auf Sebastian Dulien, der fragt, für Kritik an der Schuldenbremse hier auf Twitter, kommt inzwischen ein Shitstorm ähnlich dem, der folgt, wenn man Bitcoin kritisiert. Was sagt uns das? Da schreibt Fabio Di Masi, dass einige weniger an der Schuldenbremse gut verdienen müssen. Das ermöglicht diese Public-Private-Partnerships. Das muss man ganz deutlich sagen. Da gibt es auch von der letzten Woche die Fernsehmomente, wo ich auch noch mal das alles so zusammenbaue, aus Lindners Auftritten jetzt und so. Schuldenbremse heißt, Deutschland macht eine Schuldenbremse, die dann gleichzeitig für ganz Europa gilt, sodass man sich als Hegemon, lokaler Hegemon, auch wenn das auf Kosten der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit im Systemschwätzstreit mit China und USA geht, aber in Europa hat man sich erst mal gut platziert. Und in dem Moment, wo man den Staat rausnimmt als Finanzie ist man als privater Finanzie drin, was bedeutet, alle Renditen sind privatisiert. So, und wenn wir jetzt eine große sozial-ökologische Wende machen, ist ja wirklich die Frage, wollen wir das denn alles als private Infrastruktur oder nicht besser als öffentliche? Wenn wir jetzt an Strom zu Hause, die Internetdatenstruktur, die wir dafür brauchen, Mobilität, Verkehr, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, wir verabschieden uns vom individuellen Auto, das war natürlich alles unser privates Gut, da haben wir uns selbst viel verschuldet und so weiter. Das macht der Deutsche dann so. Aber wenn wir jetzt neue Mobilitätsformen haben, wollen wir die wirklich alle in privater Hand? Oder könnten wir das nicht einfach öffentlich machen? Und da will ich nur einen Clip von Christian Lindner spielen, der das so ein bisschen darstellt. Er sitzt bei Illner, sitzt Norbert Röttgen gegenüber, der ihm, wie soll man sagen, hechelnd, lechzend, ja, das private Geld, der private Renditen immer nur zustimmt bei allem, was Lindner jetzt sagt. Und das Einzige, was Lindner hier verschweigt, ist das Wort Rendite. Denn zu privaten Investitionen gehört immer auch die private Rendite. Aber da ist unser Publikum aufgeklärt genug, das kann jeder eins und eins zusammenzählen.
Ich will nur sagen, dass dieses Instrument, private Investitionen mit privatem Kapital zu ermöglichen, bislang in Deutschland nicht hinreichend genutzt worden ist. Nehmen wir etwa die Lebensversicherungen, die viele Milliarden Euro haben. Die dürfen ihr Kapital für bestimmte Aufgaben nicht einsetzen, aufgrund von regulatorischen Vorgaben. Wenn es nun gelingt, diese Regulatorik zu verändern, indem vielleicht auch der Staat bestimmte Absicherungen, die gar kein Geld kosten, breit stellt, dann fließt viel Geld. Und zwar nicht nur zum Vorteil der wichtigen ökologischen Vorhaben, sondern auch um eine rentierlichere Verzinsung für die Altersversorgung der Menschen zu erreichen.
Eine öffentliche Mittel, das sind ja dann private Mittel.
So steht es in dem Sondierungspapier, dass wir neben der Schwerpunktsetzung im Öffentlichen... Aber öffentliche Mittel brauchen wir natürlich auch.
Ja, da hakt sich ja auch noch mal ein öffentliche Mittel. Und Rotkin ist so froh, er sagt ja nur noch, mhm, mhm, mhm. Also ich finde Rotkin ja auch ganz furchtbar. Das ist ja für mich auch jemand, da renne ich schreiend weg. Und er hat also so Angst, dass jetzt der Staat irgendetwas für seine Bürger tun könnte, für seine Klientel. Was dann nicht nochmal abgreifbar ist für Unternehmer. Also das ist so perfide eigentlich, wenn du das siehst. Und es fällt jetzt, wenn man ökonomisch unbeleckt ist, gar nicht so oft. Sondern die reden dann so ein bisschen, ach ja, schön, dann wird doch allen ein bisschen geholfen. Gibt so einen Anschub für Investitionen und passt doch alles.
Genau, man muss das einmal so raus isolieren und dann hört man auch, worum es hier geht. Denn das Christian Lindner jetzt, die jungen Arbeitnehmer, die dann auch mal ihr Geld für später in private Fonds und so weiter. Ja, aber die Rendite fällt eben nicht nur für die ab, sondern für alle Eigner. Und da spielen nun die Arbeitnehmer, die irgendwie für später vorsorgen, wirklich eine kleine Rolle. Es sind vor allem große institutionelle Anleger, die dann da die große Rendite erwirtschaften wollen.
Und Baerbock hat es gecheckt, aber Ilne offenbar nicht.
Ilne, das ist ganz erstaunlich. Ilne hat es wirklich nicht gecheckt. Es kam bei YouTube dann auch die Diskussion auf, warum denn nicht. Na ja, sie ist mit René Obermann und so verheiratet. Das ist nun wirklich mal mitten im Herz der Privatökonomie. Die Frage, die ich mir immer stelle, das hören wir gleich bei Habeck ein bisschen anders, warum ist Baerbock da so zurückhaltend? Und sagt das nicht ganz klar, dass es eher darum geht, Werte zu schaffen. Ich finde ja immer...
Das könnte man ja auch mal erklären. Also das kriegt man ja in 60 Sekunden hin, dass man das mal so ausbuchstabiert, was Lindner da meint und was wir eigentlich meinen und warum das, was wir meinen, besser ist.
Genau, also den eigentlichen Widerstreit kann man ja durchaus mal formulieren. Und ich finde auch, dadurch, dass die CDU jetzt gerade auf der Suche ist, was heißt eigentlich konservativ? Mein Vorschlag wäre immer zu sagen, also konservativ heißt einfach nur Vermögen bewahren. Nicht immer so ein Wertkanon oder so ein Scheiß, sondern einfach es geht darum, es sind Vermögensbestände da und die müssen erhalten werden. Und wir haben ja gestern erst wieder so eine Aufzählung gekriegt, wie alt eigentlich das deutsche Vermögen ist. Also weniger als ein Viertel, 23 Prozent des Vermögens, das heute privat gehalten wird, bei den 1000 reichsten Familien ist jünger als 1950 entstanden. Alles andere hat wirklich auch dunkle historische Mental über sich geschwungen und in deren Sicht gäbe es hier doch einiges zu sagen. Aber gut, gehen wir mal hier in die aktuelle Diskussion und fragen uns, wie viel Geld geht jetzt eigentlich dazu?
Vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung dazu, weil du das jetzt so schön herausgearbeitet hast. Es gibt ja einen Beitrag zur Ideologiekritik von Adorno, wo er sagt, es gibt Momente, in denen eine Ideologie so fest verankert ist schon und auch das System so sehr gefestigt ist, dass man dann tatsächlich diese Kui Bono-Frage stellen darf. Also wer profitiert jetzt eigentlich noch davon mit dieser Schuldenbremse? Wer profitiert noch von der schwarzen Null und so weiter? Und du hast sie jetzt beantwortet. Naja, es gibt da schon noch Gruppen, die PPP-Projekte und so. Die profitieren noch genau davon. Und die vertritt jetzt ein Röttgen oder ein Lindner.
Genau, die beiden. Und in dem Clip sieht man ja auch so ein bisschen, wie Röttgen weiß, ich habe die Wahl verloren. Aber du kümmerst dich gerade um meine Klientel, oder? Also du, du... Du kannst dir noch mal eine Nummer geben. Genau, ich habe noch so ein paar Leute, die wollen noch ihr Vermögen bewahren. Da muss die CDU natürlich aufpassen, dass die FDP das nicht so gut macht und die CDU dann nicht mehr gebraucht wird. Also in deren Sicht, ja, da geht es jetzt zur Sache. Gut, ich bin sehr dankbar. Und jetzt habe ich den Namen leider nicht parat. Aber so wie Südekum mir eine Zulieferung schickte, was die Clips für heute angeht, zumindest was die Veranstaltungen angeht, die es zu begucken gibt, bin ich auf diese BDI-Veranstaltung in der Bundespressekonferenz auch nicht aufmerksam geworden, bis sie mir geschickt wurde von einem Hörer, der dachte, hier schalte das mal an, das ist bestimmt ganz gut. Gab es auch nur bei Phoenix und hat dort auf YouTube auch nur so 1000, 2000 Leute irgendwie interessiert, die wahrscheinlich so mal bei Phoenix geguckt haben, was ist denn das und so. Aber dadurch, dass die auch, die Audio, der ganze Ton war nur auf der linken Tonspur, also man hätte sie über Kopfhörer gar nicht konsumieren können und so. War wieder völlig neben der Spur. Na ja, der BDI, also der Industrie, der größte Industrieverband der Welt, der hier in Deutschland ansässig ist, hat einen Plan, der heißt Klimapfad. Den gab es schon und der wurde jetzt nochmal geupdatet und da wird auch gleich zu Beginn die Zahl genannt.
Ein zentrales Ergebnis unserer Studie lautet, die Umsetzung der Klimaschutzmaßnahmen erfordert bis 2030 mehr Investitionen in Höhe von rund 860 Milliarden Euro, die Staat, Bürgerinnen und Bürger und Unternehmen aufbringen müssen.
Also aus dem laufenden Betrieb heraus ergibt sich ein Mehrbedarf an 860 Milliarden, die aufgebracht werden müssen. Geldquellen dafür sind unklar, aber das kann Südekum ja gleich erklären und er betont hier nochmal der Staat und die Unternehmen. Diese Verkopplung zu machen, ist ja auch nicht per se schlecht, denn die Unternehmen wissen ja, wie sie das Geld verwenden sollen, wenn sie Kreditechancen ergeben und das Risiko ist gering. Warum sollten sie es nicht selber machen? Aber bei 860 Milliarden stellt man schon fest, naja, so viel haben die Unternehmen wahrscheinlich nicht und die Banken werden wohl auch nicht so viel locker machen. Vor allem, wenn man nicht genau weiß, in welche Richtung geht das hier. Man hat ja bei so großen Wandelungsprojekten immer nur einen Schuss. Das ist ja jetzt nicht hier, sondern wir bauen mal einen Film und wenn wir den falschen Filter benutzt haben, dann machen die mal einen anderen oder so. Sondern hier gibt es halt immer nur einen Versuch. Und der BDI plant mit 860 Milliarden. Und wir können wieder an Lindner denken, ja, wenn die alle hören, 860 Milliarden sind zu investieren. Angenommen, das geht alles auf. Welche Rendite ist dann zu erwarten? Und wer soll sie bekommen? Also wen wollen wir hier als Eigner am Ende haben? Denn wer bezahlt, dem gehört es am Ende auch. Das, dem wir gerade gehört haben, ist der Herr Russwurm. Der sitzt also dem BDI gerade vor. Er kommt selbst aus dieser Thyssen-Krupp-Richtung. Er sitzt da mit dem Vorstand und pipapu. Und er macht ja einen Naivitätsvorwurf.
Und wer glaubt, dass sich angesichts der bevorstehenden Belastungen die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Industrien mit ein paar steuerlichen Abschreibungen in klimafreundliche Investitionen sichern lässt, wer das glaubt, ist bestenfalls naiv.
Ja, wir brauchen also eine Geldquelle, sagen wir ja. Ganz klar, auf die 860 Milliarden brauchen wir eine Geldquelle. Irgendwo muss es herkommen. Und ganz interessant ist, wie sehr er hier dieses grüne Argument, von dem ich eben auch sage, wir müssen über das Konservative, also Konservieren heißt, etwas zu erhalten. Da kommt der Begriff her. Was erhalten? Naja, Wohlstand halt. Es geht ja ums Geld. Der CDU ging es immer nur ums Geld. Warum sollte sie nicht einfach mal sich eingestehen und sagen, wir schützen das Vermögen, Schöpfung bewahren, Wohlstand sichern? So irgendwie, kann man doch mal zusammenbinden. Naja, und da ist doch erstaunlich, wie groß die Einigkeit hier mit dieser neuen, grünen politischen Herangehensweise eigentlich ist.
Meine Damen und Herren, die aktuelle Planlosigkeit und Unsicherheit der deutschen Klimapolitik drohen.
Und damit meinte eigentlich die 16-Jahre Merkel.
Zur Gefahr, für unseren Standort zu werden. Vom Auseinanderdriften der Gesellschaft bis zu einer dauerhaften Schwächung der Industrie. Wenn wir scheitern würden, würden wir das Erfolgsmodell des Industrielandes Deutschland zerstören und den Wohlstand des ganzen Landes gefährden.
So, Wohlstandsgefährdung. Das hat der Baerbock eigentlich immer wieder betont. Während habe ich ja mehr so auf diese, ich erkläre euch jetzt mal, Freiheit und so weiter, hat der Baerbock immer gesagt, es geht um die Wohlstandssicherung. Wer jetzt nicht investiert, bringt alles in Gefahr. Denn die Automobilindustrie wird dann einfach abgeräumt und dann ist es halt vorbei. Deswegen machen wir lieber hier mal einen Shift, auch wenn es was kostet. Und der Co-Autor, Herr Prof. Jens Buchhardt, der hier neben ihm sitzt, macht auch noch mal das Argument. Und es ist mir, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, dass wir das nicht aus den Augen verlieren. Am Ende geht es ja nicht nur um Geld. Das haben wir, glaube ich, gesehen. Die Bundesregierung kann sehr gut Geld ausgeben, nur damit ist ja selten was getan. Sondern es braucht auch so eine gewisse Intelligenz. Wir brauchen also diesen privaten Sektor, die Unternehmen, die das Geld verwenden sollen, am Ende, die müssen mehr machen, als nur Geld annehmen und ausgeben. Sie müssen auch mitdenken.
Herr Russwurm hat die Investitionen angesprochen, die dafür nötig sind. 860 Milliarden Euro bis 2030, fast 100 Milliarden pro Jahr. Trotzdem ist diese Transformation nicht in erster Linie ein finanzielles Problem. Damit diese Investitionen fließen, müssen Millionen Menschen, Zehntausende Unternehmen in den nächsten zehn Jahren andere Entscheidungen treffen, als sie es heute tun. Während wir gleichzeitig unsere Energieinfrastruktur umbauen, werden wir komplett neue Energieinfrastrukturen aufbauen. Das zu koordinieren, dafür die richtigen Anreize zu schaffen, das ist die eigentliche Herausforderung.
Ja, und der BDI, da saßen ja am Ende 80 Unternehmen in 30 Workshops zusammen und haben da mit 90 Experten irgendwie überlegt, was sie da so tun sollen. Und die bauen jetzt eben so dieses Bild zusammen. Wir brauchen 860 Milliarden insgesamt, das ist da mehr Bedarf. Wir brauchen aber mehr als das. Wir brauchen auch so einen Gesinnungswandel. Also wir brauchen zum einen die Politik und auch Fridays for Future, das haben wir vor einem Jahr schon diskutiert, so als Kulisse dafür, dass sich jetzt auch wirklich was ändert. Wir brauchen die EZB, die irgendwie sagt, Green Bonds und Green Finance und so weiter und so fort, sodass alle feststellen, es ändert sich wirklich was. Und jetzt wird es hier konkret. Jens Buchhardt sagt mal, wie hoch jetzt er schätzt, dass der öffentliche Anteil von den 860 Milliarden ist.
Laut unseren Berechnungen wird das den Staat über die kommenden zehn Jahre in Summe ungefähr 250 Milliarden Euro kosten. Das ist natürlich extrem viel Geld. Aber wenn wir eins in der Vergangenheit wieder und wieder gezeigt haben, dann ist es, dass Deutschland in der Lage ist, solche Geldmittel zu mobilisieren, wenn es wirklich nötig ist. Das war zum Beispiel für den Aufschwung ostnötig. Der hat uns gemessen, ein Bruttoinlandsprodukt Deutschlands mehr als doppelt so viel gekostet.
Noch mal ein schöner Verweis. Eigentlich auch noch mal so an die CDU. Guckt mal, damals habt ihr noch was gemacht. Und jetzt verschlaft ihr hier alles. Ganz, ganz Interessantes so zu rechtfertigen.
Machen sie leider nicht so deutlich, die Vorwürfe an.
Ja, aber man kann es rauslesen, wenn man denn möchte. Aber diese Idee, also der Staat wissen wir ja, kann Gelder locker machen, hat er jetzt auch getan. Dass das jetzt noch mal als eine Kraftanstrengung verkauft wird. Die Frage ist, worin liegt die Kraftanstrengung? Also liegt die Kraftanstrengung nicht letztlich nur darin, dass man genügend in einer Koalition versammelt, die sagen, ja, wir machen es jetzt einfach?
Genau, ein schwarz-grünes Bändnis hat daher für Habeck total Sinn gemacht, weil er diese Idee, die der BDI hier sozusagen unterfördert mit richtiger Traktion ausstattet, der CDU hätte beibringen können.
Aber glaubst du, dass die CDU sich auf solche staatlichen Dinge stark eingelassen hätte? Weil das so entgegen allem ist, was die wollen. Also gut, hier geht es ja auch noch nicht darum, dass der Staat jetzt als großer Akteur auftritt.
Das kann man im nächsten Clip eben gut auflösen. Der BDI sitzt hier da und sagt, 860 Milliarden sind gebraucht, nur 250 Milliarden staatliches Geld, also 600 Milliarden privat. Jetzt kann man sich überlegen, 600 Milliarden zu 250 Milliarden, was heißt das? Dass es ein paar ganz super sichere Rendite abfallende Investitionen gibt, in die geht man einfach privat rein und alles andere, was weiß ich, Verkehrsinfrastruktur oder so, die soll dann der Staat machen und dafür sind dann 250 Milliarden. Oder brauchen wir das irgendwie so als Stütze, dass man sich so Investitionen teilt und dann aber, kennt man ja bei der Maut, einfach die Renditen zusichert, egal wo es am Ende knifflig wird und dann auch wirklich mal nicht funktioniert. Interessant ist, finde ich, die Zahl von 250 Milliarden, weil das hätte ja, wenn jetzt hier Habeck und Röttgen oder so, wenn die beiden, das hat ja, wer ist der, jetzt habe ich gerade seinen Namen, Konstantin von Notz saß ja auch bei Anneville, hat Röttgen so gesagt, ja sie sind ja ein progressiver Typ, mit ihnen hätten wir ja was machen können, aber sie haben die CDU ja nicht unter Kontrolle gekriegt, sondern haben das Theater Spiel den anderen überlassen und so. Aber angenommen, Röttgen und Habeck saßen jetzt da und hätten mit dem BDI hier verkündet, 860 Milliarden, dann sind wir in zehn Jahren ein modernes Land, das sind die Projekte, moderne Hochöfen, neuer Verkehr, Pipapo, kostet uns 250 Milliarden und schaut mal her, Leute, 400 Milliarden hat uns allein Corona an einem Jahr gekostet. Hat das irgendwer gemerkt, dass wir 400 Milliarden extra ausgegeben haben? Nein, weil der Bundestag hat es einfach ausgegeben. Ja, es ist im definikelten Sinne, der Bundestag entscheidet. Also ist das Geld dann auch da. Und deren Sicht liegt ja, glaube ich, schon so ein Programm da. Und dass man jetzt einfach hätte machen können, wenn man nicht, und das ist die neue Konstellation, erst mal ausfechten muss zwischen Grün und Gelb. Weil die sich eben da plötzlich so neu zusammenfinden müssen, wer macht jetzt was und so.
Also ich glaube, du überschätzt die Union und ihre Progressivität. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das unbedingt stattgefunden hätte.
Wir sehen ja auch, dass es nicht stattfindet.
Die CDU hat es ja nicht geschafft, sich da so zu platzieren. Also wenn ich sehe, wie lustvoll Röttgen Lindner zustimmt, dann habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass der da viel locker gemacht hätte.
Naja, aber um 610 Milliarden in den Szenario Investitionen so abzustützen, dass sie auf jeden Fall Rendite abwirft, mit 250 Milliarden staatlichen Geld, also das hätte die CDU locker mitgemacht, weil dann hätten sie all ihren Industrieverkehrs und so weiter.
Also ich bin auch skeptisch, ob diese Summe reicht.
Ja, also das ist eben auch, ich finde, so 250 Milliarden. Das scheint mir nicht wirklich zu sein. Das ist erstaunlich wenig.
Also wenn wir sehen, dass 400 Milliarden ausgegeben wurde, jetzt bei Corona, und das war jetzt mal gerade ein paar Monate, wo man da ein bisschen was mitmachen wollte. Das ist irgendwie klar, dass damit eine Transformation von diesem Ausmaß, wie erhofft und gewünscht, nicht nur von Fridays for Future, sondern von allen, die klar denken können, dass das damit nicht bewältigt war.
In der Ansicht ist immer die Gefahr, dass das so ein Fuß in die Tür ist. Und dann, jetzt müssen wir leider nachlegen, wie bei den ganzen Großbauprojekten und so, wo man dann nicht auf halber Strecke anhalten will. Na ja, und Herr Russwurm, und wir haben jetzt immer 610 Milliarden private Investitionen, die auf jeden Fall Rendite abwerfen im Hinterkopf, die nicht über die 250 Milliarden, um dann auf 860 Milliarden zu kommen, abgesichert sind. Herr Russwurm sagt dann noch Folgendes.
Unternehmen der Industrie im engeren Sinn, aber auch Energieversorgungsunternehmen im Sektor Industrie, die privatwirtschaftlichen Akteure im Sektor Verkehr, die privatwirtschaftlichen Akteure im Sektor Gebäude werden investieren und werden den großen Teil der Investitionen schultern müssen. Das werden sie allerdings nur tun, wenn sie daraus eine Renditeerwartung haben. Investitionen, privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen, müssen sich lohnen, sonst werden sie nicht stattfinden. Und auch das macht den Mix der Instrumente und die Rolle des Staates und die Regulierung so anstrengend und spannend. Es muss uns gelingen, dass wir große Mengen privaten Kapitals für die Investitionen mobilisieren. Aber noch mal, das wird nur passieren, wenn wir Mechanismen finden, dass sich diese Investitionen lohnen.
Wir hatten ja einen Clip mal aus einer BDI-Veranstaltung, da hatte ich was von Ross vom Vorgespielt, wo er dann auch nur fast hysterisch sagte. Und leben wir denn überhaupt noch in einer Marktwirtschaft? Das will ich jetzt mal wissen. Jetzt fordert er natürlich selbst den Staatskapitalismus ein, also der Staat, der handelnd auftritt, weil das sonst gar keine Möglichkeit ist, für Unternehmer was zu tun. Denn er hat ja vollkommen recht, warum sollte man investieren, wenn man keine Rendite daraus bekommt. In privatwirtschaftlicher Hinsicht ist das ja absolut korrekt. Weshalb der Staat eben in manchen Dingen, die keine Rendite bringen können, tatsächlich einfach der bessere Akteur ist.
Ich finde, Herr Rosswurm setzt zum einen die Politik unter Druck. Ihr müsst das bezahlen und ihr müsst uns Rendite zusichern. Ansonsten machen wir das nicht. Das ist ja auch die Idee von Green Bonds. Die zwei Prozent sind in Ansonsten-Null-Zins-Szenarien einfach staatlich gesichert. Und er macht das halt hier ganz clever. Und ich würde sagen, fast mit so einer systemtheoretischen Kühle. Ihr müsst als Politik uns so irritieren, dass wir unsere BWL-Anstrengungen in die richtige Richtung lenken. Ansonsten geht das hier nicht. Nur der Appell reicht nicht. Und nur Geld drauf werfen reicht eben auch nicht. Und da hat auch sein Jens Buchhardt dabei. Wir haben gerade gehört, wie er sagt, hier geht es um Gesinnungswandel, Umdenken, neue BWL-Strategien. Das kann man nicht nur mit Geld machen, sondern hier geht es darum, den privaten Sektor...
Das hatte sich ja auch vor der Dotcom-Blase mal gezeigt. Da hat man ja auch einfach mal gedacht, ach ja, Internet, wir werfen jetzt mal ein bisschen Geld ab. Und dann haben sich da Leute bereichert, haben mal so ein Jahr da den großen Max gemacht. Und dann war das Unternehmen pleite. Da wurde ja nichts groß gesteuert damals.
Genau. Und in dem Sinne dachte sich Herr Husswurm, jetzt habe ich das 50 Sekunden gesagt, das reicht mir eigentlich nicht.
Für die notwendigen Investitionen und wie wir sie aufteilen, wird entscheidend wichtig sein, welche Möglichkeiten wir finden. Nochmal die obere Grenze für privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen, grosso modo von philanthropischen Stiftungen mal abgesehen, wird sein, was sich lohnt, auch im globalen Wettbewerb lohnt. Deswegen müssen wir überzeugende Szenarien entwickeln, zusammen mit der Politik, dass wir diese Finanzierung wirklich aufaggregieren können.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt hier nochmal, nur jetzt einfach deutsche Unternehmen zu subventionieren, damit sie irgendwas machen und so weiter. Nein, man muss die deutschen Unternehmen im internationalen Wettbewerb beobachten und ihre Platzierung dort mit betrachten. Und das Geld so geben, dass entsprechend die Motivation da ist, da auch Hidden-Champion mäßig Weltmarktführer zu bleiben oder werden zu können oder wie auch immer.
Und was wir jetzt hier im ganz Kleinen finden, 1200 Leute gucken sich das an, kaum einen interessiert das, was der BDI hier verkündet. Das ist aber ein globales Phänomen. Also wir sehen jetzt hier den neuen Staatskapitalismus, der eng wieder zusammenarbeiten muss. Also das ist mit der Industrie, beziehungsweise also der Staatskapitalismus ist Staat und ist Industrie oder ist Privatwirtschaft. Und wir haben die ganze Zeit diese Erzählung gehabt, wir als Staat sind schlank, wir ziehen uns raus, lassen wir den Markt mal machen, was wir permanent noch hören jetzt auch, wenn die CDU frustriert in den Talkshows sitzt. Und wir sehen hier von BDI Seite, dass die offenbar auch mit globalem Blick verstanden haben, naja, wenn die das in Indien so machen, in China so machen, Amerika so machen, was sollen wir denn jetzt eigentlich tun? Und deswegen auch nochmal diese Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, ist ja sehr richtig, sie anzusprechen. Denn wenn die unterstützt werden vom Staat, dann müssen die deutschen Unternehmen jetzt plötzlich den Staat auch mehr einfordern. Und müssen jetzt auch den Staat nicht nur als den erkennen, der ihnen irgendwie Steuern wegnimmt, sondern sie müssen ihn erkennen, der jetzt die Hilfestellung leistet. Denn alleine werden sie das nicht schaffen, beziehungsweise sie werden es auch nicht schaffen wollen. Also es wird jetzt auch nicht so sein, dass die an ihre Substanz gehen. Also ich denke nicht, dass Klappen und Co jetzt sagen, naja, wir haben ja genug Impetto, wir machen das mal alleine.
Ja, aber auch BMW, VW, Audi und so. Audi gehört dazu, VW. Aber die werden alle im Business as usual vor die Hunde gegangen, wenn nicht mal der Druck von außen über, was weiß ich. Das mit dem Diesel klappt nicht. Und es gibt jetzt nicht nur Tesla, sondern auch in China die großen neuen E-Mobilitätsunternehmen und so weiter. Irgendwo muss der Druck herkommen. Und in der Ansicht finde ich das ganz interessant, wenn der BDI-Typ so da sitzt und eigentlich soziologisch aufgeklärt sagt, ihr müsst uns jetzt auch mal anstupsen. Nehmt die VBL-Logik ernst.
Im Handelsblatt ist natürlich BDI sehr geschätzt. Und da stehen dann auch solche Sachen drin. Und dann ist das auch schon der Ruf nach einem neuen Staatskapitalismus. Und wenn du dann aber dem manche Kommentare ansiehst, zum Beispiel von Thomas Siegmund, der auch so ein Schuldenbremsenverfechter ist, die finden ja immer alles auch ganz toll, was Lars Feld von sich gibt und so. Und dann liest du diese Kommentare, wo dann noch mal gesagt wird, der Staat ist kein guter Unternehmer, das muss der Markt und so weiter. Und du denkst dir aber, ihr habt es doch hier schon von BDI jetzt auf vier Seiten. Was muss da noch passieren?
Aber ich bin auch ein bisschen beeindruckt, wie schnell wir in Deutschland failtisch mit Sinn aussortiert haben. Und jetzt plötzlich Südekum, Fratscher und so weiter, die ganze Neueriege da irgendwie, das ist schon beeindruckend. Und der Jens Buchhardt, der hier als Professor mit dabei sitzt und sozusagen die Hoheit über das Papier hatte, das sie hier vorstellen, sagt hier noch mal Folgendes. Das finde ich natürlich auch grundsätzlich einfach, wie soll man sagen, da steckt fast so ein Motivierargument für ganz Deutschland eigentlich drin.
Und in einem Land wie Deutschland, in dem fast alle fossilen Energieträger importiert werden und in dem Kapital extrem wenig kostet, ist das jetzt erstmal volkswirtschaftlich mehr eine Chance als ein Risiko. Das heißt, die Netto-Wirkung auf Beschäftigung, auf wirtschaftliches Wachstum von so einer Transformation sollte in einem Land wie Deutschland positiv sein. Das gilt, wenn man sie richtig umsetzt und zum richtigen Umsetzen gehört, dass die Sektoren, für die diese Chancenerzählung nicht gilt und die gibt es, das ist für emissionsintensive Industrien natürlich ein unglaubliches Risiko, wenn ein Stahlunternehmen von einem Hochofen auf Wasserstoffdirektreduktion umstellt, dann steigen Produktionskosten um 50 Prozent. Das kann sein, dass der Markt das bezahlt, aber kann auch sein, dass es nicht tut. Das heißt, natürlich ist das ein Risiko und natürlich müssen wir an den Stellen unserer Volkswirtschaft, wo dieses Risiko besteht, unterstützen und ausgleichen.
Ja, unterstützen und ausgleichen ist schön und gut, aber was er vorhin sagt, bisher importieren wir Strom. Also Gas aus Russland, Öl von daher und so. Wir haben ja gar keine eigenen großen fossilen Quellen, das bisschen Kohle, was wir irgendwie in diesen gigantisch großen Löchern ausbuddeln. Aber wenn wir das jetzt umstellen auf regenerative Energien, die wir im Land selber haben, also was weiß ich, überdachte Autobahnen mit Solarplatten und wirklich mal konsequent, steht ja im Sondierungspapier schon drin, Gewerbeflächen auf jeden Fall mit Solar überdachten und ansonsten die Innenstädte so auch, dass man irgendwie ein großes Parkhaus am Hauptbahnhof in den deutschen Innenstädten hat und dann aber sagt, ja, und die 50 Hektar drum herum, die Dächer werden halt komplett verwendet, um für das Parkhaus den Strom zur Verfügung zu stellen, damit dann alle Autos, die da stehen, auftanken und so. Und damit holt man ja die Geldempfänger ins Land, denn man zahlt nicht mehr an Russland und an die Emirate und so für Energie, sondern man lässt es jetzt im Land. Und da liegt natürlich ein großer Nettogewinn einfach drin grundsätzlich in diese Art von Energieschöpfung.
Und auch das muss intelligent gesteuert werden, dass man nicht am Ende sagt, wir haben ja hier eine tolle Landschaft, wir haben hier Felder und der Bauer kann plötzlich mehr damit verdienen, wenn er Solarfelder aufs Feld stellt, als wenn er dort was anbaut.
Das ist so verrückt, ja.
Aber das zeigt auch wieder, wenn man dann nur den Markt walten lässt. Und da muss man tatsächlich sagen, wo ist es denn sinnvoll, also Autobahnen und diese ganzen Punkte, die zu nennen werden. Und da würde ich auch wieder sagen, da reichen diese 250 Milliarden nicht. Da müsste man also tiefer in die Tasche greifen. Würde ich aber auch hinzufügen, ist nicht unbedingt die Baustelle von BDI primär. Sondern das ist jetzt eigentlich was, was eine Ampelkoalition begreifen müsste. Und ich sag mal so, da ist ja so eine gute Erzählung draus zu machen. Ja eben. Also das ist ja gar nichts, wo man noch mit Verbot und diesem ganzen Pipa Pro ankommen muss. Sondern das ist ja einfach nur für jeden sinnvoll und ist auch keine Lärmbelästigung. Es ist auch nicht, dass es irgendwie stört. Ich kann ja durchaus auch bei manchen Leuten verstehen, die sagen, das Windrad fände ich jetzt aber unglücklich hier in der Nähe. Also das sind auch immer so private Ansichten, die Leute dann haben. Und die kann man natürlich dann bezweifeln, dass die so wichtig sind, dass nicht anderes wichtig ist und all das. Aber das ist noch was, was man so als Gemütsregung nachvollziehen kann. Aber hier hätte ja niemand was dagegen. Also da würde ja niemand sagen, oh, wie schlimm, dass wir jetzt Solardächer haben.
Ich bin auch dafür, dass wir sagen, Windräder gehören an die See, wo sie richtig was bringen. Da stehen da 10 Megawatt Turbinen. Es werden Windparks in Gigawatt Größe aufgebaut. Und ein Gigawatt ist immer äquivalent zu einem Atomkraftwerk. Und wir haben da jetzt so sieben und da nochmal sieben und kriegen es aber nicht angebunden, weil Südlink und so weiter. Da sperrt man sich dann wieder bei den Stromtrassen. Also da könnte man ja dann mal ansetzen.
Man sollte aufhören mit diesen ganzen Scharmützeln. Ich meine, jetzt wird uns dieses Tempolimit immer noch erhalten bleiben. Also diese Debatte wird uns da immer erhalten bleiben. Ehrlich gesagt, mir ist es inzwischen egal. Ich bin selten mal auf einer Autobahn noch mal schneller als 130 gefahren. Aufgrund der ganzen Baustellen und so. Ich kann sagen, es wird geblitzt an jeder Ecke. Es ist eine Katastrophe. Ich bin auch schon wieder geblitzt worden mit 120, wo 100 war, weil das einfach so schnell wechselt, dass ich das gar nicht mehr richtig mitbekomme. Und wann bin ich mal 180 auf der Autobahn fahren? Und jetzt mal nachts, als ich von Frankfurt zurück bin oder so. Aber sonst ja eigentlich nie. Also mir ist es vollkommen egal. Ich würde einfach sagen, man lässt dieses Thema jetzt aus. Also was wollt ihr denn da? Also worüber reden wir jetzt?
Also ich wäre allein für ein Tempolimit, weil es super entspannt ist. In Niederlande ist ja dieser 100 kmh, was ja bedeutet, alle fahren 100. Die machen in den Tempomat einfach 100 und damit keine Überraschung mehr. Das ist fast wie Bahnfahren.
Aber 100 ist mir wirklich zu langsam.
Holland ist nicht so groß.
Da hat man ja den Eindruck, man kann noch während der Fahrt aussteigen.
Ja, aber Holland ist ja nicht so groß. Da kannst du sowas noch machen. Wir wollen natürlich nur über das Geld reden, weshalb wir jetzt einen ganz großen Haken an alle Sachen machen, bei denen wir uns fragen, aber die Dunkelflaute, was machen wir nachts, was machen wir mit dem Winter, was ist, wenn keine Sonne scheint, was ist, wenn kein Wind weht. Das ist jetzt das große Finale des BDIs hier.
Die Technologien, die wir bis 2030 brauchen, die müssen heute in Anführungszeichen erfunden sein. Die gibt es, sie sind nicht alle großtechnisch bereits installiert. Das ist der wesentliche Schritt. Es mangelt uns nicht an klugen Köpfen in der Forschung von Basistechnologien.
Ja, also sehen wir genauso, wir haben in unseren Augen kein Technologieproblem, kein Erkenntnisproblem. Die Technologien, um unser Ziel vor allem jetzt mit Zeithorizont 2030 zu erreichen, die sind alle heute da. Wir haben ein Umsetzungsproblem. Und da muss Regulierung jetzt schon deutlich umfangreicher unterstützen, das zu lösen.
Technologien alle da, Haken dran. Man muss es halt einsetzen. Einsetzen heißt bezahlen und zu wissen, warum. Also der Mindset in den Unternehmen, was er da angesprochen hat. Das nehmen wir jetzt mal als gegeben hin und fragen uns nur, wo kommt das Geld her und welche Ideen müssen wir damit verbinden. Da hat Jens Südekum bei McKinsey im Juni 2021, als noch unklar war, wie geht die Bundestagswahl aus, von den Transformationsfonds gesprochen. Zuerst dachte ich, ich habe nur das als Grundlage, aber wir haben gleich noch Clips, das ist ganz gut. Also es gibt einen Investitionsbedarf und die Unsicherheit ist recht hoch, denn wir haben es hier mit Klimawandel, es ist Pionierarbeit für alle zu tun. Also die Idee Schuldenfinanzierte Fonds. Wir gründen Gesellschaften, die sich das Geld nicht vom Staat holen, sondern mit Hilfe des Staates sich selbst verschulden. Und er macht dann so verschiedene Beispiele. Also ein deutsches Stahlunternehmen macht ernst mit grünem Stahl, hat einen Finanzierungsbedarf von 100 Millionen Euro. Das wollen natürlich die Geschäftsbanken alleine nicht machen, weil wenn diese eine Apparatur dann nicht funktioniert, ist halt Pussekuchen. Also sagt man den Banken, kommt ihr müsst nur 60 Millionen bezahlen. Und zur weiteren Risikominimierung gibt es halt 40 Millionen von dieser Investitionsbank, was dann bedeutet, wenn die Rendite da ist, ist sie gewaltig. Nämlich dann hat man eine Apparatur, die für 100 Millionen und so weiter dann Renditen abwirft und auch konkurrenzlos ist, weil man hat ja ein Pionierding geschaffen, das dann funktioniert. Und kann dann ordentlich einsacken. Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, hat man nur 60 Millionen aufs Spiel gesetzt und nicht 100. Er spielt es dann so weit, dass man auch mit 80 Prozent von Seiten des Staates eingehen kann, um dann Anteilen später, wenn man sieht, es funktioniert, zu verhökern. Wie auch immer. Wir haben ja bei Corona gesehen, auch die 80 Prozent sind...
Das ist doch, wenn ich da gleich schon einhaken darf, ist das nicht eigentlich fast so das Modell, wie wir in Deutschland Filme fördern? Also wir fördern ja in Deutschland zum Beispiel Filme, wo man weiß, die bringen jetzt kommerziell nichts. Aber die klammern wir mal aus. Aber hier zum Beispiel ein Til Schweiger Film ist ja leider meist kommerziell erfolgreich. Das heißt aber, der hat trotzdem Filmförderung. Und diese Filmförderung sieht so aus, dass der sagen wir 1, 5 Millionen bekommt aus den Filmförderfonds, die es so gibt. Und wenn das erfolgreich ist, dann zahlt er das zurück. Und wenn das nicht ganz so erfolgreich ist oder so, dann zahlt er halt nur ein Teil zurück. Was jetzt bei Schweiger tatsächlich so ist, dass er in der Regel voll zurück zahlt. Da ist das Problem bei der Fördersstruktur ein anderes.
Genau, also der Staat kann ja durchaus finanzieren und trotzdem die Marktkräfte sich selbst überlassen. So ein bisschen. Und das haben wir ja auch gesehen bei der Frage, wie beteiligt sich jetzt. Also juristisch immer heikle Unterschiede, aber wir können ganz viele Äquivalente finden. Die Lufthansa-Unterstützung zum Beispiel. Man sieht einfach, den wurden jetzt am Markt weggenommen, aber in zwei Jahren sind die wieder da. Also geht man da rein, sagt, wir sind jetzt beteiligt, haben aber keine Stimmenrechte, Eigentumsrechte aber schon. Und damit fließt dann das Geld wieder zurück. Die Lufthansa bemüht sich, das wieder zurückzuzahlen, läuft ja auch gerade. Und dann sind halt 9 Milliarden einmal raus und einmal wieder rein. Die Diskussion kennen wir ja alle darum, aber es war halt in dem Sinne Staatsgeld, aber eben keine Subvention, sondern es war ein Investment, das der Staat macht, um das zu stützen. Auch wenn es dann so ein bisschen absurd ist, dass man ein Unternehmen, das nur 3 Milliarden wert ist, mit 9 Milliarden unterstützt. Aber da muss man halt nochmal, da laufende Betrieb und ein Unternehmenswert.
Da ist auch wieder die Frage des Politischen. Also was macht man? Und da ist vielleicht ganz gut, dass wir eine Ampelkoalition haben und jetzt nicht da alte Seilschaften, die jetzt seit 16 Jahren verfestigt sind. Ja, einfach mal so sich fortsetzen können. Wir haben das ja bei den Masken und so gesehen. Da kann man sagen, das ist immer noch Kinkalizien, die Millionenbeträge ärgerlich. Aber naja, wenn es aber hier um solche Summen geht, 250 Milliarden. Und da werden dann solche Glücksritter plötzlich ausgestattet von der Union.
Na ja, genau. Und das ist auch gleich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Das ist nämlich ganz interessant zu sehen, wie man das dann auch juristisch fasst. Dass man hier nicht einfach eine alte Seilschaft nochmal aufwärmt und dann so mündliche Absprachen oder sowas. Sondern dass man sich hier wirklich Gedanken darüber macht, wie man das so formal fasst, dass man das auch als Blaupaus sozusagen kopieren kann für andere Modelle. Denn ich würde sagen, Investitionsfonds kann man ja durchaus im Plural mal nehmen und dann wirklich themenspezifisch das zu unterscheiden. Unterschiede zu Subventionen, sagt dann Südekum, es werden Vermögenswerte geschaffen und nicht nur kostensozialisiert. Über die Partizipation ist man eben auch am Profit der Transformation beteiligt. Also das ist sozusagen auch für den Staat ein bisschen was drin. Ein reiner staatlicher Investitionsfonds, wie die KfW zum Beispiel auch so als Bank, da haben wir ja schon so ein Beispiel dafür, finanziert sich über staatliche Anleihen. Also die geben Anleihen raus, von denen es dann heißt, naja der Bailout ist schon geregelt, dass wir dann einfach Deutschland machen, falls es da knifflig wird. Und das bedeutet ganz konkret, dass man hier bei so einem Transformationsfonds die staatliche Sicherheit hat und trotzdem so weit weg vom Staat ist, dass die schwarze Null nicht gilt, weil man nämlich der finanziellen Ausgabe ein geschaffenes Vermögen gegenüberstellt. Es wird dann halt als Buchwert verrechnet und dann ist dann aber plus minus Null immer. Man sagt halt nur, ja das dauert halt drei Jahre, bis der hoch aufeinander steht. Aber er ist dann halt da und der ist ja dann auch nicht wertlos. Also in der Ansicht kommt man so um die schwarze Null drum rum. So und jetzt gucken wir uns Clips von Südekum an, wo er das so ein bisschen beschreibt. Das ist eine sehr lange zweieinhalbstündige Diskussion der Heinrich Böll Stiftung, die Corona bedingt online stattfand. Also jeder ist so ein bisschen zugeschaltet. Am Anfang auch Michael Hüter und so. Und es haben bis heute 200 Leute angeklickt. Also in den letzten sechs, sieben Monaten oder so. Also in der Ansicht, ich hoffe, es waren ein paar Journalisten dabei. Und ein paar sind jetzt in Bilde. Ansonsten ist das wirklich wieder krass, wie sehr da gearbeitet wird und wie wenig das so verfängt. Im Vergleich zu, wir hatten Wahlkampf. Was haben wir alles nicht diskutiert in den letzten Monaten. Also wirklich verrückt. Gut, stecken wir mal bei Südekum ein. Ich habe einfach so Sachen rausgeschnitten, die jetzt zu unseren Problemen passen. Zum einen 250 Milliarden, staatliches Geld, trotz 860 Milliarden Finanzierungsbedarf. Kann man nicht einfach sagen, wir bezahlen euch das. 860 Milliarden MMT, wir haben auch schon diskutiert. Also wenn der Deutsche Bundestag will, könnte er einfach jedem Deutschen eine Million schenken. Nur das bedeutet halt, dann ist halt ganz schön viel Geld im Umlauf. Und man hat ziemlich viele Turbulenzen geschaffen. Aber es mangelt jetzt nicht mehr an der Kompetenz der politischen Entscheidung. Das sieht man ja auch in Amerika. Da widerspricht er hier so ein bisschen und sagt, man sollte auf jeden Fall mal laufenden Haushalt und laufende Einnahmesituationen im Blick behalten.
Aber es gibt ja manchmal sozusagen die Überlegung, überspitzt gesagt, Schulden sind völlig egal, solange sich die Inflation nicht meldet. Das ist ja eine Theorie, die mittlerweile recht prominent teilweise auch ist. Und ich habe gesehen, im Chat klang das auch so ein bisschen an. Ich glaube, eine Wirtschaftspolitik, die sozusagen mit diesem Paradigma operiert, ist auf Messerschneider angelegt. Und es besteht eine reale Gefahr, dass, wenn man eine solche Politik tatsächlich umsetzen würde, dass die Wirtschaft und die Währung, die dahinter steht, sehr schnell auch Schaden nehmen kann. Also ich halte gar nichts davon und bin deswegen sehr, betone das sehr, sehr stark, dass man eben sagt, diese laufenden Ausgaben sind wichtig und sollten aber auch aus laufenden Steuereinnahmen gedeckt sein. Dazu muss man aber auch sagen, wer genau hingeschaut hat, da steht auch die Konjunkturkomponente mit drin. Also der solide Teil, das heißt strukturell, keine Neuverschuldung für die laufenden Haushaltsausgaben. Aber das heißt natürlich auch, die Konjunkturkomponente, wenn wir eben an einem Unterbeschäftigungszustand sind in der Wirtschaft, dann ist im Prinzip dann eben auch ein expansiverer Kurs der Fiskalpolitik möglich, um eben diesen Unterbeschäftigungszustand zu reduzieren und abzubauen. Und da haben wir eine riesige Diskussion, die wir auch führen müssen, in Deutschland, aber vor allem auf europäischer Ebene. Weil die Definition des konditurnäutralen Zustandes funktioniert einfach in der Praxis nicht.
Also ihr habt euch ja auch, du und Ole, gegen bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen. Und wir haben auch immer MMT als Begriff hier so ein bisschen, sondern wenn ein funktionales Argument machen.
Genau, aber MMT und BGE sind ja auch nicht zusammenzudenken. Die meisten BGE-Anhänger haben mit MMT jetzt ein neuer Ding vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zu tun. Aber ich würde eher sagen, dass MMT-Leute gegen das BGE sind. Aber was er anspricht, diese Jobgeschichte ist natürlich eine entscheidende. Nun ist unsere Arbeitslosigkeit viel, viel geringer als im Süden Europas. Aber da ist es ein erhebliches Problem. Und da ist auch die Frage, da kann der Staat natürlich jetzt auch nicht einfach so die Jobs aus dem Boden schaffen, sondern das schafft er nur, indem er volkswirtschaftlich was ändert, sodass Jobs entstehen.
Genau, ich wollte noch mal BGE und MMT so sagen in diesem Kontext, weil man ja durchaus auf die Idee kommen könnte, wenn man ganz naiv ran geht und sagt, wir bezahlen jedem Deutschen ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen. Wo soll das Geld herkommen? Na, wir nehmen einfach Schulden auf. Diese Rechnung könnte man ja machen.
Also dann hätte man vermutlich auch wirklich eine inflationäre Wirkung.
Genau, wir haben ja immer dazu gesagt, wenn wir MMT behandelt haben, die Ausgabe des Staates, die auf Geldquelle Schulden setzt, muss immer klug sein. Nicht einfach Geld rauswerfen, um dann Konsum anzuheizen. Das reicht nicht, sondern das wird ja auch ganz scharf immer wieder von ihm betont. Wir können zwar immer nicht so ganz genau sagen, was jetzt eine Investition von einem Konsum unterscheidet, aber wenn man es sieht, weiß man, was eine dumme Ausgabe wäre, die man schuldenfinanziert macht und was eine kluge Ausgabe ist, die man schuldenfinanziert macht. Aber er besteht noch mal drauf, da schließt er ganz gut an, an das BDI-Ding. Es gibt laufende Einnahmen, laufende Ausgaben, die sollten sich auch die Waage halten, aber manchmal gibt es dann doch eine Herausforderung, die sollte man adressieren durch zusätzliches Geld, dass man nicht versucht durch, wir müssen auf der Einnahmenseite was ändern, weil das führt ja auch wieder zu Turbulenzen, wenn man jetzt große Steuerreformen macht, dann haben die Unternehmen nicht nur mit Klimawandel, sondern auch nur mit Steuerreformen zu tun, dass man dann sagt, wir lassen Einnahmen und Ausgabenregime, wie sie sind, legen aber noch was drauf, für eine besondere Aufgabe, und die hat ja der BDI gerade formuliert, 860 Milliarden mehr Bedarf durch Klimawandel. Darauf kommt er gleich nochmal zurück, aber vorher müssen wir nochmal auf die Ausgabenseite, also Einnahmenseite, Steuern oder Schulden. Aber wie ist das jetzt mit dieser Schuldenbremse? Und als ich Ihnen hier so reden gehört, habe ich gedacht, wieso fällt einem das nicht von selber oder mal vorher auf, dass die Schuldenbremse ein Fehler in sich hat, also einfach ein fehlkonstruiertes Ding ist, weil sie nämlich sehr einseitig ist.
Selbst wenn wir in einem Vollbeschäftigungszustand sind, mit voll ausgelasteten Produktionskapazitäten, macht es absolut Sinn, die Kreditfinanzierung von Investitionen zuzulassen. Warum? Weil die Schuldenbremse, wie wir sie haben, ist eine allein schon logisch zutiefst widersprüchliche Regel. Ich brauche gar nicht auf die aktuelle Politik einzugehen. Sie ist allein logisch inkonsequent. Die Schuldenbremse basiert ja auf die Idee, dass in einer Demokratie gewählte Politiker einem Deficit-Bias unterliegen. Also kurz gesagt, dass gewählte Politiker eben das Instrument der Schulden nehmen werden, damit eben Ausgaben für ihre Freunde und Wähler finanzieren.
Da würde ich sagen, ist er nah dran an der CDU. Die CDU hat sich selber in Ketten gelegt. Weil das macht Boris Johnson gerade. Also große Verschuldung, um irgendwie die Tory-regierten Städte da zu bevorzugen.
Und die Kosten auf die kommenden Generationen verlagern. Und um das zu verhindern, ist die Idee der Schuldenbremse, darf man gerade an der Demokratie Politiker dieses Instrument der Schuldenfinanzierung gar nicht erst an die Hand geben. Weil sonst werden sie es missbrauchen. Das ist quasi die Logik, die gilt auf der Einnahmenseite des Staates. Auf der Ausgabenseite des Staates haben wir aber maximale Naivität. Da sagen wir, das machen dann schon die Politiker. Und wir vertrauen, sie werden dann schon genug Zukunftsausgabeninvestitionen machen. Da brauchen wir uns im Prinzip nicht groß drum zu kümmern. Das ist aber logisch inkonsequent. Wenn ich an das Menschen- und Politikerbild glaube, das für den Deficit-Bias steht, dann hat dieser Typus auch einen Present-Bias. Dann wird er sich eben die Politik so ausgestalten, dass er eben, wenn er sagt, ich will nur den Medianwähler bedienen und der Medianwähler hat graue Haare mittlerweile in Deutschland wegen der demografischen Entwicklung, dann interessiert mich Ausgabe für Klimaschutz, Digitalisierung, Wasserstoff und was auch immer. Das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Mich interessiert nur noch die Rentenpolitik. Weil da werden die Wähler Stimmen gewonnen.
Und ich habe auch gedacht, bei dem Thema Rentenrepublik, also das läuft ja alles unter der Maxime. Die Demokratie bringt die Demokratie ganz schön in Gefahr, weil wenn wir nur noch alles demokratisch entscheiden, sind die Mehrheiten immer geregelt. Also dann machen wir keine Klimapolitik, sondern kriegen wir die Alten noch gut durch ihre Rente und dann ist aber auch Schluss für alle. So, und dass wir hier so eine Disbalance haben zwischen die Einnahmenseite, entziehen wir komplett der demokratischen, parlamentarischen Entscheidungsfähigkeit. So sagen einfach, nee, im Grundgesetz steht Schuldenbremse. Damit ist es ein für alle mal geregelt. Und auf der Ausgabenseite haben wir aber nicht so ein striktes Regime, das eben auf, und da ist halt Merz wieder mit seiner Zukunftsfähigkeit, der Haushalte und so weiter. Ja, aber was ist denn mit der Zukunftsfähigkeit Deutschlands, für das wir Politik machen, mit dem Geld, das wir eben zur Verfügung haben? Und das stimmt natürlich. Wenn wir eine Schuldenbremse machen, müssen wir auch sagen, und die FDP erstaunlicherweise macht das ja ganz streng, die will ja Demografie wirklich richtig reinschreiben ins Rentenproblem. Wenn das Geld nicht da ist, ist es nicht da. Das ist halt Demografie, so wie sie sagen, es ist halt Schuldenbremse. Es steht im Grundgesetz, es ist Demografie, es ist Naturgesetz. Wir haben nicht so viel Geld für die Rentner. Also die wollen das ganz konsequent. Und ja, eigentlich bräuchten wir, wenn wir eine Schuldenbremse machen, auch eine politische Verständigung darüber, was wir grundsätzlich den demokratischen Kräfteverhältnissen entziehen oder geben in Sachen Haushaltspolitik. Also man könnte einfach so wie wir, und das ist eben der Present Bias, wir sagen, ein Drittel des Haushaltes ist weg für Rentenzahlung. Ein Drittel, über die kann man nicht reden.
Das kommt jetzt in die Verfassung.
Die muss Hubertus Heil ausgeben.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Genau, und wir könnten ja alles möglich jetzt mal regeln.
Ganz genau, und das ist ja auch was, vor Alexander Thiele meines Wissens immer war, dass man immer glaubt, alles in die Verfassung einschäumen zu müssen. Also das ist eigentlich der politische Spielraum, den man sich lassen sollte. Und das ist ja auch gerade das, was bei der FDP das Amüsanteste von allem ist. Das hatte Lukas Scholle jetzt auch mal so getwittert. Und zwar meinte er, was wird denn eigentlich passieren, wenn man der FDP sagt, dass wenn man die Schuldenbremse lockert, dann könnte man auch Steuersenkungen machen. Also das ist so diese Idee, die man jetzt eigentlich mal so auch der FDP einpflanzen müsste.
Ich meine, die FDP, wir hören nachher noch einen schönen Clip von den Mikroökonom. Da kommt ja auch die Frage auf, wenn die FDP so viel Bürokratieabbau will, warum zwingt sie uns dann in so Transformationsgesellschaften, einfach zu sagen, wir finanzieren alles im Haushalt? Die bauen ja genau diese ganzen Vehikel jetzt auf, die da so kompliziert sind. So, Punkt Nummer drei bei Südekum. Ja, wir haben jetzt zum einen eine Ausgabe, die wir tätigen müssen und nicht aus dem laufenden Betrieb finanzieren können. Damit rechtfertigen wir irgendwie Schulden. Dann haben wir ein politisches, eine Disbalance zwischen, wir können an der Einnahmenseite, wir könnten ja, so wie wir die Ausgaben steigern wollen, dann eben auch die Einnahmenseite steigern, indem wir sagen, ja dann verschulden wir uns eben um die Maßen, die wir das Geld dann brauchen. Das geht aber auch nicht durch diese Disbalance in der Schuldenbremse, die uns eben bei den Einnahmen da die Fesseln anlegt und die Ausgabenseite nicht entsprechend regelt. Fällt dieses Problem jetzt eigentlich hinten runter oder wie gehen wir denn jetzt damit um? Und er betont hier nochmal klar, wie das jetzt ist. Er geht auf die BDI-Argumentation ein, europäisiert sie aber gleich.
Wir stehen eben jetzt gerade in den nächsten 10 Jahren, glaube ich, kann man sagen, einer einmaligen Menschheitsaufgabe. Kann man sagen. Es muss jetzt eben, also wenn wir es ernst meinen, dass wir die Dekarbonisierung erreichen wollen, dann können wir das nicht irgendwann machen, sondern müssen die wesentlichen Weichenstellungen in den nächsten 10 Jahren erfolgen. Und das wird große Summen verschlägen. Viroldika hat ja gerade einen Beitrag im Wirtschaftsdienst veröffentlicht, da wird eine schöne Zahl genannt, die lebe ich jetzt einfach mal so, dass die EU-Kommission sagt, zusätzliche Investitionen von 2, 6 Billionen Euro bis 2030 sind notwendig, um Klimaneutralität zu erreichen. Wohlgemerkt öffentliche und private Investitionen. Klingt einer riesigen Zahl, ist aber eigentlich gar nicht so groß. Also 2, 6 Billionen entspricht ungefähr 20 Prozent des BIPs eines Jahres der Europäischen Union. Und hier reden wir hier bei Investitionssummen bis 2030. Also eine Aufgabe, die groß ist, aber auch nicht komplett unrealistisch, dass man die sterben könnte. Und es ist völlig richtig, das ist erstmal etwas, was vor allem auf der Seite der privaten Investition geleistet werden muss.
Ja, so, finde ich erstaunlich. Der BDI sagt, also technisch ist alles geregelt. Und jetzt kommt er und sagt, ja, ist alles durchgerechnet. So groß ist der Finanzbedarf gar nicht. Wir müssen nur dieses ganze Niveau von Einnahmen und Ausgaben, dadurch, dass wir mehr Ausgaben haben, auch auf Einnahmeseite mal um 10 Prozent des europäischen BIPs steigern. Da denkt man sich so, wieso passt das nicht zusammen? Eins plus eins ist doch zwei. Warum finden hier BDI und die Ökonomen nicht so zusammen, dass die Politik einfach mal sagt, klingt logisch, machen wir jetzt. Klar, kommt dann immer die privaten Gelder, die privaten Renditen dazwischen. Und das ist eben der Kampf, den Christian Lindner jetzt kämpft. Es müssen möglichst viele private Renditen möglich sein. Die Investitionsmöglichkeiten müssen da sein. Das kann nicht einfach jetzt alles der Staat durch Schulden finanzieren, sondern der Staat kann ja allenfalls stützen. Und deswegen eben dieses komplizierte Vehikel zu sagen, na gut, da machen wir es nicht über den Bundeshaushalt oder die Staatshaushalte, sondern gründen dann irgendwelche bürokratisch total aufwendigen und eben auch nicht demokratisch legitimierten und auch verwaltungsmäßig sehr intransparenten Banken, weil keiner weiß, wie die KfW funktioniert. Und ich meine, die KfW hat letztes Jahr 60 Milliarden Schulden gemacht. Hat das irgendwer mitbekommen, die nicht auf den Bundeshaushalt angerechnet werden? Also das ist einfach verrückt so. Naja, aber solche Wege werden jetzt gemacht. Und da spielen jetzt die Investitionsmöglichkeiten eben über diese Transformationsfonds eine Rolle und damit auch die Green Bonds, die die EZB da jetzt gerade eigentlich wirklich auf die Schiene bringt.
Ich glaube, da ist genau das Spielfeld für diese Green Bonds zur Finanzierung eines staatlichen Transformationsfonds, das eben ganz gezielt eben diesen Umbau der nächsten zehn Jahre mitfinanziert. Ich betone mich dafür mitfinanziert, dass eben die notwendigen privatwirtschaftlichen Investitionen, ohne die es nicht gehen wird, zu einem Teil an solchen Transformationsfonds mitfinanziert werden. Und das sollte eben, muss aus meiner Sicht, auf europäischer Ebene passieren. Sonst geht es gar nicht. Also wenn wir das versuchen würden, als Deutschland alleine zu machen, sind wir fünf Minuten später im Konflikt mit den europäischen Beihilferegeln. Also das kann nicht funktionieren. Das heißt, wenn wir ehrlich sind, ist dann eben der Moment zu sagen, der Corona-Aufbaufonds, das war der Hamilton-Moment für die gemeinsame Verschuldung in der USA, der EU, Entschuldigung. Nach dem, was man jetzt weiß, hat es ganz gut funktioniert. Eine gemeinsame Währung braucht auch gemeinsame Fiskalpolitik, wenn wir ehrlich sind. Aber darüber will ich jetzt nicht reden. Das heißt dann, wenn die nächste Zukunfts- und Herkulesaufgabe vor entsteht, brauchen wir eben im Anschluss an den Wiederaufbaufonds, den Europäischen Transformationsfonds. Und das ist im Prinzip die dritte Säule unseres Dreiklans.
Ja, also nicht viele kleine deutsche KFWs, die so Transformationsfonds Stahl, Transformationsfonds Verkehr oder so, sondern er hat so die Idee des einen europäischen Transformationsfonds finanziert über dieses, und das kann man jetzt groß zusammenbinden, das haben wir alles schon thematisiert, das ist ganz erstaunlich eigentlich, dass der BDI sagt, das ist der Finanzierungsbedarf und wir nehmen konkret seine Idee, die er da mit McKinsey besprochen hat, die Stahlproduktion 100 Millionen, so jetzt zu 60 Millionen kann man stemmen, aber zu 40 Millionen braucht man noch mal den Staat. Und dann kommt die Europäische Union und sagt, ja, dann haben wir hier ein Fonds für euch, ihr müsst nur darauf aufpassen, dass die Investitionsmöglichkeit grün ist. Also da gibt es einfach einen Kriterienkatalog und dann kann das Geld da fließen. So, und das macht ja die EZB gerade, also jetzt in diesen Tagen, also jetzt diesen Monat oder, also dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall noch kommen, Taxonomie nennen die das dann, indem die die Investitionsmöglichkeiten aufteilen. Green und eben nicht green, um das zu unterscheiden und damit zu klassifizieren, wer sich qualifizieren kann für diese Art der Investition. Und das Geld dann noch bereitzustellen, also das ist ja eine Fingerübung, das hat sie bei Corona innerhalb von vier Tagen gemacht. Da haben wir ja bei Adam Toos gelesen, wie sie alle im Homeoffice saßen bei EZB und halt diese Dinger da aufgezogen haben. Und in deren Sicht passt das ja eigentlich alles ganz wunderbar zusammen. Man muss es halt nur politisch regeln irgendwie, aber diese Gewichtung zwischen privaten und öffentlichen Renditen, die ist auf jeden Fall möglich und auch handhabbar und fast geübte Praxis. Das Einzige, was wirklich neu ist, sehen wir jetzt dieses Label Green, das man dann eben sagt, ja, das ist dann auch EZB-mäßig abgesegnet im Sinne von, ja, da darf dann mitgestützt werden oder so, wie man schon die zwei Prozent zugesichert hat bei den bisherigen Greenfinance-Möglichkeiten. Veronika Grimm macht hier noch so einen kleinen demokratischen Punkt. Sie erinnert nochmal an die Demokratie.
Man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass man dann sozusagen den Parlamenten auch die Chance nimmt, genau das zu diskutieren. Und das Haushaltsrecht liegt nun mal bei den Parlamenten. Und da ist eben die Frage, ob wir zusätzliche Investitionsgesellschaften außerhalb des Parlaments einrichten sollten.
Ja, ich meine, wir sind schon alle, wir leben gut damit, dass die EZB da ist, die von uns auch nicht demokratisch kontrolliert wird, aber einfach die 1, 8 Billionen Pandemiehilfe fließen lässt in die Märkte.
Nur ist immer die Frage, ob dann da die Richtigen gerade auch sitzen. Also das war ja bei der EZB auch keineswegs immer so. Dass dieses demokratische Problem bleibt.
Hätte auch Jens Weidmann Chef werden können.
Ja, wenn gleich ich auch nicht jemand bin, der sagt, naja, wenn da die Leute alle mal demokratisch drüber abstimmen, dann wird das viel, viel besser. Also sagen wir mal so, man hat jetzt, also ich will das mal so äußern. Man hat jetzt ja diese vier Jahre sehr wahrscheinlich und kann da jetzt mit Dingen wie den hier vorgeschlagenen etwas auf den Weg bringen, dass dann auch von den Nachfolgern, sollten sie drohen, nicht so leicht zurückzuführen ist. Das ist ja immer die Frage, was kann man erhalten, nachdem man nicht mehr selbst an der Macht ist. Und wenn ich ansehe, was da so gerade in der Union gärt, nicht nur Junge Union, auch hier dieses konservative Think Tank, obwohl man Think dabei schon mal in Anführungsstriche setzen sollte. Wenn ich sehe, was da so auf uns zukommt, denen ist ja alles zuzutrauen. Die würden ja noch aus dem Klimaabkommen von Paris noch mal aussteigen am liebsten, glaube ich. Also in einem absoluten Wahn. Insofern vielleicht dann doch jetzt Strukturen festigen, schaffen, die nicht so leicht revidierbar sind.
Ist ja bei der EZB auch so gewesen. Im Grunde war egal, wer folgte. Es ist Lagarde geworden. Wer ist Weitmann geworden? Die hätten wahrscheinlich trotzdem das Geld locker so rausgehauen. Weil es gab welche Alternative. Du hast jetzt vier Jahre angesprochen. Wir haben in Deutschland ja keine Midterms, die alles schon mal auf zwei Jahre begrenzen. Trotzdem hören wir kurz Olaf Scholz dazu, wer Anne will.
Natürlich geht es um den großen industriellen Aufbruch in Deutschland, den wir zu Alexander bringen müssen, damit wir den menschengemachten Klimawandel aufhalten können. Und da ist mein großes Ziel, dass wir schon im ersten Jahr gemeinsam bewerkstelligen, dass wir alle Regeln in Deutschland so ändern, dass das auch klappt.
Ja, alle Regeln so ändern. Bei beiden ist ja das große Problem gerade, dass er von den eigenen Leuten extrem blockiert wird. Die Ausgaben, die er versprochen hat, sind jetzt sehr geschrumpft worden. Jetzt wird man natürlich einiges fürs Klima tun. Aber gerade das, was das Soziale anbelangt, ist das wieder weggefallen. Auch die höhere Besteuerung, die vorgesehen war für Vermögen und so. Und das ist eigentlich meine große Sorge, die ich auch dann mit Blick auf eine nächste Wahl habe, ist, wenn man es nicht schafft, einen sozialen Ausgleich zu kreieren. Und wenn das Aufstiegsversprechen weiter so leer bleibt und all das, dann führt das zu Verwerfungen. Und das wird dann gegen eine solche Politik sich richten. Und eigentlich hofft und wartet die Union darauf, dass diese Ampel nicht so sozial sein wird. Denn dann können die das abschöpfen, nicht weil sie dann eine soziale Politik machen, sondern weil sie eigentlich dann auf so einem Trump-Pfad laufen.
Also in Glasgow beginnt ja heute die Weltklimakonferenz. Und Joe Biden fährt mit leeren Händen ein.
Im Prinzip ja.
Es wurde ihm alles genommen, weil Joe Manchin in West Virginia selber millionenschwer von der Lobby finanziert wird. Also der demokratische Senator, der da mit im Senat sitzt. Und eigentlich die einnötige Stimme da noch hat. West Virginia wird zu 90 Prozent von Kohle befeuert. Und da war nichts zu machen. Und in Amerika gibt es auch diesen Sozialausgleich in dieser Klimakomponente nicht. Sondern die machen das komplett über Verschuldung und eigene Sozialpolitik, die ihm auch gerade entgleitet. Also in Amerika geht gerade alles vor die Hunde.
Also Trump kann schon sich in die Finger reiben.
Ja, also da ist gerade ganz düster in Amerika. Hier in Deutschland ist es ein bisschen anders. Olaf Scholz kennt Europa. Und er weiß, er hat für alle Länder was Positives dabei. Die Italiener haben jetzt schon angefangen. Jeden das Solardach zu schenken, was eben nicht nur bedeutet, man muss für sein Solardach nichts zahlen, sondern man hat dann auch sein Haus mit Strom versorgt. Also man ist entkoppelt von monatlichen Zahlungen. Denn das ist ja ganz erstaunlich. Auf einem privaten Dach kann man ja achtmal mehr Strom ernten als... Was man wirklich braucht in der eigenen Bude. Also im Privaten ist das ja wirklich erstaunlich. Wir haben es ja nur mit industriellem Strom Knappheit zu tun. Und ich hab irgendwie so eine Vorstellung, dass das nicht aus der Luft gegriffen wird mit dem Jahr, sondern dass dieses Programm bei ihm schon da liegt und dass er auch mit allen bis hin zu Lagarde darüber schon gesprochen hat. Und Jens Südekum macht das auch nochmal ganz scharf in diesem Talk. Den Clip habe ich aber nicht, aber den ist trotzdem ganz wichtig. Die soziale Komponente über, wir müssen es auch über den CO2-Preis steuern und der liegt idealerweise nicht bei 10 oder 25 Euro, sondern bei 180 Euro, muss zu 100 Prozent an die Bevölkerung zurückgegeben werden, und zwar genau nach sozialer Verteilung.
Das ist ja ganz irritiert gewesen, als man 180 Euro jetzt mal sagte.
Aber das ist wirklich nur ein Transformationsgeld, das muss komplett zurück, das soll nur auf Seiten der Ausgaben steuern, damit die Top 10 Prozent, also dann wirklich einfach mal die Minderung gehen.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben das ja jetzt auch schon mit den Benzinpreisen. Ich wäre da auch sehr dafür, dass man jetzt da überlegt, wie man da vorgeht, wenn das weiterhin so hoch bleibt, denn das ist für viele eine Belastung. Ich habe jetzt auch mit jemandem gesprochen, der zum Beispiel eine Ausbildung macht, in Mainz und von Darmstadt fahren muss und sehr oft auf das Auto angewiesen ist, weil er zum Teil zu Zeiten da zu sein hat, wo keine Bahn fährt. Und naja, wenn du halt 1200 Euro verdienst im Monat und gibst jetzt plötzlich 50 Euro mehr für Benzin aus, dann ist das sehr erheblich.
Das muss ausgeglichen werden. In Frankreich bekommt man wirklich einfach 100 Euro-Dings in den Briefkasten geschoben. Da muss man nicht mehr beantragen oder so. Da heißt es einfach unter 2000 Euro im Monat Einkommen. Zack, gibt es 100 Euro für Benzin obendrauf. Das ist eine sehr einfache Regelung. In Deutschland gibt es ja alle Kassen, die so was abwickeln könnten. Es wird ja immer wieder behauptet, wir wissen gar nicht, wie man den Leuten Geld zahlen. Aber wir zahlen, das hat der Ulrich Schneider immer wieder betont, wir zahlen so viel Kindergeld, Renten und so weiter. Also da einfach das mit rein Dingsen in diese Geldströme ist ja kein Problem.
Also sie können sich das Geld ja auch holen. Also von daher müssen sie es ja auch in einem anderen Weg auch nutzen können.
Genau, also da gibt es kein Problem. Das muss alles politisch entschieden werden. Das Energiegeld haben sich ja die Grünen gerade so ein bisschen ausreden lassen. Aber mal gucken, das muss ja dann da wieder mit rein. Letzter Clip von Südekum. Der Staat wäre am Ende Miteigentümer und trotzdem wäre es eine private Veranstaltung, die so über die Transfergesellschaft abläuft, Transf, Transformationsfonds abläuft.
Jetzt werde ich noch mal dieses Modell des Transf aufbauen, dass wir eben klar definieren, wie das strukturell im Prinzip aussehen soll, die Beteiligung, das Risiko-Aufteilung zwischen Markt und Staat, welchen Prozentsatz reden wir da. Nebenbei im Chat kam die Frage, wenn der Staat einen Teil des Risikos trägt, was ist denn damit in Erträgen? Ja klar, wenn der staatliche Transf etwa über die KfW bei den Investments sich beteiligt, ist er auch am Profit beteiligt, im Durchschnitt vom Portfolio.
Aber er verdient mit.
Er verdient mit, genau. Also wir haben jetzt das ganze Bild zusammengebaut. Der BDI hat das Geld benannt, hat gesagt, an Technik mangelt es nicht. Südekum sagt, an der ökonomischen Idee mangelt es auch nicht. Und Professor Burchardt hat nochmal gesagt, ja, am Ende ist es so eine Mindset-Frage. Wir brauchen also nochmal so einen öffentlichen Stimmungswandel. Und Olaf Scholz sagt, für all das nehmen wir uns ein Ja. Und jetzt gehen wir mal die Clips durch Habeck bei Lanz vor allem. Es ist ganz interessant, dass Habeck diesen Willen der FDP unbedingt Finanzministerium haben zu wollen. Nicht kontert mit, ich will aber auch, sondern einfach nur mit der Darstellung seiner Kompetenz auf dem neuen Feld, auch für ihn. Und das macht er hier bei Lanz ganz wunderbar. Er beginnt mal zum einen mit diesem Schuldenbremsen-Argument. Die Schuldenbremse steht nicht mehr zur Debatte. Was für uns bedeutet, wissen wir jetzt. Aha, also sind es die Alternativen, zum Beispiel dieser große europäische Transformationsfonds oder viele kleine Transformationsfonds, die in Deutschland aufgezogen werden?
Die Schuldenbremse ist am Wahlabend verloren. Die Reform der Schuldenbremse, die, das hat Herr Schulte richtig gesagt, eigentlich inzwischen, ich würde fast sagen, ökonomisches Mehrheitswissen ist, dass man das anders machen muss, ist durch die Mehrheitsbildung am Wahlabend nicht möglich gewesen, weil da absehbar war, dass die Union in die Opposition geht. Und das wäre eine Verfassungsänderung. Dazu braucht man in jedem Fall die Union. Und die Union wird es nicht tun in der Opposition. Der eigentliche Charme bei einer, darf ich das so sagen, Herr Hentrien, bei einer Wahlniederlage der Union, das war sie ja, von Jamaika wäre gewesen, das vielleicht, oder von Schwarz-Grün wäre gewesen, das hinzubekommen, die Schuldenbremse zu ändern. Aber da war die Union auch nicht bereit dafür. Insofern ist das jetzt nichts, was wir in den Sondierungen verloren haben. Das war am Wahlabend klar, dass das nicht geht.
Ja, also das Sondierungsprogramm ist, wie es ist, weil die CDU in Opposition sich weigern wird, alles Konstruktive mitzumachen. Und deswegen muss man jetzt halt auf Alternativen gehen. Da fand ich ganz erstaunlich, wie ihr jetzt hier im zweiten Clip, zum einen zugesteht, ja, spontanische Sätze im Sondierungsprogramm, aber wir haben echt eine Idee. Die sage ich Ihnen aber noch nicht. Und wir haben ja jetzt thematisiert eigentlich, wie rund so eine Idee dann doch ist, über diese ganzen Transformationsfonds und so weiter zu gehen.
Nochmal gerade darauf zurück, das ist ja interessant. Also er glaubt, dass es da schon bei der Union Leute gäbe, die das auch so gesehen hätten. Er ist da zwar skeptisch, ob das tatsächlich so gelaufen wäre, mit Frau Prien vielleicht, die er da anspricht, aber sicherlich nicht damit allen. Aber das zeigt doch eigentlich, dass dieser Modus, in dem Robin Alexander über die Politik berichtet, also dieses, der hat das gesagt, der hat jetzt noch mal Merkel angerufen, AKK trifft sich heute Abend, ist eine Pizza mit dem und dem. Das ist ja auch eigentlich so ein Modus, die wir jetzt bei der Kühnert-Doku gesehen haben. Man hat den Eindruck, es ist so schrecklich banal und es ist total boulevardesk. Und ich nehme das jetzt auch nicht so wahr, dass ich jetzt so Texte lese von Robin Alexander. Aber wahrscheinlich ist das der Modus, in dem Politik funktioniert.
Am Ende trifft man sich zum Frühstück und prügelt aus, wer Kanzler wird.
Jaja, und aber nicht nur das, sondern auch viele andere Sachen. Und zwischendurch hört Robin Alexander mit.
Ja, und in deren Sicht, man saß schon gut zusammen und hat auch schon viel geklärt. Man konnte es nur noch nicht der Öffentlichkeit sagen.
Verloren ist, dass die Schuldenbremse jetzt nicht das Geld bereitstellt, wie die Reform der Schuldenbremse. Aber das hat Frau Duns richtig gelesen. Es gibt die Aussage, die notwendigen Investitionen für Klimaschutz werden finanziert werden. Das sind die bezifferten 50 Milliarden jährlich oder 500 Milliarden über den Zeitraum, über den man das umsetzen will. Die müssen erbracht werden. Und wir haben natürlich an der Stelle lange, stundenlang darüber geredet, wie das unter Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse gelingen kann. Fairnessgründe sagen, dass ich das jetzt nicht hier aufblättern darf. Aber Frau Neher-Schulte hat darauf hingewiesen, dass eine Reihe von Vorschlägen im Raum sind. Und die stecken den Rahmen der Möglichkeiten ab. Also die öffentlichen, und das ist auch festgelegt, die öffentlichen Investitionen und die privaten Investitionen, und das hängt dabei das zusammen, der öffentliche Euro hebelt ja private Investitionen von großen Unternehmen, von Gebäudesanierungen usw. Das sind ja immer Zuschüsse. Die werden deutlich steigen. Und an der Stelle, wenn auch noch nicht ausformuliert, würde ich sagen, das ist nicht gelbe Handschrift. Ich will dieses Spiel gelbe-grüne Handschrift nicht fortsetzen, aber ich würde sagen, das, was die Wirklichkeit an Notwendigkeiten fordert, ist, wenn auch mit spartanischen Sätzen in diesem Kapitel sehr gut abgebildet.
Da ist man ja fast genaugt zu sagen, ach komm Robert, dann gedulde dich und uns noch einen Monat, bis du es dann sagen darfst. Aber hier so um den heißen Brei herum, aber schon die richtigen Signalworte zu setzen. Und ja, da wird dann gehebelt und privates Geld, öffentliches Geld, wie auch immer. Er ist jedenfalls genervt von dieser Schuldenbremsen-Diskussion und macht ja auch dieses Südekum-Argument hier. Wenn wir Geld ausgeben, dann immer in dem Rahmen, dass wir auch Werte schaffen. Es ist also alles im Butter, was die schwarze Null angeht.
Okay, keine neuen Steuern, Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse. Woher kommen die 50 Milliarden?
Das habe ich gerade erklärt, Herr Lanz. Das eine hat mit dem anderen nichts zu tun. Es war immer unser Programm, die Investition, also das.
Da sitzen immer so Journalisten mit in der Runde, die wissen nicht, wie ihnen geschieht. Ja, verstehen nicht, um was es da geht.
Das ist nämlich dann nur der Robin-Alexander-Modus. Der funktioniert dann nicht, wenn man so was erklärt bekommt.
Genau, das ist ganz erstaunlich.
Was verbaut wird, was Vermögen schafft, das volkswirtschaftliche Vermögen schafft, durch Kredite zu finanzieren. Idealerweise, weil es ehrlich, transparent, der haushaltärischen Wahrheit und Klarheit genügt. Durch eine nachvollziehbare Investitionsregel in der Schuldenbremse. Da das nicht möglich ist, wird man jetzt andere Formen der Finanzierung finden müssen. Aber die Logik ist noch einmal, wenn Sie sich ein Haus kaufen, das kostet 300.000 Euro, Sie haben nur 100.000 Euro, Sie machen 200.000 Euro Schulden, dann haben Sie ja trotzdem das Haus. Das sind zwar Schulden, die Sie dann auf dem Konto haben oder bei der Bank, aber das Haus ist ja da. Wenn wir also jetzt Kredite nehmen, um Ladesäuleninfrastruktur, Glasfaserausbau, Gebäudesanierung, die Schulen, Theater, Bibliotheken auf Vordermann zu bringen, dann schaffen wir ja Werte. Wir werden also nicht ärmer, wenn wir investieren, sondern wir machen das Land klimaneutral und reicher. Das war immer unsere Argumentation. Und dafür, wie privat, wenn Sie ein Haus kaufen, oder was immer Sie sich kaufen, ein Auto, dann nimmt man halt ein Kredit auf. Und dann schafft man ein Wert und so funktioniert Wirtschaft.
Das heißt, ja, und das gelingt eben, indem man nicht blindlings subventioniert, sondern immer eine Investition privat, die eh schon da ist, noch mal stützt, einfach ergänzt. Weil dann ist einfach geregelt, dass da auch ein Wert geschaffen wird, weil man dann das Haus oder den Hochofen als Sicherheit mit auf dem Papier stehen hat. Und dann kommt man da um die schwarze Null drumrum. Und jetzt verweist er auf den großen Systemstreit.
Weil das Europäische und vor allem das US-Amerikanische und das chinesische Ausland agieren völlig anders. Die investieren und gewinnen geopolitische Macht dadurch. Wir verlieren technologischen und damit Wertefortsprung. Wo sind denn die großen europäischen Technik-Player? Wo sind die denn alle? Kommen alle aus Amerika. Und was importieren wir damit? Wir importieren damit eine Sprachkultur, die uns das Leben eher schwer macht. Wo sind die europäischen Werte bei Facebook und Twitter? Ups, ich kann sie nicht finden. Wo ist die europäische Technik beim 5G-Netzausbau? Nur chinesische Technik. Ich kann sie nicht finden. Woran liegt es? Wir sind ökonomisch gerade bei den Zukunftstechnologien zurückgefallen. Woran liegt es? Weil wir glauben, wir können nur das Geld ausgeben, das wir haben, statt zu verstehen, dass die Investition, den Kredit, den wir uns geben, neue Werte schafft, die dann vielfach mehr sich politisch kapitalisieren lassen. Ökonomisch, aber auch wertetechnisch. Wie soll denn Europa bestehen, wenn wir nur noch angewiesen sind auf die Zukunftstechnologien der anderen Länder?
Ich verstehe ja nicht, wie man das nicht verstehen kann. Also das ist mir ein großes Rätsel. Ich kann jetzt noch aus so einem reinen Interessenkalkül bei Unionsleuten oder so nachvollziehen, warum die sich einfach jetzt dagegen stellen, so wie man einfach behauptet, es gibt kein Corona oder so was. Also in dieser Art kann ich das nachvollziehen, was der politische Gegner damit will. Aber dass zum Beispiel so viele Journalisten und hier ihr auch offenbar Lanz, der auch nicht weiß, was hier eigentlich passiert, sich so dagegen sträuben, das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Es ist vor allem verrückt, da wir ja immer eine Klammer gemacht haben zwischen der schwäbischen Hausfrau und Merkels Politik. Und in dem Falle kann man es ja wirklich, wenn auch ein bisschen vulgär ökonomisch mal machen, 100 Prozent der Deutschen haben doch den Wunsch, in einem Eigenheim, ihr im eigenen Haus zu wohnen. Und 90 Prozent müssen das Kredit finanzieren. Und das ist ja genau der Mechanismus. Man zieht schon mal in ein Haus, das einem aber gar nicht gehört. Alle Eigentumsverträge, die da dazugehören, sagen, das gehört der Bank und nach den und den Regeln, nämlich monatlich bezahlen und so weiter gehört, kannst du es verwenden. Und genau so ist das ja hier auch.
Das könnte man hier mal ganz deutlich so machen. Also, wenngleich wir ja um den Unterschied wissen, dass Privathaushalt, Staatshaushalt, Haushalt, vollkommen anders funktionieren. Aber hier ist es absolut so. Und da müsste das doch in jeden Kopf mal einsickern.
Ja, neben ihm, er hat es sich ja schon angesprochen, ist ja die Karin Prien, die in Schleswig-Holstein... Ist sie in Schleswig-Holstein? Dann wäre sie ja mit ihm damals... Naja, woran man so je Ministerin ist. Die reden hier über die Corona-Schulden. Jetzt haben wir ja schon gesehen, der Transformationsfonds für das Klima wäre nach dem Vorbild Corona-Hilfsfonds der EU-Kommission und so weiter zu bauen. Und hier gibt es eben genau diese naive Strittigkeit noch mal zwischen wo kam dieses Geld her?
Wenn die Ideologie die Lösung in der Gegenwart verhindert, dann haben wir wirklich mit die Frauen gehandelt.
Darf ich einmal auf die Denkschule zurückkommen? Das ist genau die Denkschule, die uns ermöglicht hat, jetzt während der Corona-Pandemie solche Rücklagen zu haben, die uns ermöglicht haben, hier wirklich gut und auch sozialverträglich durch die Krise zu kommen. Doch, das stimmt.
In der Corona-Pandemie sind ja Kredite aufgenommen worden, also Schulden gemacht worden.
Ja, aber das hätten wir doch niemals machen können, wenn wir vorher nicht so gewirtschaftet hätten.
Wenn wir nicht am Markt so ein guter Schuldner wären, wenn wir nicht so glaubwürdig wären, wenn wir nicht so kreditwürdig wären, hat sie doch recht.
Wir sind kreditwürdig, weil wir eine starke Volkswirtschaft sind. Weil das Vertrauen der Märkte in den Fleiß der Deutschen und in die staatsbürgerliche Treue der Deutschen so groß ist.
Das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt. Wir merken, da wird noch viel zu besprechen sein.
Es ist wichtig, nicht zu glauben, dass wir in der Corona-Pandemie all die Hilfspakete nur mit Geld, das wir haben, geschnürt haben. Wir haben uns enorme Gelder geliehen, Schulden gemacht, Kredite aufgenommen, ist alles das Gleiche. Und zu Recht, um die zukünftige Leistungsfähigkeit herzuhalten. So nun ist die Corona-Pandemie die eine Krise. Wenn wir die Klimakrise als mindestens so wichtige oder wahrscheinlich größere nehmen, dann sollten wir doch das Gleiche tun.
Ja, fabelhaft. Das ist ja großartig. Prien weiß nicht, wie ihr geschieht. Lanz ist auch total maximal irritiert. Und er hat vollkommen recht. Klar, weil Deutschland ein stabiles Land ist, eine gute Volkswirtschaft ist, alles läuft eigentlich. Kann man da an den Kapitalmärkten alles bekommen. Das ist ja das MMT-Argument. Deswegen funktioniert MMT in Venezuela nicht so gut.
Genau, du kriegst gute Kredite, wenn du gute Sicherheiten hast. Und nicht ein volles Bankkonto, ein volles Fank.
Die haben ja damals ihre Schulden zurückgezahlt. Die sagen einfach, die Wirtschaft ist stabil. Und natürlich können die immer mehr Schulden aufnehmen. Deswegen ist Amerika noch stärker da aufgelegt, weil die noch mehr ausgeben können. Toll, dass er das mal so schön deutlich macht. Und das wünsche ich mir eigentlich. Ich möchte eigentlich morgens Hütte anmachen. Und dass das viral ist. Und nicht Elke Heidenreich, die da im Schlafanzug sitzt. Wieso hatte sie einen Schlafanzug an in der Sendung? Hattest du das gesehen? Sie hatte so ein komisches rotes Samtling an. Das wird am Vorabend aufgezeichnet, oder?
Wenn das Dolly Parton angehabt hätte, wärst du aus dem Häuschen.
Dolly Parton würde so etwas niemals tragen.
Wir wissen ja von Havoc noch nicht genau, was er wird. Wir wissen aber bei Olaf Scholz, was er wird. Und wir hören uns jetzt nochmal, und Olaf Scholz sitzt hier nicht einem CDU-Politiker, wahrscheinlich auch gegenüber, aber es ist vor allem die FAZ-Redaktion in Form von Rainer Hank, also absolut unterirdisch und niveaulos.
Das ist unter meinen marxistischen Freunden ein Quell ewiger Freude. Sie lesen also alle sonntags immer diese Kolumne von Rainer Hank und beömmeln sich.
Es ist schlimm. Rainer Hank ist der schlimmste Wirtschaftsjournalist in Deutschland. Ich habe ihn auch manchmal live erlebt. Das ist unglaublich. Na ja, Olaf Scholz erklärt uns hier nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher, nämlich knapp eine Minute. Alles im ersten Jahr. Wenn ich Kanzler bin, geht es rambazamba los.
Und diese Dinge, die müssen wir alle sofort im ersten Jahr der künftigen Regierung zustande bringen. Das bedeutet, wir müssen das hinkriegen, dass wir alle Gesetze so ändern, alle Planverfahren, alle Genehmigungsverfahren und alle Ausbauziele, dass wir den Anforderungen der Industrie, der Wirtschaft und der Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerecht werden, nämlich Strom aus erneuerbaren Quellen, aus Windkraft auf hoher See, Windkraft an Land, Solarenergie, ein leistungsfähiges Übertragungsstromnetz zur Verfügung stellen, damit das alles klappt. Das ist doch jetzt nicht eine niedliche Veranstaltung, sondern das ist eine solche Modernisierung Deutschlands, wie sie wahrscheinlich am Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts, das letzte Mal in dieser Dimension, stattgefunden hat, als der ganz große industrielle Aufschwung Deutschlands damals stattfand. Unter ganz anderen Umständen. Und das müssen wir jetzt hinkriegen, dass wir das machen. Da darf man das überhaupt nicht gering schätzen. Das ist die größte Modernisierungsaufgabe, die wir für Deutschland haben. Und alle drei Parteien, die jetzt über eine Koalition verhandeln, haben sich exakt das vorgenommen. Das finde ich die richtige Aufgabenstellung zur richtigen Zeit. Und es erfordert viel Kraft für Mut und auch Leadership.
Wo ist der Herr Scholz so mad, der sonst immer gar nichts sagt?
Ich bin ganz verblüfft, wie kann das sein?
Erstaunlich, ne? Plötzlich aus der Position der Stärke heraus.
Naja, und wir kennen ihn ja auch noch aus früheren Jahren, aus nuller Jahren. Das war immer wirklich das Langweiligste überhaupt, was die SPD dann rausschicken konnte. Wenn aber keiner mehr wollte, musste er.
Ja, genau. Und stellt mal vor, wenn es ihm, wenn es, wenn der Ende, wenn das Ende des Weges für ihn nicht ist, Kanzler zu werden, sondern er das nochmal inhaltlich für sich versteht, als so wie bei Ursula von der Leyen, da haben wir auch alle gedacht, das ist ja ganz komisch und so, ist sie da dieses Amt reingestobert und plötzlich hat sie über dieses Amt so entdeckt, halt so und dann ist sie so tatenfroh geworden und so und hat auch die Bundesregierung so ein bisschen vorgeführt. Also in deren Sicht schöpfe ich jetzt auch ein bisschen Zuversicht, ehrlich gesagt. Und jetzt kommt Rainer Hank ins Spiel. Er macht, ist wirklich erstaunlich, er macht ein Argument, dass wir alle seit 800.000 Jahren kennen. Bringt das hier nochmal vor, traut sich in einer Anivelsendung vom Millionenpublikum sich nochmal so die Blöße zu geben und natürlich hat Olaf Scholz darauf dann die richtige Antwort. Und da denken wir wieder an den BDI, Gesinnungswandel, Technologien sind da, sie sind vor allem bei uns da. Wir sind das Hochtechnologieland, wir haben die Ressourcen, auf die es jetzt ankommt, nämlich nicht die fossilen, sondern kognitiv und wie auch immer. Und da verdient er natürlich Punkte bei uns, wenn er reine Hang zerlegt.
Sie tun so, als könnte Deutschland den Klimawandel stoppen. Nein, wissen Sie natürlich auch, dass es nicht geht, aber Sie tun so. Ich habe mir dieser Tage nochmal eine Tabelle angeschaut des IWF. Und da sieht man erstens, dass wenn der Klimawandel bewältigt werden kann, dann geht es um ein internationales Koordinierungsproblem. Sie können vieles Tugendhaftes hier in Deutschland machen und ich bin überhaupt nicht dagegen. Aber man sollte den Horizont und den Rahmen dabei nicht vergessen. Und der Rahmen heißt, noch einmal, internationale Koordinierung und das heißt, wenn wir es nicht schaffen und wenn Sie das nicht international schaffen, einen Klimaclub zu gründen, der klare, ja machen Sie es doch, ich habe es nicht gelesen.
Also jetzt, jetzt muss ich mal, darf ich mal ganz kurz das zu sagen. Erstens, die Idee eines internationalen Klimaclubs wird gerade verhandelt bei G7, G20.
Internationaler Klimaclub, wir haben Weltklimarat und alles Mögliche. Wir haben diese ganzen Treffen und wir wissen, dass Kyoto-Protokoll, das hat Merkel ja jetzt auch noch mal gesagt, nicht so funktioniert hat. Man kriegt die nicht an einen Tisch. Und was ist das für ein lustiger Club, in dem Bolsonaro und Scholz und Habeck oder was man miteinander redet? Also klar, braucht man auf internationaler Ebene diese Bestimmungen, man weiß mit welchen kleinen Schritten das passieren kann. Also dazu behaupten, also das wäre genau, also dann, Rainer Hank ist ja auch sicher jemand, der immer dabei ist, wenn irgendwo ein Interventionskrieg ansteht, da muss Deutschland natürlich immer mit dabei sein, ja. Da könnte man auch mal sagen, ach was sollen wir überhaupt uns mit irgendwas noch, also wir machen jetzt einfach mal so eine generelle Weltfriedenskonferenz, das reicht doch dicker aus. Da würde jeder sagen, naja, aber gut, es gibt schon noch geopolitische Gemengelagen, da wird es schwierig. Aber hier wird dieses Argument so überstraftiziert.
Ja, es ist einfach Banane.
Wo man einfach weiß, nein, Länder wie Deutschland sind auch einfach tonangebend und was dann hier passiert, das hat einen Effekt weltweit. Wie wir ja schon bei der Autoindustrie sehen, nur waren wir da nicht tonangebend, sondern die anderen.
Genau und die Antwort wird sogar noch besser, denn der BDI sagt ja, 860 Milliarden sind zu investieren, damit wir in eine Position kommen, in der wir auf dem Weltmarkt weiter mitspielen können oder ihn sogar dominieren. Das hat ja Rot-Grün damals schon gezeigt, Solartechnik und so weiter, da war ja 50% Marktanteil in Deutschland. So und jetzt hat Rainer Hank sich hier wirklich nicht erblödet nochmal dieses, wir sind ja nur 2% der Welt, reicht das denn, sie brauchen ja den großen Klima-Club, alle müssen mitmachen, ansonsten bringt das ja gar nichts. Und jetzt hat man schon, also wir sehen ihn hier, wie Olaf Scholz schon nach vorne rückt auf seinen Sessel und in Angriffsposition geht und dann schießt er hier zurück.
Denn wir werden ja mit keinem Geld der Welt, Afrika, Asien, den Süden Amerikas, davon überzeugen können, dass sie auf den Wohlstand, den wir haben, verzichten, das wollen sie auch erreichen. Wir werden sie also nur davon abbringen, das alles mit Kohlekraftwerken zu tun, überall in der Welt zum Beispiel, indem wir billige, genauso leistungsfähige Alternativen technologisch entwickeln. Aber wenn in einem der erfolgreichsten Industrieländer der Welt, nämlich Deutschland, plötzlich Stahl produziert wird, klimaneutral, Chemieindustrie gemacht wird, klimaneutral, es gelingt, dass der Maschinenbau, die Automobilindustrie Produkte anbietet, die das können, wir auch unsere Energieversorgung so gewährleisten können, dann ist das unser bescheidener Beitrag für die Welt, dass wir nämlich die zeigen, es geht und die Technologien marktfähig machen, die dann weltweit genutzt werden können, mit dem kleinen, gar nicht so schlechten Nebeneffekt, dass wir vielleicht sogar als Volkswirtschaft davon für unsere Exportleistungsfähigkeit von profitieren können.
Habext ist neben ihm, hört andächtig zu. Es ist ganz erstaunlich, was er hier sagt und ist absolut das richtige Argument. Denn nur so kann es überhaupt gehen. Das ist ja auch mein Vorwurf an viele Postwachstumsökonomien, dass sie zwar hier einfach so oft verzichten und so weiter aus sind und dann aber diese globale Perspektive gar nicht kennen und einfach wissen, da werden Leute zu Wohlstand kommen, tun es ja gerade ganz massiv in Indien und in China und hoffentlich dann auch mal irgendwann in Afrika in größerem Ausmaß. Und da wird konsumiert werden und da wird auch produziert werden müssen. Und da stellt sich die Frage, mit welchen Technologien. Und wenn die nicht von hier kommen und wenn die nicht hier diese grüne Transformation durchgemacht haben, dann wird die Umweltverpestung unendlich groß sein. Und wir haben keine moralische Möglichkeit, das zu stoppen, weil wir haben uns die ganze Zeit schon an der Natur vergangen. Insofern ist das auch unsere einzige halbwegs noch gute Möglichkeit, zu sagen, naja, wir wissen, was wir da getan haben, aber jetzt haben wir noch das wenigstens anzubieten, der Welt, und die wird zugreifen, wenn es günstig ist, wenn es sich lohnt. Da sind dann wieder privatwirtschaftliche Motive die Entscheidenden.
Ja, das ist ganz brutal, wie Rainer Hank hier abgemeldet ist. Der BDI sitzt ja im Grunde da und sagt, Rainer, müssen wir dich echt anrufen, um es dir zu erklären? Wir haben hier einen Mehrbedarf, der muss finanziert werden. Wir brauchen der für Olaf Scholz. Er macht genau das, was wir wollen gerade. Die Koalition wird sich so finden. Und wenn es gut ausgeht, haben wir in 20 Jahren die Technologien geschaffen, die für weitere 80 Jahre den Afrikanern sagen, und mit Afrikanern meine ich jetzt mal wirklich den ganzen Kontinent, eure Bevölkerungsexplosion, die ja projiziert ist von mehr als 2 Milliarden zusätzlichen Menschen, werden wir mit einer Energie bewerkstelligen können, die billiger ist, als auf fossile Brennstoffe zurückzugreifen, ein Loch wie in Köln oder da vor Leipzig zu graben, wird für euch wahnsinnig sein, weil ihr könnt doch einfach unsere coolen Solardächer benutzen. Die machen es viel billiger, die sind mobil, die kann man auf- und abbauen, wie man sie braucht, wie auch immer. Und das ist ja eigentlich die Idee, das hat Olaf Scholz ja hier eindeutig so gesagt. Wir müssen Technologien schaffen, die diffusilen Alternativen, rausnehmen aus der ökonomischen Rechnung, weil sie sich nicht mehr rechnen. Wenn das nicht gelingt, also wenn dieser technologische Sprung in Deutschland nicht gelingt, in Europa und nur hier kann er gelingen, klar, Amerika und China machen auch mit, also dann wird Afrika die Welt verpesten.
Und wir werden uns dazu beitragen. Wir haben dann schon ganz viel, da kommt noch unseres dazu und Indien und China kommen dazu. Das heißt, das wird so massiv werden, dann brauchen wir wirklich nicht mehr groß nachdenken, was wir machen, sondern dann ist Land unter angesagt. Aber ich finde es schön, dass Rainer Hank so eine Rechercheleistung suggeriert, dass er nochmal nachgeguckt hat. Ich habe noch mal gestern nachgeguckt, dass Deutschland nicht das größte Land der Welt ist und deswegen nicht so einen großen Beitrag leisten kann.
Ja, also Rainer Hank ist ganz gefährlich, weil er damit für CDUler und so weiter, die es auch nicht verstanden haben, einfach Wählerstimmen mobilisiert, die das komplett utopidieren.
Das ist für mich auch nicht jetzt hier ausgleichende Positionen oder so. Also für mich ist ja eine sinnvolle Talkshow-Zusammenstellung, jetzt wenn dort ein MMTler sitzt, wenn da ein Südekum sitzt und wenn da ein Habeck sitzt und vielleicht so. Also solche Leute, die jetzt verschiedene Vorschläge machen, aber sich in so einem Grundkonsens dann einig sind. Wir kommen ja gleich auf dieses Thema Grundkonsens und so was noch zu sprechen. Aber es ist nicht jetzt für mich eine Pluralität, wenn ich einfach noch jemanden dahinsetze, der ihres Zeug von sich gibt.
Ich meine, in der Sendung, die wir vorhin mit Habeck bei Ilna geguckt haben, war noch Münkler zugeschaltet als akademische Stimme. Wo man sich fragt, gibt es keine Ökonom, die man jetzt mal reinholt? Wenn Lindner mit Habeck da diskutieren, kann man das dann nicht mal. Es ist halt einfach bescheuert.
Ja, ich meine, Adam Toos steht ja auch zur Verfügung.
Zum Beispiel?
Er spricht perfekt Deutsch. Junge MMTler-Stimmen zur Verfügung. MMTler waren noch gar nicht in Talkshows vertreten. Es ist auch interessant, dass man das noch immer so geschafft hat, ganz rauszuhalten.
Ja, Toos soll ja wirklich mal, gerade weil er sich publizistisch da noch mal in die deutsche Geschichte so reingewurschtet hat, einfach noch mal präsenter sein. Jetzt mit seinem Text, den er mit Stieglitz geschrieben hat, gab es ja gleich wieder Vorwürfe auch von Südekum, ob das so klug ist, das von außen zu machen. Aber ich würde sagen, nö, jetzt ist gerade die Zeit all in.
Man muss das machen. Es ist sehr lustig. Ich habe Fehler, das jedem nachzulesen. Man kann ihn ja online lesen, Englisch ohne Bezahlschranke. Und da gibt es so eine wunderbare Passage. Ole, ich hatte dich schon gepostet. Wie es so ist, wenn man die beiden Administrationen, alles ja Veteranen der Obama-Ära eigentlich, wenn man die darauf anspricht, wie waren das damals so, als ihr diskutiert hattet, dann mit Schäuble und Brüderle. Und dann werden traumatische Erinnerungen wach. Es war eine Horrorshow. So wird das dann bestildert.
Ophakis, auch immer schon beschrieben. Aber jetzt aus allen Richtungen. Da wird jetzt aus allen Rohren geschossen. Und das ist auch genau richtig so. Denn die Inkompetenz der CDU von März, und wie sie alle heißen muss, als einfach dargestellt.
Das ist auch so schön, dass es vom Ausland kommt. Denn du weißt, wir sind ein Volk, das sehr viel Wert darauf legt, dass man uns im Ausland gut ansieht. Und es war immer die Argumentation von der Union, wenn irgendwas kam von links gerade was Pazifistisch oder so. Was wird man im Ausland über uns denken? Was werden die amerikanischen Freunde über uns denken? Und hier erfahren wir jetzt mal, was die amerikanischen Freunde über die deutsche Wirtschaftspolitik und vor allem die deutsche EU-Wirtschaftspolitik so denken.
Ja, in deren Sicht ist auch Merkel noch nicht ordentlich verabschiedet. Und wir können auch kurz ein Wort zu Weitmann verlieren. Das ist natürlich irgendwie auch, wie soll man sagen, ein Segen, dass die neue Koalition...
Dass die Bundesbank jetzt einen neuen Chef suchen muss.
Ja, und vor allem, das jetzt schon geklärt ist, man kann nur über eines bestimmen, FDP. Entweder Finanzminister oder Bundesbank. Und ich würde fast sagen, der Bundesbank-Posten ist wichtiger. Denn die Pflöcke sind jetzt eingeschlagen fürs Finanzministerium.
Würdest du sagen? Ich bin mir da noch unsicher, ob das... Also ich kann nicht so richtig abschätzen, wie wirkmächtig so ein Bundesbank-Chef dann ist. Also er war so ein Störenfried halt dauerhaft. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob nicht dann doch der Finanzminister, wenn er grün besetzt würde durch Habeck, noch mal mehr ausrichten könnte, als wenn man da jetzt einen installieren würde, der den Grünen gewogen ist oder diesen Investitionen gewogen ist.
Also wir hatten damals im Aufwarnpodcast überlegt, was ist eigentlich wichtiger, EU-Kommissionsposten oder EZB? Wurde ja zeitgleich besetzt. Und das ist ja wirklich strittig. Die Frage ist ja auch, was es geht. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie lang die EZB braucht, nämlich nur drei Tage, um 1, 8 Billionen locker zu machen oder ein Programm zu starten, das dann sich so aufläuft und dass die EU-Kommission erst mal drei Gipfel abwarten muss, um auf ihre 750 Milliarden revolutionäre Eigenmittelbeschaffung kommt, würde ich sagen.
Stimmt, das ist absolut. Aber würdest du sagen, dass die Bundesbank diese Schlagkraft hat? Weil ich irgendwie den Eindruck hatte, bei den Weitmann-Auftritten, vielleicht war es aber auch nur so ein Empfinden, dass die Bundesbank durch dieses starke Wirken der EZB schon so geschwächt ist, dass die irgendwie so mitrennen müssen.
Also die Bundesbank ist immer noch ein Drittel EZB.
Okay.
Also sie gilt ja so als Anteilseigner und Deutschland ist so gigantisch. Wir haben ja den Finanzbedarf 2, 6 Billionen und 860 davon entfallen auf Deutschland. Also das ist schon ein Drittel, zwei Drittel im Verhältnis. Und die Bundesbank fährt ja eigentlich weit und also das eine Stimmrecht Deutschlands da im Gremium ist ja weit unter der eigentlichen Bedeutung Deutschlands und in deren Sicht ist jemand wie Weidmann, von dem ich mir mittlerweile auch echt unsicher bin, ob er das nur noch für die Öffentlichkeit so gespielt hat, da immer dagegen zu sein, um dann lagart zu sagen, klar was soll ich sonst machen? Ich habe ja keinen besseren Vorschlag. Klar müssen wir jetzt eine Billion hier raushauen an die Märkte, damit die da und ja, das bedeutet halt am Ende, dass 30 Prozent aller Staatsanleihen Europas bei der ECB liegen und damit im Grunde aus der Rechnung rausgenommen werden. Es kommt jetzt alle darauf zu sprechen, dass ja die Österreicher so einen tollen Trick haben mit 100-jährigen Staatsanleihen, also 99-Jährige, wo man sich denkt, naja gut, 99-jährige Staatsanleihen oder 30 Prozent der Schuldensumme liegt bei der ECB, die sie nie einfordern wird, ist ja dann auch egal, also da ist die Trickserei schon gilt jetzt für alle Staaten. Und ich würde sagen, wir nehmen ganz ernst, dass Jens Südekum sagt, das ist ein europäisches Projekt mit dem Transformationsfonds. Wir wissen von Tragoy und Macron, dass die am liebsten jetzt sofort und die sind heil froh, dass Merkel weg ist. Denn egal, wer in Deutschland als neuer Kanzler kommt, er muss sich erstmal einfinden. Jetzt kriegen sie Scholz, der aber hier schon auf Linie ist, das als Einjahresprojekt sieht, alles institutionell vorzubereiten. Und in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, kann der Finanzminister jetzt, das wird alles so festgezurrt, dass, und ich meine, du musst dir überlegen, du wirst Finanzminister unter Kanzler Olaf Scholz, der vier Jahre lang dein Haus hatte, der jede Telefonnummer kennt. Und so, ja, was willst du als Finanzminister groß machen, außer eine öffentliche Show abziehen? In der Ansicht würde ich sagen, ja, die FDP muss noch eine öffentliche Show abziehen, um Gesichtswahren durch die Sachen zu kommen.
Das könnte doch wirklich wie Stieglitz und Tuus vorschlagen mit so einem lustigen digitalen Ministerium, wo mal alles irgendwie gemacht werden kann.
Werden sich nicht mit abspeisen lassen. Aber dass sie nicht beides besetzen können, dass sie, wenn sie den Finanzministeriumsposten bekommen, auf jeden Fall die Bundesbank verlieren und dann vielleicht wirklich immer ein Visabelschnabel oder so da sitzt, wo einfach klar ist, jetzt geht auch die EZB wieder im Gleichschritt und nicht immer mit so einem öffentlichen Theater irgendwie. Das ist doch alles gut und in der Hinsicht, diese Green Bond Sache wird jetzt geregelt. Also die Klassifizierung der Investitionsmöglichkeiten kommt noch dieses Jahr. Das ist also jetzt, wenn er dann seine Weihnachtsansprache gehalten wird und die Arbeit beginnt, ist das alles in trockenen Tüchern. Und dann müssen halt nur noch die paar Entscheidungen getroffen werden und in deren Sicht, finde ich, ist alles insgesamt auf einem guten Weg. Ich bin irgendwie zuversichtlicher als die letzten zehn Jahre. Seit 2008 überlegen wir, was hier abging mit Griechenland 2015 und so. Und jetzt so eine Situation.
Es geschehen noch Zeichen und Wunder, auch in den Geisteswissenschaften. Denn wir sprechen jetzt über ein Thema, das vielleicht gar nicht so nahe liegen wird bei den Neuen Zwanzigern, weil wir sowas noch nie aufgegriffen haben. Also Philosophen kommen eher mal am Rande bei uns vor. Damals bei der Corona-Krise. Na ja, du hattest das Guck von Peter Sloterdijk jetzt empfohlen sehr. Und wir wollen heute über den Antipoden von Peter Sloterdijk sprechen. Es ist Jürgen Habermas. Jürgen Habermas ist der wichtigste Philosoph. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es der bedeutendste deutsche Philosoph ist des 20. Jahrhunderts. Und jetzt auch 21. Jahrhunderts. Der Mann ist 92 Jahre alt. Er ist auf jeden Fall der wichtigste. Insofern, als er weltweit der am meisten rezipierte deutsche Philosoph ist, in China, USA, überall kennt man Habermas. Seine Werke sind übersetzt, werden zitiert. Und er ist immer noch aktiv, hat zwei große Bände veröffentlicht, jetzt zu Religionsphilosophie vor zwei Jahren. Jetzt im Alter von 92 Jahren, da publiziert er einen Aufsatz und setzt sich noch einmal mit seinem Bestseller auseinander, aus dem Jahr 1962. Das war der Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit. Und es scheint so, als würde sich dieser 92-jährige Philosoph nun ein wenig revidieren.
Das wäre natürlich krass, denn sein ganzes Werk ruht auf seiner Dissertation zum Strukturwandel. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe nichts davon mitbekommen, von dieser Debatte. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wo die Clips herkommen, ob wir ihnen jetzt reden hören.
Leider nicht, dazu komme ich gleich, aber wir fangen vielleicht erst mal mit dem Antipoden an. In der Fachzeitschrift Leviathan ist dieser Habermas-Aufsatz erschienen. Ich bin aufmerksam geworden durch einen Artikel in der FAZ, der ist am vergangenen Mittwoch erschienen, der ist überschrieben mit Die Wüsten Geräusche von Oliver Weber. Und der hat sich diesen Aufsatz genauer angesehen. Und daraufhin hat er mich so interessiert, dass ich mir den auch gleich bestellt habe. Also man kann den über Uni-Bibliotheken bekommen. Dann also dieses Buch, wenn man es selbst kaufen will, in dieser Sonderausgabe müsste man 99 Euro ausgeben. Das ist ein bisschen viel für so eine Fachzeitschrift. Das ist ein eigenartiges Publikationswesen. Aber gut, man kommt auf öffentlichem Wege dann ran, wenn man möchte. Ich würde aber gerne erst etwas aufgreifen, nämlich Peter Sloterdijk. Das ist der große Gegner von Habermas. Seit Jahrzehnten streiten sie sich, beziehungsweise Habermas greift ihn auch immer wieder an. Es gab damals so eine Rede, Regeln zum Menschenpark, bei der Habermas dann, als er von dieser Rede hörte, Sloterdijk vorwarf bzw. dann auch vorwerfen ließ, dass er hier an Selektionen wohl wiederdenke und so weiter und so fort. Also man versucht immer, Sloterdijk zu skandalisieren, aus dem liberaldemokratischen Konsens zu entfernen. Sloterdijk amüsiert das eher. Und nun hat die Zeitschrift für Ideengeschichte, also auch eine Fachzeitschrift, eine Habermas-Ausgabe rausgebracht, wo Intellektuelle sich an Habermas erinnern. Und in dieser Zeitschrift abgedruckt sind auch Transkripte von Exzepten, die Peter Sloterdijk gemacht hat, als er in den 70er Jahren Habermas-Werke inhalierte, muss man sagen. Unter anderem auch Struktur, Wandel der Öffentlichkeit. Und anlässlich des Erscheins dieser Zeitschrift wurde er jetzt vor wenigen Wochen interviewt. Man kann das bei YouTube sehen. Und da hören wir uns jetzt ein paar Stellen so an. Er ist also immer noch der Feind von Habermas. Aber jetzt beschreibt er erst mal, wie er studentisch gearbeitet hat. Das ist ganz schön.
Ich weiß nur eines, dass ich seinerzeit die Definition eines gründlichen Studenten erfüllt oder übererfüllt habe. Unter anderem eben dadurch, dass ich Lektüren nicht einfach nur dem Gedächtnis anvertraut habe, sondern ob das jetzt ein memotechnischer Trick war oder eine andere Form der Aneignungskunst. Ich musste alles, was ich gelesen habe, selber noch einmal schreiben, in reduzierten Versionen, aber meistens doch von einer ziemlich erschreckenden Ausführlichkeit, sodass ich die frühen Hauptwerke von Habermas, Strukturwettel der Öffentlichkeit an erster Stelle, der Erkenntnis und Interesse wirklich minutiös mit dem Finger auf der Zeile.
Fast nachgezeichnet.
Ja, gewissermaßen nachgezeichnet, fast durchgepaust.
Er geht sogar so weit zu sagen, eigentlich war das zu einer Zeit so, dass er Habermas hätte perfekt imitieren können. Und er versteht Bell Trachy, der eine gewisse Lust daran hat, die alten Meister zu imitieren. Aber er ist ja dann einen ganz anderen Weg gegangen und hat sich auch stilistisch von Habermas so weit entfernt, wie man es nur irgendwie kann.
Aber das begegnet einem ja immer wieder. André Kieserling, der ja dann später auch auf Luhmann folgte in Bielefeld, hat ja auch, da haben wir uns stilistisch immer drüber lustig gemacht, aber er konnte es sehr gut, wirklich einfach Luhmann imitiert. Er kannte die Sätze, um die es dann geht, so perfekt, dass er sie einfach in Reaktionen auf Wortbeiträge, andere, die sie verwendet haben, nochmal aus dem Gedächtnis vortrug und dann dazu sagte, was Luhmann eigentlich damit gemeint hatte. Also Wortlaut und Kommentar gleich dazu geliefert. Das war immer sehr beeindruckend in deren Sicht, gibt es da schon so einen gewissen Fanatismus unter diesen Geisteswissenschaftlern.
Wir werden uns diese besondere Habermas-Syntax nachher mal anhören, wie das dann so klingt. Ich habe das mit Mühe eingelesen, denn es ist tatsächlich nicht leicht, diese Texte zu lesen. Aber jetzt nochmal Slotardyke, der jetzt so ein bisschen mal Habermas einordnen will.
Und obwohl mir immer klar war, dass das Habermas eigentlich kein Primärphilosoph ist, sondern dass er jemand ist, der von der Sozialphilosophie her sich in die Philosophie hinein bewegt, war er auf jeden Fall eine Instanz, die für mich und für einen Teil der Generation, zu der ich gehört habe, so etwas wie Niveauerziehung hat ausrichten können.
Niveauerziehung finde ich ein sehr, sehr schönes Wort. Und das ist auch etwas, was man, wenn man Habermas liest, erfahren kann. Es ist erstaunlich, was er alles rezipiert und auf welchem Niveau er generell argumentiert. Wenngleich ich mit dieser Philosophie nie so viel anfangen könnte, würde ich mir jetzt nicht ganz den Primärphilosophen absprechen wollen. Aber für mich war das immer ein bisschen langweilig. Macron und viele weitere Politiker hingegen sind große Fans von Habermas. Denn, um das mal deutlich zu machen und damit auch zu verkürzen, Habermas ist eigentlich der staatstragende Philosoph, insofern als er eine Theorie ausarbeitet, wie ein liberal-demokratisches System, wie zum Beispiel unseres, funktionieren kann, durch einen öffentlichen Diskurs, durch uns als Bürger, die wir partizipieren, durch Meinungen, die gebildet wird durch Massenmedien, dazu kommen wir gleich noch, dann aber auch durch Parteien, die für verschiedene Meinungen aufgreifen und wie sich daraus ein liberal-demokratischer Rahmen ergibt, der eine rationale Argumentation jederzeit ermöglicht. Und jetzt frage ich dich schon mal und nehme das jetzt schon mal vorweg. Du als Talkshow-Gucker oder Hörer, muss ich ja viel mehr sagen. Da hat man schon den Eindruck, das ist ein schönes Ideal eigentlich, aber die Realität ist doch eine sehr, sehr andere.
Ja, also ich konnte mit dieser ganzen T-Stuben-Verherrlichung nie so richtig was anfangen. Er hat ja dann doch hinter der Sprache, klar Niveauerziehung, wie macht man ordentliche Wissenschaft und so weiter, er hat sich selber aus der Wissenschaft, und da würde ich jetzt sagen, Philosophie ist dann doch mehr so, aus der Soziologie, da sich er selber verabschiedet. Und naja, ich würde sagen, Habermas holt uns als Menschen alle nochmal ab, die wir ihn konsumieren. Und in deren Sicht liegt es irgendwie nahe den Ursprung der modernen Welt oder auch sozusagen, die Zeit läuft irgendwie zurück zu binden auf, wie sich Menschen verhalten. Ja, es beginnt dann so in diesen T-Stuben bei Sammensein, Gesellschaft in Interaktion zu entwickeln, seine ganzen, ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie es heißt, seine Kriterien hier, seine fünf Dingstabums, alle wissen, worum es geht, Wahrheit, Wahrhaftigkeit und so weiter und so fort. Ich konnte mich da immer nur drüber lustig machen.
Genau, wie so ein kommunikatives Handeln idealerweise funktioniert. Da gibt es Kriterien zu. Und du hast jetzt gerade von T-Stuben gesagt, also die Salons sind das Entscheid, also die bürgerlichen Salons, also alles, was nach 1789 dann erblüht, die bürgerlichen Salons, wo resoniert wird über das politische, über das kulturelle, aber auch also die literarischen Salons, die finden statt und die konstituieren eine Bürgerlichkeit, die eine Voraussetzung auch dafür ist, dass ein gutes liberal-demokratisches Partizipieren gewährleistet ist. Wir werden jetzt gleich auf genau diese Salons zu sprechen kommen, denn du hast schon gerade jetzt gesagt, analoges Twitter. Und das ist die ganze Zeit die große Frage gewesen. Deswegen machen wir das hier überhaupt. Habermas hat das ausgearbeitet und war aber mit dieser Ausarbeitung eigentlich fertig, als die Digitalisierung begann, als das Internet begann. Und dann kann man sagen, hat Habermas zwar unendlich viel publiziert zu allen möglichen Fragen, aber er hat zu dieser Thematik geschwiegen, was heißt denn das jetzt eigentlich, Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit bezogen auf das digitale Zeitalter? Ist das jetzt so eine Rückkehr des bürgerlichen Salons? Also wir haben ja hier im Podcast einen Salon, wo wir beide uns unterhalten über Texte verständigen. Das ist ziemlich nah an diesem Idealbild. Habermas würde sagen, der Salon könnte größer sein. Also wir würden dann mit mehreren Leuten reden, so wie das in literarischen Salons üblich war.
Genau, das ist ganz wichtig.
Aber die Frage ist, ob das im digitalen Zeitalter möglich ist. Das lassen wir jetzt mal noch so dahingestellt, denn das ist das große Thema seines Aufsatzes. Wir hören aber noch weiter, denn Habermas war ein Abkömmling der Frankfurter Schule bzw. ist auch nächste Generation Frankfurter Schule. Sloterdijk charakterisiert das folgendermaßen.
So etwas wie ein Primus inter pares unter den Begabteren einer Generation, die fest davon überzeugt waren, dass Adorno das Niveau markiert, während Habermas sozusagen die Assistenzstelle besetzt. Das war jetzt nicht nur ein akademischer Zufall, der dies bewirkt hat, sondern es war fast so etwas wie eine Rollenverteilung in einem zeitgeschichtlichen Drehbuch.
Ja, und Habermas, wir haben es schon gehört, ist nur Primärphilosoph und Sloterdijk wird dann noch mal deutlicher.
Das Exerpt ist ja auch eine studentische Gattung, die auch noch mal in der Nachkriegszeit blühte. Und Habermas selbst, das ist ja beeindruckend und imponierend, wie er Wissensstoff natürlich auch auf seine Theorie hinlesen kann, aber wie er einfach auch aus Philosophie Exerptliteratur macht.
Ja, aber auf seine Weise in diesen Jahren war er so etwas wie ein Genie der Paraphrase. Ich glaube nicht, dass er im ganzen Leben einen originellen Gedanken gedacht hat.
Ja, das hat gesessen. Genie der Paraphrase, nie einen originellen Gedanken gedacht. Also Sotadeik nimmt das natürlich für sich in Anspruch, originelle Gedanken zudenken und hat sich dann ja auch ganz abgesetzt von Frankfurter Schule oder so, ist zwar im selben Verlag, ist zwar auch bei Suhrkamp, aber ist ein ganz anderer Suhrkamp-Autor. Und Sotadeik wird dann auch ein Bestseller bei Suhrkamp mit seinem Buch Kritik der zynischen Vernunft Anfang der 80er Jahre. Das beunruhigt Habermas. Habermas will natürlich seine Schule vor allem etabliert sehen und fürchtet sich auch ein bisschen vor dem, was aus Frankreich da kommt mit den Poststrukturalisten. Es gibt ja eine lange Auseinandersetzung auch mit Derrida oder auch eine große Kritik an Foucault, die ziemlich gut ist. Also da würde ich sagen, ist Habermas sehr, sehr genau und sehr gründlich in dieser Foucault-Lektüre. Und es schildert jetzt mal hier, Kritik der zynischen Vernunft kommt raus, ist erfolgreich. Und Habermas will jetzt, und wir müssen das immer so gleich schon im Rahmen sehen, was können wir im Diskurs noch machen? Wir hatten jetzt auch wieder so ein Thema, was ist im Diskurs erlaubt, wer darf da keinen Platz finden und so. Wir haben das ja allenthalben. Und wir haben das eigentlich jetzt hier auch noch mal. Also jetzt kommt jemand, der schreibt eine Kritik der zynischen Vernunft, setzt sich von der Frankfurter Schule deutlich ab, hat da auch viele Spitzen in dem Werk. Und Habermas versucht jetzt noch mal was, Stotadeig Schildertz.
Ich glaube, es war von seiner Seite her ein Versuch, die Alternativszene näher an die kritische Theorie heran zu ziehen, indem er ein Buch, das einen gewissen Kultwert sehr schnell entwickelt hat in dieser subkulturellen Dimension. Also ich denke schon, dass Sie recht haben mit der Vermutung, dass es ein Einordnungsversuch war begleitet von dem Wunsch, es möge eigentlich keine neue Stimme geben. Es soll auch keine neue Position geben können.
Und eigentlich auch keinen neuen Autor fügt Sloterdijk dann an. Und damit ist dann gemeint, dass Habermas also da einen Konkurrenten sah. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht nur so zu verstehen, sondern es ist wirklich auf so einer diskursiven Ebene, was braucht der liberaldemokratische Diskurs und was ist gefährlich? Und Sloterdijk ist ja jemand, der immer mit den, ich will mal sagen, bösen Philosophen auch geliebeäugelt hat, der gesagt hat, wenn jetzt alle gerade Marx lesen, lese ich Max Stirner. Wenn alle gerade sich mit Sozialdemokratie beschäftigen, warum nicht mal sich mit den Libertäern auseinandersetzen? Also Sloterdijk ist immer jemand, der eigentlich die Gefahr in der Philosophie will, während Habermas, das haben auch Peter Trafny und Slawe Szcziszek mal so gesagt, eigentlich jemand ist, der die Gefahr aus der Philosophie verbannen möchte.
Ja genau, ich habe es gerade versucht, herauszufinden, aber ich weiß nicht mehr wo. In irgendeinem FAZ-Text oder so habe ich mal Habermas vorgeworfen, bei den Geltungsansprüchen einen zu übersehen und das ist Unterhaltsamkeit, Entertainment. Denn klar, wir kommunizieren alle miteinander, sitzen so bei Samu und dann wird immer geprüft, ist das wahr, wahrhaftig und was sind die weiteren? Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr, weil mir das alles so fern liegt. Und diesen Anspruch sollte auch unterhaltend sein, der spielte da einfach keine Rolle. Und unter der Maßgabe finde ich das wahnsinnig interessant, dass Habermas ja eigentlich von zwei Seiten Kritik erfuhr. Einerseits von Niklas Luhmann, der ihm einfach ein Gesamtkunstwerk Gesellschaftstheorie vor die Füße gesetzt hat, wo Habermas dann selber nicht mehr wusste, wie gehe ich denn jetzt damit um? Okay, ich verabschiede mich immer aus der Wissenschaft, also aus der Soziologie. Und dann auf der anderen Seite, Sloterdijk, der immer versucht, wie so ein guter Theaterkritiker, in seinem eigenen Text unterhaltungswert einzubauen, wenn auch nur für eine kleine Klientel, aber die kannte er. Deswegen lese ich das ja auch wahnsinnig gerne und wundere mich dann, ah, sprechen kann er also auch. Also selbst wenn es ein Gesprächsband ist, ist das noch irgendwie, oder man hört ja auch hier wieder solche Wortschöpfungen wie Primärphilosophie, sowas gibt es gar nicht. Er setzt das dann einfach mal so als Grundbegriff, um da so einen Haken zu schlagen und so. Genau, und dazwischen geht Habermas total verloren. Denn entweder will ich was verstehen, was mir selbst durch Nachdenken nicht gelingt, dann lese ich Niklas Luhmann und wende das an. Oder ich will unterhalten werden und dann gehe ich zu Slaughterlike. Und dann kriege ich was tagesaktuelles irgendwie so hingesetzt, wo ich dann denke, das ist aber ganz unterhaltsam, dann vergesse ich das aber auch wieder. Und Habermas ist eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer irgendwo dazwischen. Vor allem mit seinen frühen Sachen, seinen Theoriearbeiten. Also ich war das nicht mal so richtig als Theorie.
Aber Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit ist ja auch eine historische Herleitung. Also Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit beschreibt, wie sich mit der Entstehung des bürgerlichen Zeitalters eine Öffentlichkeit herausbildet, die auch medial vermittelt, dann irgendwann massenmedial vermittelt, ihre Meinung bildet. Und da, glaube ich, hat er auch einfach historisch schon mal sehr viel geleistet, um aufzuzeigen, welchen Stellenwert Salons hatten, welchen Stellenwert dann Zeitungen haben. Und er beschreibt dann auch sehr gut diese monopolkapitalistischen Strukturen, die sich in den 50er- 60er-Jahren dann ja auch entsprechend durchsetzen im Verlagswesen, im Zeitungswesen. Und wie dadurch auch eigentlich, und das ist die große These von Habermas, da es eine Entwicklung gibt, weg vom resonierenden Publikum, das ist das, was in Salons miteinander disputiert, hin zum rein konsumierenden Publikum, das also einfach so schluckt und frisst. Und das ist eines, was aber nicht eigentlich gemacht ist für diese liberale Demokratie, weil die auf Diskurs aus ist und nur so kann Meinungsbildung entstehen. Und das ist eine große Kritik, die er in starker Form äußert in den 60er-Jahren. Und das nimmt er dann in einem Nachwort etwas zurück. Dann noch mal drei Jahrzehnte später, glaube ich, wo er sagt, na ja, das war vielleicht ein bisschen stark noch. Da war er sicherlich noch mehr von der alten Frankfurter Schule geprägt. Und dann schwächt er das ab. Und die Frage ist jetzt, wie ist denn heute unser Medienkonsum, wo wir nicht nur Konsumierende sind, sondern wir auch natürlich Partizipierende sind, in der Form, dass wir Kommentare schreiben, selbst Podcasts aufnehmen, was auch immer.
Genau, also ich bin super gespannt darauf, was gleich von Habermas selbst dazu zu hören ist. Dass du dafür auch so ein Faible hast, das ist ja total nachvollziehbar. Denn gerade das Kino, da muss man sich überlegen, okay, Habermas beginnt so mit dem Salon, das mit sich im Gespräch seiende Publikum eines was auch immer, einer Politik, eines Gottes oder eines fremden Schicksals. So, und dann versucht man da irgendwie so zu steuern. Und klar, dann versuchst du zu argumentieren in der großen Filmanalyserarbeit zum Beispiel, zu sagen, nee, eigentlich wird jetzt da Gesellschaft verhandelt, wo Menschen zwar hingehen, aber dann in so einer Dunkelkammer schweigend beieinander sitzen und gar nicht miteinander reden, sondern einfach zwei Stunden was konsumieren, was wo ganz anders auf der Welt entstanden ist. Und man kennt, man weiß gar nicht, für wen hat man den Film gemacht, aber man hofft halt, dass es funktioniert. So, und da hat das totale Attraktivität, solche Gedankengänge, auch diese historischen Entwicklungen, wie entsteht ein Film, das ist ja auch eine Technikgeschichte und so weiter, spielt da alles mit rein. Nur als Soziologe denke ich mir halt immer, wozu brauche ich das alles, wenn ich auch einfach ein funktionales Argument nachlesen kann? Also wenn ich einfach ein Luhmann Buch aufmache, im Sachwortregister nachschaue oder dann Luhmann Lexikon oder was weiß ich, es gibt ja auch sehr viele, die sich wirklich verdient gemacht haben, die Luhmann arbeiten, so ein bisschen aufzuarbeiten, dass man nicht so reingesogen wird in den Text, sondern wirklich mal an Begriffen sich was herleiten kann und so. Und da zerbröselt halt so was wie Habermas sofort in den Fingern irgendwie im Vergleich dazu. Sondern das kann man dann wirklich nur wieder machen, wenn man selber, wie du jetzt vom Kino angeleitet, oder auch viele im Fernsehen, die dann so einfach was machen müssen, also einen kurzen Bericht von der Buchmesse oder so, die gehen denen natürlich dann nach. Also die nutzen dann was sich Habermas, was da so im Angebot ist. Es geht um den Mensch, der Mensch steht im Mittelpunkt, es ist sein Verhalten, es sind die Geltungskriterien seiner Kommunikation und so weiter und so fort. Und dann baut man sich halt so was zusammen. Und da ist das super attraktiv.
Nur unsere Verfassung ist ja so, dass sich die Frage einfach stellt, was ist zulässig. Also wir haben zum Beispiel einen Verfassungsschutz, der sagt manche Dinge sind nicht zulässig. Und um noch mal einmal ein letztes Mal zu Sotardyck zu kommen, ist hier ein Aspekt interessant, dass Sotardyck sagt, ja es gab noch mal diesen Eingemeindungsversuch bei meinem erfolgreichen Buch. Das ist ihm aber dann nicht geglückt. Und dann sind es sich noch mal begegnet. Und hier fällt mal ganz kurz das Wort Historikerstreit. Für die, die das jetzt nicht so kennen, 80er Jahre war das. Es gab da ein Streit, ausgelöst wurde, der vor allem dadurch, dass es eine Position von Ernst Nolte war, die für Aufregung sorgte, nämlich Ernst Nolte war. Um das jetzt ganz verkürzt zu machen, der sagte, der Nationalsozialismus war Reaktion auf den Bolschewismus. Und der Nationalsozialismus ist ja auch kein singuläres Ereignis.
Das ist der wichtige Punkt.
Und diese Singularität von Auschwitz ist eine große Debatte damals gewesen, die immer wieder auch neu verhandelt wird. Aber damals war ganz entscheidend, dass das, was Neute da vertritt, unmöglich ist. Neute hat sich dann noch sehr aus dem Diskurs selbst rausbewegt danach. Also er hat merkwürdigste Auftritte und so was hingelegt. Aber lassen wir das mal dahingestellt. Stotadek geht hier ganz kurz auf diesen Historikerstreit ein. Und da sehen wir schon mal diesen Unterschied, auch wenn wir mal unsere Debatten aus jedem Podcast vergegenwärtigen. Was darf man denn so in den sozialen Medien sagen? Und wir wissen, Mark Zuckerberg lässt sich noch darauf ein, dass man doch sagt, ja, aber ist der Holocaustleuken auch eine Meinung? Da geht er ja auch und sagt dann mal, ja, aber ist doch auch eine Meinung. So weit geht dann diese Silicon Valley Ideologie, auf die wir gleich kommen. Und Stotadek ist da auch eher Team Silicon Valley, wie wir hier hören.
Und als dieser Wunsch sich zerschlagen hat, spätestens nach unserer Begegnung oder Wiederbegegnung in Baltimore.
Nach dem Historikerstreit war das dann, nach dem Historikerstreit war Habermas ja wirklich als das, der große Autor.
Auf das habe ich mich damals überhaupt nicht bezogen. Für mich hat der Historikerstreit gar nicht stattgefunden. Das war mir ehrlich gesagt immer zu kleinlich. Ich fand immer, dass Neute seine Berechtigung hat in einem weiten Spektrum einer Diskussionslandschaft.
Ja, also er ist da jemand, der den Diskurs ganz, ganz weit macht. Und bei Habermas gibt es immer den Vorwurf, der macht den Diskurs zu eng, gibt es Leute wie Chantal Muff, die das herausgearbeitet haben, oder auch Alan Kennedy hat das in einem Aufsatz herausgearbeitet. Sijek weist darauf natürlich auch immer hin. Und jetzt kommen wir aber zu Habermas. Also, Habermas schreibt jetzt einen 30-seitigen Aufsatz in dieser Publikation, die 99 Euro kostet. Ich habe den Aufsatz gelesen und da Habermas ja in der Regel keine Interviews gibt und auch selten Vorträge und im Fernsehen auch so gut wie möglich auftritt. Es gibt ein Doku über ihn, aber es gibt wirklich nicht viel. Haben wir jetzt hier nur gelesene Textausschnitte und ich will auch dann ein bisschen referieren. Aber ich glaube, man bekommt einen Eindruck. Und wir hören jetzt uns erst mal diese Vermutung an, die Habermas hat, warum er jetzt überhaupt noch mal zur Feder greift und sich auf ein Buch bezieht, das 1962 erschienen ist. Der Aufstieg der neuen Medien vollzieht sich im Schatten einer kommerziellen Verwertung der einstweilen kaum regulierten Netzkommunikation.
Diese droht, den traditionellen Zeitungsverlagen und den Journalisten als der zuständigen Berufsgruppe die wirtschaftliche Basis zu entziehen. Andererseits scheint sich bei exklusiven Nutzern sozialer Medien eine Weise der halböffentlichen, fragmentierten und in sich kreisenden Kommunikation zu verbreiten, die deren Wahrnehmung von politischer Öffentlichkeit als solcher deformiert. Wenn diese Vermutung zutrifft, wird bei einem wachsenden Teil der Staatsbürger eine wichtige subjektive Voraussetzung für den mehr oder weniger deliberativen Modus der Meinungs- und Willensbildung gefährdet.
Ja, der deliberative Modus, also alle reden miteinander und Konsens wird dann das gewaltfreie Argument irgendwie und so gemacht. Jetzt mal ganz überspitzt. Ja, schon allein, dass wir jetzt von Öffentlichkeit im Plural reden und feststellen, okay, für alle gilt, das ist jetzt eine erhobene Zahl, wir lesen pro Monat 18 Minuten Spiegel online und nicht pro Tag, sondern pro Monat. Und das bedeutet für sehr viele, sie lesen gar kein Spiegel online oder sonst irgendwas, sondern treiben sich nur in den sozialen Netzen. Schon das ist inkompatibel mit dieser ganzen Idee vom Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit. Also, dass es so eine Pluralität an Öffentlichkeiten gibt. Denn wir können ja nicht sagen, nur weil sich die ganzen Influencer nicht für die Politik interessieren, spielt das Öffentlichkeit keine Rolle, was die machen oder so.
Das ist dann die Öffentlichkeit.
Genau, das ist dann die Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist die Öffentlichkeit. Und wie ist dann eigentlich noch ein liberal-demokratischer Konsens zum Beispiel herzustellen? Oder wie ist ein Austausch darüber möglich? Was können wir jetzt für den Klimaschutz tun, wenn eigentlich in den sozialen Medien Millionen Leute Tausende Stunden im Monat sich Posts durchlesen, in denen es heißt, den Klimawandel gibt es gar nicht? Um jetzt ein Beispiel zu nennen, ähnliches könnten wir von den Impfungen sagen. Das sind jetzt immer die Extrembeispiele. Wir könnten auch viel kleinere Sachen uns rausnehmen. Aber da ist also die Frage, wie kann man das erreichen, während man früher also dieses Publikum hatte, was Habermas kritisierte, das auf dem Sofa sitzt, Fernseher anmacht, 20 Uhr, hier ist die Deutsche Tagesschau. Das ist also jetzt nicht mehr gegeben. Und da stellt sich jetzt die Frage, kann dann dieser Modus der deliberativen Demokratie noch funktionieren? Verweis da erst mal kurz auf Trump und macht da schon mal was deutlich. Also es ist richtig was im Argen. Trumps fatale Aufforderung hätte in der Wut der Bürger, die am 6. Januar 2021 das Kapitol gestürmt haben, kaum das erwünschte Echo gefunden, wenn nicht die politischen Eliten seit Jahrzehnten die legitimen, von der Verfassung gewährleisteten Erwartungen eines erheblichen Teils ihrer Bürger enttäuscht hätten.
Ja, da kann man genauso gut formulieren, Trumps Sieg bei der Präsidentenwahl wäre nie möglich gewesen, wenn man von Jürgen Habermas abgerückt wäre und statt in dem politischen Diskurs auf Konsens abzuzielen gesagt hätte, als Geltungsanspruch muss man auch Unterhaltung und Entertainment mit reinnehmen, weil das ist den Menschen offenbar wichtiger, als die Wahrhaftigkeit und Wahrheit der politischen Aussagen, die kommen. Also in der Ansicht dreht man sich hier so ein bisschen im Kreis. Und was man glaube ich jetzt mal festhalten kann, ist eigentlich ganz witzig, während in Habermas Öffentlichkeit der Konsens am Ende steht, und dann auf eine Öffentlichkeit hinausläuft und alle sind konsensual einverstanden, haben wir es ja mit einer Mehrzahl an Öffentlichkeiten zu tun, bei der man sich jeweils auf einen Konsens besinnt und den auch nicht in Frage stellt.
Aber das meint er ja hier. Also wenn er sagt, dass diese Verfassung, also es bedeutet ja erst einmal, dass er deutlich macht, die Bürger müssen quasi intuitiv zur Verfassung stehen. Denn wenn ich nicht intuitiv zur Verfassung stehe, dann überhaupt renne ich los und sage, das Kapitol ist jetzt meins. Denn wenn ich intuitiv zur Verfassung stehe, dann sage ich, ich finde Merkel zwar furchtbar, aber ich jag die jetzt nicht aus dem Parlament oder so. Und hier sagt er aber, ist dieser intuitive Konsens nicht mehr gegeben, der aber entscheidend auch ist, um darauf dann, also das ist sozusagen der grundsätzliche Rahmen, der anerkannt werden muss, um innerhalb dieses Rahmens dann die Argumentationen auszutragen, pro und con ist ja für ihn da das Entscheidende.
Ja, aber man könnte eben diesen Konsensbegriff jetzt mal einfach richtig neu fassen und sagen, klar, die einigen sich nicht mehr auf die Verfassung oder so, sondern sagen halt einiges. Aber die stehen ja trotzdem auf irgendeinem Fundament. Und bei QAnon ist es halt so eine Ideologie. Also wir haben jetzt ganz viele Ideologie-Nichter.
Ja, aber dann entwickeln wir ja den Verfassungsstart ab.
Richtig, das wird ja auch gemacht. Das ist ja genau das Problem.
Ja, aber das ist ja das, was er kritisiert.
Ja, aber das ist...
Aber ich kann ja nicht jetzt schon so weit gehen, dass ich sage, gut, das ist eh vorbei. Also damit habe ich ja dann mal gerade seit 89, 1789 alles durchgestrichen und sage jetzt, jo.
Ja, aber das ist die große Gefahr, dass man das immer noch nicht einsieht, dass das die Gefahr ist, dass nämlich Menschen kommen und irgendwann auch die Mehrheit stellen, die sagen, das, was bisher als demokratischer und politischer Konsens galt, gilt für uns nicht mehr, uns ist irgendeine Ideologie wichtiger. Und das ist ja ganz wichtig, dass wir in der Soziologie den Erfolg der Theorien haben, die sagen, funktionale Differenzierung, die Politik ist nur ein System unter vielen. Und nur weil der Bundespräsident immer sagt, die deutsche Verfassung und so weiter, heißt das noch nicht, dass sie für alle so zentral steht wie für einen Bundespräsidenten. Klar, für ihn ist das so. Aber sehr viele haben halt andere.
Wir müssen sie ja akzeptieren eigentlich. Also wenn wir jetzt auf einem liberaldemokratischen Konsens noch aufbauen wollen, wenn wir nicht sagen, gut, dann möge am Ende nur noch irgendwie die Teorz-Show gewinnen. Oder so. Aber ich meine, also man kann das machen, man kann diesen Modus machen, aber du willst in keinem Land leben, wo das die Bedingung wäre.
Aber es gibt so eine Realität, in der sehr viele sagen...
Genau, es gibt diese Realität, die aber glaube ich hier ja schildert. Also das glaube ich ist ja was, was er erkannt hat. Sonst würde er ja noch nicht da reifen.
Also mir fehlt dann doch so eine gewisse Anerkennung des Phänomen Trumps. Dass man nicht nur als, das ist eine Abweichung von meiner Idealvorstellung, sondern das ist sozusagen Realität.
Wir kommen da jetzt gleich zu. Wir wollen jetzt erstens mal diese Syntax da ansehen, die Slotardyke schon beschrieben hatte. Ich habe mir jetzt mal die Mühe gemacht, so einen längeren Abschnitt einzulesen. Bitte nicht umschalten, sondern wirklich diese zwei Minuten einmal genießen. Immerhin auch Respekt, das formuliert ein 92-Jähriger. Auf den ersten Blick ist es eine ziemlich mysteriöse Vorstellung, dass aus dieser rechtlichen Etablierung eines Verfahrens demokratischer Willensbildung, also aus schierer Legalität, gleichwohl die Legitimität allgemein überzeugender Ergebnisse hervorgehen soll. Einen wesentlichen Teil der Erklärung liefert die Analyse der Bedeutung, die dieses Verfahren aus der Sicht der Beteiligten gewinnt. Und zwar verdankt es seine Überzeugungskraft der unwahrscheinlichen Kombination von zwei Bedingungen. Das Verfahren verlangt zum einen die Inklusion aller von möglichen Entscheidungen Betroffenen als gleichberechtigt an der politischen Willensbildung Beteiligte, und es macht zum anderen die demokratisch, also von allen einzelnen gemeinsam getroffenen Entscheidungen abhängig von einem mehr oder weniger diskursiven Charakter vorangehender Beratungen. Damit wird die inklusive Willensbildung abhängig gemacht von der Kraft der Gründe, die während des Prozesses einer vorangehenden Meinungsbildung mobilisiert werden. Die Inklusion entspricht der demokratischen Forderung nach der gleichberechtigten Partizipation aller Betroffenen an der politischen Willensbildung, während der Filter der Deliberation der Erwartung kognitiv richtiger und tragfähiger Problemlösungen Rechnung trägt und die Vermutung rational akzeptabler Ergebnisse begründet. Diese Vermutung lässt sich wiederum mit der falsifizierbaren Unterstellung rechtfertigen, dass in jenen, eine Mehrheitsentscheidung vorbereiteten, Beratungen nach Möglichkeit alle relevanten Themen, erforderlichen Informationen und geeigneten Lösungsvorschläge mit Argumenten pro und con zur Sprache kommen. Und es ist dieses Erfordernis der freien Deliberation, das die zentrale Rolle der politischen Öffentlichkeit erklärt. Du verdrehst die Augen, aber du musst auch zugeben, stilistisch ist es auch nicht schlimmer als Niklas Luhmann lesen.
Also für mich liegen da Welten dazwischen.
Also Luhmann lesen ist ja auch eine Folter.
Es ist auch fordernd, aber da...
Es ist auch eine Folter. Es ist nicht stilistisch schön, es ist nicht wie Sloterdijk lesen oder Adorno lesen.
Zugestandenermaßen, aber den Bogen habe ich ja vorhin schon gespannt, warum das eine attraktiv ist und das andere auch. Bei Habermas, ich kann es nur immer wieder sagen, oder anders gefragt. Hörst du hier keine neoklassische Politikvorstellung raus, so wie wir so eine Idee haben von der allwissenden Marktteilnehmer, der sich im Konsens, die Preisfindung und so weiter... Wir haben es doch nicht mit diesem, alle sind gleichberechtigt dabei, allen wird unendlich viel Zeit eingeräumt. Bei Niklas Luhmann ist das ganz einfach. In der Politik ist die Entscheidung das Entscheidende, die Entscheidung, die Mehrheitsentscheidung.
Das ist ein dezentralistischer Ansatz, den Habermas natürlich nicht haben kann, weil er so ein Antischmedianer ist, dass, glaube ich, alles, was nach Entscheidungen riecht, schon für ihn wahrscheinlich verdächtig ist. Und du hast vollkommen recht, was hier aufschimmert. Und deswegen, ich bin überhaupt nicht dafür, ich will es an keiner Stelle verteidigen, ich will es nur in gewisser Weise auch würdigen, weil ich es doch auch für interessant erachte, ist, dass Habermas hier eine Vision von einer Partizipation durch gleichberechtigter Teilnehmer malt, die überhaupt nicht der Wirklichkeit entsprechen kann, weil wir konfligierende Interessen haben. Also das ist schon in der Talk schon nicht möglich, es ist bei Koalitionsverhandlungen nicht möglich. Es ist auch gar nicht möglich bei den großen Fragen, wir hatten ja hier, ich hatte es mal mitgebracht, das Thema Bürgerräte. Bürgerräte basieren auf diesem Habermas-Modell. Ganz viele, die jetzt damit durch die Gegend tingeln, so an Wissenschaftlern, die haben in der Regel eine Habermas-Schule durchlaufen, haben zum Teil noch bei Habermas promoviert. Und die sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal über alles lang genug reden, rational abwägen, argumentieren, prokonnen. Und dann haben wir irgendwann diesen Konsens, und den präsentieren wir dann Wolfgang Schäuble, und der nimmt das und legt es in die Schublade. Also das ist genau das, was ich auch da immer kritisieren würde. Er sagt dann hier in dem Aufsatz, also er hat auch offenbar langsam Zweifel daran. Er sagt, naja, so ein Diskurs macht noch kein Gesetz. Und dann deutet er das mal gerade an. Aber indem er diese diskursive Seite so stark macht, würde ich auch sagen, das ist total übertrieben. Und diese Diskussion hat wirklich wahrscheinlich nur in dem Salon stattgefunden im 19. Jahrhundert.
Aber auch der war super exklusiv.
Er hat die Türen geschlossen und dann war er… Genau, der war ausgeschlossen natürlich für alle, die nicht vermögend waren, nicht eine entsprechende Bildung hatten und so.
Aber das ist, finde ich, einen guten Hinweis. Immer, wenn man bei Habermas Deliberation, Deliberative und so weiter hört, dann ist damit immer der Bürgerrat gemeint, der die Türen aufmacht und für alle sagt, wir entscheiden hier gar nichts, sondern am Ende sind wir einfach alle einer Meinung. Ja. Das kann aber auch fünf Jahre dauern bis und so.
Ja, du hast jetzt bei dem Neoklassischen das auch sehr schön gesagt. Also das ist so ein Markt von Meinungen, der dann da ist und dann bildet sich da so eine gute Meinung aus. Das müsste man, glaube ich, auch nochmal, das wäre eine gute Dissertation, das nochmal so miteinander zu verquicken.
Hätte ja auch zeitgleich.
Hayek Habermas, also das würde ich gerne lesen. Vielleicht gibt es das aber auch. Es ist ja unendlich viel publiziert zu beiden. Jetzt zur Bedeutung der Massenmedien, die ja auch immer noch konsumieren in Form von Fernsehen zum Beispiel. Haben wir hier schon ARD-ZTF-Sendungen gehabt heute. Obwohl die zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteure, die Face-to-Face-Begegnungen im Alltag und in öffentlichen Veranstaltungen jene beiden Nahbereiche der Öffentlichkeit darstellen, von denen ihre eigenen Initiativen ausgehen, bildet die von Massenmedien gelenkte öffentliche Kommunikation allein den Bereich, worin sich die kommunikativen Geräusche zu relevanten und effektiven öffentlichen Meinungen verdichten können. So war es und das ist auch absolut richtig. Und das hat sich geändert. Wenn man ins 19. Jahrhundert legt, dann gibt es da die literarische Öffentlichkeit, so nennt er das. Das ist das, was in Salons stattfindet. Und da ist das noch nicht so wichtig mit den Massenmedien.
Genau, wir haben das im Fernsehpodcast mal durchgerechnet. Wenn du die Grünen nimmst, die 100 Städte besuchen, um da Wahlkampfauftritte zu machen, also Mensch zu Mensch-Begegnung. Und da kommen wie in Frankfurt am Main zum Beispiel zweieinhalbtausend. Das gilt dann als echt viel und ansonsten so tausend, zweitausend. Dann kommst du auf 20.000 Leute oder so, die das dann gesehen haben. Und wenn du das vergleichst mit einem Anne-Ville-Auftritt von Robert Habeck, dann erreicht er mit den 100 Auftritten so ein, zwei Prozent der Masse im Vergleich zu einem Anne-Ville-Auftritt mit drei, vier Millionen Menschen, die da zuschauen. Also es fällt einfach komplett auseinander. Und da ist dieses Zugeständnis genau richtig. Es spitzt sich am Ende zu in ganz exklusiven Zirkeln. Und nur weil wir alle Zuschauer sind, heißt noch nicht, dass die Anne-Ville-Sendung irgendein offenes Gespräch ist, in dem der freie Markt der Meinung ist oder so.
Das ist etwas, müssen wir jetzt noch mal für die, die jetzt im Habermas-Spektrum sonst nicht so drin sind. Das ist das, was Habermas immer kritisierte, dass das so ist. Also dass wir diese massenmediale Vermittlung haben, die uns degradiert zu Konsumenten. Wir können einfach nur sagen, gut, ich schalte den Fernseher an. Welche Gäste sind da? Toll, Wolfgang Bosbach auch wieder hat Platz genommen. Und dann spielt sich dieses Theater ab für uns. Wir sind aber nicht partizipativ. Partizipativ ist aber das, was wir eigentlich sein sollen. Jetzt hören wir aber mal, es ist schon alles jetzt sehr startlang, die Rolle der Journalisten. Das technisch und organisatorisch hochkomplexe Mediensystem verlangt ein professionalisiertes Personal, das für die Kommunikationsflüsse, aus denen die Bürger öffentliche Meinungen kondensieren, die Rolle von Torhütern, wie es inzwischen heißt, spielt. Das Personal besteht aus Journalisten, die für die Nachrichtendienste, die Medien und die Verlage arbeiten, d.h. aus Fachkräften, die im Medien- und Literaturbetrieb Autoren, Redakteur, Lektoren und Managerfunktion ausüben. Dieses Personal lenkt den Throughput und bildet zusammen mit den Unternehmen, die die Technik der Herstellung und die Organisation des Vertriebs organisieren, die Infrastruktur der Öffentlichkeit, die letztlich über die beiden entscheidenden Parameter der öffentlichen Kommunikation entscheiden, über Reichweite und deliberative Qualität des Angebots. Journalisten also als Gatekeeper plus dann die Verlage und die deliberative Qualität des Angebots bedeutet zum Beispiel, also um das jetzt mal direkt zu übersetzen, in einer normalen deutschen Tageszeitung wird jetzt nicht drinstehen, es gibt kein Corona. So, das würde da einfach nicht stattfinden. Da gibt es eine Kontrolle, die sagt, nee, das geht nicht. Oder es finden andere Themen nicht statt, die extremistisch sind. Oder es finden auch vielleicht Dinge nicht statt, weil man sie als nicht so wichtig erachtet, wo man schon genau wieder ins Fragen kommt, aber was ist denn jetzt gerade wichtig? Also wir diskutieren ja hier laufen, warum kommt das nicht vor? Und das müsste man doch viel größer machen, warum ist die EU so wenig repräsentiert in den Medien? Also da sieht man, diese Gatekeeper-Funktion hat auch das, also dieses Loben hier eigentlich, was hier schon so ein bisschen stattfindet, so zwischen den Zeilen. Der Gatekeeper ist ja sehr, sehr kritisch zu betrachten. Man kann sagen, ja gut, so das Kröpste halten die jetzt irgendwie uns fern, also dass wir jetzt nicht da die großen Save-And-I-Do-Interviews jetzt drin haben. Aber man kann ja schon jetzt fragen, wie gut dieses Gatekeeper-System funktioniert mit Blick auf Geldpolitik zum Beispiel.
Ja, entsprechend seines normativen Anspruchs sollte er auch einfach mit dem Wort sollte ein bisschen häufiger arbeiten, statt immer so zu tun, als wäre es so. Er wünscht es sich halt so und dann wäre alles besser als dann so ein Argument.
Ja, aber er schildert das so ein bisschen als Fakt und das ist glaube ich kommt sehr Journalisten zu passen. Ich war ja auch kürzlich bei so einer Konferenz, dass die sagen dann immer, ach wie schaffen wir das, dass wir weiter so eine Qualität haben und dann hast du aber da manchmal irgendwie Leute sitzen von der Bildzeitung und denke ich mir, ja wovon redet ihr dann da eigentlich? Dann ist ja auch alles bei YouTube lieber. Ich muss auch sagen, also das ist natürlich ein bisschen peinlich, jetzt diesen Namen im Zusammenhang mit Habermas und Sloterdive, mit solchen Größen zu nennen, aber das fand ich halt auch einfach daneben, als dann so Leute wie Passmann oder so plötzlich dann auf Grund dieser Ken-Jepsen-Geschichten da zu Corona sagen, Gatekeeper sind toll und das hat auch schon einen Grund, warum man in seriösen Zeitungen sonst nicht vorkommt. Also so einfach kann man es sich nicht mal, nur weil es da Trottel auf der einen Seite gibt und Demagogen gibt, kann man jetzt nicht einfach so alle Gatekeeper abfeiern, weil Gatekeeper bedeutet auch, dass halt Wolfgang Bosbach immer noch in Talkshows sitzt und Rainer Hank. Also das ist auch eine Gatekeeper-Sache, die man jetzt nicht begrüßen kann. So, jetzt aber Habermas geht ins Internet. Was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich los? Also wie sieht das eigentlich aus? Wir wissen, Habermas ist natürlich nicht im Internet, irgendwo mit einem Twitter-Kanal, aber er hat offenbar mal reingeguckt. Der egalitäre und unregulierte Charakter der Beziehungen zwischen den Beteiligten und die gleichmäßige Autorisierung der Nutzer zu eigenen spontanen Beiträgen bilden das Kommunikationsmuster, das die neuen Medien ursprünglich auszeichnen sollte. Dieses große, emanzipatorische Versprechen wird heute von den wüsten Geräuschen in fragmentierten, in sich selbst kreisenden Echo-Räumen übertönt. Filterbubble, wüste Geräusche, also von Corona-Verschwörern bis hin zu Alt-Right-Bewegungen, was weiß ich. Das passiert also jetzt in den sozialen Medien. Es sind Echo-Räume und keine Salons.
Es ist trotzdem, ich finde es niedlich, wie er hier versucht, die eigentlich gute Idee immer noch unter diesem ganzen Schmutz darzustellen. So, als wäre nicht der Schmutz die eigentliche Sache, als gäbe es noch die Perle da drunter.
Wir kommen direkt darauf, ich spiele den nächsten Clip. Zunächst schien sich der egalitär-universalistische Anspruch der bürgerlichen Öffentlichkeit auf gleichberechtigte Inklusion aller Bürger in Gestalt der neuen Medien endlich zu erfüllen. Diese Medien würden allen Bürgern eine eigene öffentlich wahrnehmbare Stimme und dieser Stimme sogar mobilisierende Kraft verleihen. Sie würden die Nutzer aus der rezeptiven Rolle von Adressaten, die zwischen einer begrenzten Anzahl von Programmen wählen, befreien und jedem Einzelnen die Chance geben, sich im anarchischen Austausch spontaner Meinungen Gehör zu verschaffen. Aber die Lava dieses zugleich anti-autoritären und egalitären Potenzials, die im kalifornischen Gründergeist der frühen Jahre noch zu spüren war, ist im Silicon Valley als bald zur libertären Grimasse weltbeherrschender Digitalkonzerne erstarrt. Also ganz deutlich. Und da sehen wir die Grimassen von Zuckerberg und Co. Ja, ganz, ganz deutlich. Und er sagte also, da gab es mal auch dieses Ideal. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch das Cyber-Manifest noch und solche Texte, die das genauso skizzieren, die eigentlich sehr Habermas treu argumentieren und sagen, hier ist es jetzt möglich. Habermas schaut jetzt nach im Internet, sagt, nee, ist gar nicht. Das ist die Libertäre Grimasse und da ist auch nicht mehr der Meinungsaustausch, sondern da ist so eine Lava, die sich da ausbreitet und man weiß gar nicht, wie damit jetzt umgehen. Er sagt, das ist also der Preis, der zu zahlen ist für die Selbstermächtigung der Mediennutzer.
Hier allerdings, finde ich, könnte man wieder groß normativ einsteigen. Machen wir auch gleich, indem man nämlich sagt, naja, vor 15 Jahren hätte man das ja durchaus anders schreiben können im Lichte von Wikipedia und so weiter. Nur, es wurde halt korrumpiert. Also da, wo Geld eine Rolle spielt, ist halt einfach abgewichen vom eigentlich durchführbaren guten Ideal.
Ja, absolut. Und er sagt dann auch, dass das das große Problem sei, dass die Bürger diese neuen Medien noch nicht hinreichend gelernt haben. Also dieses noch nicht ist ganz schön. Er glaubt also nach wie vor an dieses Projekt der Aufklärung. Und da haben wir noch nicht genug getan. Und wir können da vielleicht aber noch was ausrichten. Er sieht aber tatsächlich, dass mit diesen Plattformen ein solcher Umbruch stattgefunden hat, wie mit dem Buchdruck. Und er sagt, das Problem sieht er allerdings darin, dass man sehr viel Zeit braucht, um Lesen zu lernen. Und das war immer das große Argument von Neil Postman. Also du kannst, auch wenn du Kinder im Haus hast, alle Bücher eigentlich frei stehen lassen. Die gehen ja nicht mit sieben Jahren hin und fangen jetzt an, sich in das Werk von Marquis de Sartre einzuarbeiten, sondern erst wenn man erwachsen ist, wird man überhaupt sich damit auseinandersetzen können und kann sich dann auch der Gewalt, die dort in Schrift übertragen wird, stellen. Während die Bilder ja genau diese Niedrigschwelligkeit haben, dass man einfach einem Kind einen Film ab 18 zeigen könnte und das Kind das verstört danach. Und das ist etwas, was so eine interessante Melange ergibt, dass man zum einen noch nicht reif ist für die Bilder, sie aber schon kognitiv in sich einsickern lassen kann.
Also da gibt es von diesem Argument auch eine vulgäre Variante, in dem man nämlich sagt, Trump entzaubert sich schon, lasst ihn nur lang genug regieren. Gefahren sind groß.
So, jetzt haben sich die Standards natürlich verändert. Es ist nicht mehr so wie bei den alten Gatekeepers. Die Trennung zwischen öffentlich und privat, das ist ja für ihn auch ganz entscheidend, auch für eine liberale Demokratie. Diese Trennung verblasst, sagt Habermas. Und diese Inklusivität der Öffentlichkeit, die sich bietet, wenn man sagt, wir gehen jetzt miteinander in den Austausch, die wird nicht länger als solche erkannt, sondern es entstehen solche Filterblasen, solche Räume, in denen nur noch Meinungen bestätigt werden. Und man kommt da auch gar nicht mehr raus.
Wird er denn so deutlich, sagt er so Filterblasen und so? Benutzt er solche Worte?
Filterblasen benutzt er nicht. Er hat ja jetzt dieses Wort genannt, dass er sagt, Moment, wo habe ich es? Echo-Räume. Also da ist er schon auf der Höhe der Zeit. Er hat auch dann Shushana Zuboff zitiert und so. Also er scheint das schon noch wahrzunehmen. Er entschuldigt sich übrigens anfangs ein bisschen dafür, dass er nur noch selektiv diese Forschungsliteratur wahrnimmt, weil das schon lange nicht mehr sein Thema ist. Aber es ist wirklich eine tolle Geste, finde ich schon, eines 92-Jährigen überhaupt, das nochmal zu machen und nicht einfach zu sagen, gut, ist mir jetzt egal, macht damit, was ihr wollt. Also dass ihr nochmal versucht, das deutlich zu machen. Und so schwindet der Raum für eine diskursive Klärung von konkurrierenden Ansprüchen und von Meinungen und diese journalistisch institutionalisierte Öffentlichkeit ist nun eine Geschwächte und alle Meinungen sind plötzlich gleich viel wert bzw. alles kann rausgehauen werden ins Internet und jetzt ist die Frage, wie darauf reagieren? Wir haben ja da gleich noch einen großen Block vor uns zu dieser Frage. Hier erstmal, was Habermas zu kartellrechtlichen Fragen zu sagen hat. Die Abschöpfung und digitale Verarbeitung der persönlichen Kundendaten, die mehr oder weniger unauffällig gegen die kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellten Informationen der Suchmaschinen, der Nachrichtenportale und anderer Dienstleistungen eingetauscht werden, erklärt, warum die EU-Wettbewerbskommissarin diesen Markt regulieren möchte. Aber das Wettbewerbsrecht ist der falsche Ansatz, wenn man den Grundfehler korrigieren will, dass die Plattformen, anders als die klassischen Medien, für die Verbreitung von wahrheitssensiblen, also täuschungsanfälligen kommunikativen Inhalten, keine Haftung übernehmen wollen. Dass Presse, Rundfunk und Fernsehen beispielsweise dazu verpflichtet sind, Falschmeldungen zu korrigieren, macht auf jenen Umstand aufmerksam, der hier interessiert. Wegen des besonderen Charakters ihrer Waren, die eben keine bloßen Waren sind, können sich auch die Plattformen nicht jeder publizistischen Sorgfaltspflicht entziehen.
Amy Kloboczak wird genau das Gegenteil gleich sagen.
So, so.
Man darf nicht über die Haftung argumentieren, weil das zu zu großen Schäden führt und auch juristisch vor Richtern nicht haltbar wäre. Also da geht es ja konkret um diese Section 230, das behalten wir mal im Hinterkopf.
Aber wir hatten ja auch schon diese Argumentation, dass wir meinten, man müsste sie eigentlich wie Redaktionen behandeln. Also das ist ja das, was Habermas jetzt hier eigentlich einfordert. Ist glaube ich aber rechtlich tatsächlich sehr schwierig.
Ja, also wir hören nachher ein Argument, das so gemacht wird von Leo Laporte, zu sagen, wenn man die Haftung mit rein nimmt, dann ist auch die Wikipedia tot von heute auf morgen. Denn das ist ja auch ein Sammelbecken von Menschen, die da Zulieferungen machen. Und am Ende ist die Frage, wer haftet für die Information. Und wenn es die Wikipedia selbst wäre, dann würde sie zum einen torpediert als die Autorität, die Wissen vermittelt und dann aber Falsches. Und wenn sie dafür haften müsste, gäbe es sie nicht. Und in der Ansicht greift diese Haftungssache ein bisschen zu weit. Amy Klobuchar macht da gleich einen ganz eleganten Umweg, wenn wir eben schon, wie macht man Investitionen trotz Schuldenbremse, das macht Amy Klobuchar auch gleich nochmal, wie macht man, wie findet man Verantwortung trotz Haftungslosigkeit?
Okay, wir behalten das im Hinterkopf. Und jetzt hören wir nochmal Habermas, der nochmal jetzt ganz deutlich sagt, also das kann nicht, das darf nicht sein in einer liberalen Demokratie, was da gerade stattfindet. Wir wissen, also beim Historikerstreit hatte er schon gesagt, Ernst Neulte, das geht nicht. Und jetzt sieht er natürlich nochmal ganz anderes. Also ich glaube, es ist auch diese Überraschung, was überhaupt alles geäußert werden wird. Das war einem ja gar nicht klar. Also man wusste immer mal von Stammtischen oder so, was da so erzählt wird. Aber dass es in dieser Dimension da ist, ist überhaupt nicht klar. Und jetzt muss er irgendwie versuchen, so eine Argumentation zu finden, dass man die wie Redaktionen anerkennt. Was aber zugleich bedeutet, dass Habermas sich andocken muss an die Massenmedien, die er einst kritisiert. Um das vielleicht mal auf ein ganz dummes Beispiel zu übertragen. Es wäre etwa so, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich hätte immer Kritiken, er hätte immer geschrieben, wir müssen das Kino verbieten. Dann ist das Fernsehen gekommen. Und dann sage ich, jetzt müssen wir die Leute sehen, dass sie wieder ins Kino gehen, damit sie ja kein Fernsehen gucken. Also so ein bisschen, um es jetzt ganz platt zu machen.
Das kleinere Übel.
Das ist das kleinere Übel, für das er sich offenbar hier entscheidet. Jetzt hier Schussbehandlung, wo er nochmal sehr energisch wird. Auch die Plattformen sind verantwortlich und müssten für News haften, die sie weder produzieren noch redigieren. Denn auch diese Informationen haben eine meinungs- und mentalitätsbildende Kraft. In erster Linie unterliegen sie nicht den Qualitätsstandards von Waren, sondern den kognitiven Standards von Urteilen, ohne die es für uns weder die Objektivität der Welt von Tatsachen, noch die Identität und Gemeinsamkeit unserer intersubjektiv geteilten Welt geben kann. In einer schwer vorstellbaren Welt von Fake News, die nicht mehr als solche identifiziert, also von wahren Informationen unterschieden werden könnten, würde kein Kind aufwachsen können, ohne klinische Symptome zu entwickeln. Es ist deshalb keine politische Richtungsentscheidung, sondern ein verfassungsrechtliches Gebot, eine Medienstruktur aufrecht zu erhalten, die den inklusiven Charakter der Öffentlichkeit und einen deliberativen Charakter der öffentlichen Meinungs- und Willensbildung ermöglicht. Komm, das ist schon sehr schön. Das ist schon sehr schön noch mal formuliert, auch mit den klinischen Symptomen, die sich bei Kindern herausbilden. Obwohl ich hier gerade sagen würde, hat sich das auch bei Alten besonders gerade herausgebildet, diese klinischen Symptome. Ich finde auch gut, dass er noch mal dieses verfassungsrechtliche so klarmacht, dass das das entscheidender ist, um überhaupt ein System wie dieses zu erhalten, dass man das irgendwie braucht. Das hat schon eine gewisse Schlagkraft, wenn gleich ich doch sagen würde, es ist wahrscheinlich sehr utopisch das zu machen. Dieses, was du jetzt angesprochen hast, das ist das kleinere Übel. Man muss dazu sagen, Habermas ist wahrscheinlich der treueste SPD-Wähler aller Zeiten. Und da haben wir eben schon bei Kühnert gesehen, das kleinere Übel ist dann halt immer noch besser als nichts. Insofern ist es ganz typisch, dass Habermas hier auch mal so argumentiert. Ich will nur noch ganz kurz Oliver Weber zitieren aus der FAZ, der seinen Artikel dann so beendet. Rationalisierung setzt an Rationalisierungsansprüchen an, wo die idealisierende Unterstellung, Stellungen an die politische Öffentlichkeit wegfallen, kann auch keine echte Kritik mehr stattfinden. In der von Habermas noch ganz in den Bahnen klassischer Fachöffentlichkeit vorgetragenen Kritik ereignet sich selbst eine Akzentverschiebung, die auch als Revision gedeutet werden könnte. Die Massenmedien, die ehedem nur als Türöffner der anarchischen zivilgesellschaftlichen Kommunikation taugten, erscheinen jetzt als eine der letzten Bastionen demokratischer Öffentlichkeit, gerade weil sie filtern, was unvermittelt den Köpfen der Bürger entspringt. Auf Twitter meldete ein Professor und Kollege die Neuveröffentlichung, was auch Anlass zu vorliegendem Artikel gab. Der 92-Jährige selbst besitzt keinen Twitter-Account.
Wenn Jürgen Habermas mit 92 Jahren 2021 feststellt, dass die Welt, in der er lebt, von allen nur bekannt ist aus den Massenmedien, ist das natürlich eine tolle Errungenschaft.
Nee, das hat er ja nicht festgestellt. Das ist ja seine Feststellung für die 1960er-Jahre. Seine Feststellung ist ja, dass die klassischen Massenmedien nicht mehr diesen Durchsatz haben, sondern dass die Leute sich über Alternativen-Medien informieren. Und dies sieht er als Problem an mit Blick auf Fake News. Wenngleich man ja auch mal fragen könnte, ob es nicht bei einem 30-seitigen Artikel, der noch mal bis zur französischen Revolution zurückgeht, angemessen wäre, aufzuzeigen, dass im Internet gerade durch diese Neustrukturierung, durch den Wegfall der Gatekeeper, so etwas entstehen kann wie ein blühendes Podcastwesen, wo die rationale Argumentation, zum Beispiel hier zwischen einem Systemtheoretiker und einem Ideologiekritiker durchaus möglich sein kann, sogar mit Konsensbildung bei einigen Themen, ob das nicht gerade mal ein Zeichen dafür wäre, dass anderes möglich ist. Und da jetzt einfach nur zu sagen, ich schreibe mal so einen Text, also das könnte man ja, also wenn ich jetzt hier vom Bundesverband der deutschen Verleger wäre, das würde ich also mir sofort kopieren und jedem Politiker so reichen und sagen, wir brauchen dringend noch mal so eine Anschubfinanzierung für unser Digitalisierungsprogramm oder Geld. Sie passen aber auf, dass wir nicht den Mindestlohn auch für die Zeitungsaustreger zahlen müssen. Denn wir sind ja hier ganz wichtig, wir stützen euch. Das ist ja die Argumentation seit Trump hier von allen Verlegern gewesen. Also eigentlich ist das eine Position, die irgendwo nachvollziehbar ist. Aber ich finde es doch ein bisschen schade, dass wenn man eine Geschichte wie den Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit schreibt, wo man sich hauptsächlich beim 19. Jahrhundert auf literarische Salons, also auf einen kleinen, kleinen, konzentriert und das als das Eigentliche herausarbeitet, man jetzt so etwas wie zum Beispiel die Podcasts oder interessanten Blogs oder so, die es gibt, einfach ausklammert und nicht da einfach auch mal diese Geschichte vom 19. Jahrhundert fortschreibt und sagt, ja genau so eine bürgerliche Öffentlichkeit findet jetzt auch da statt, was nicht heißt, dass wir dem anderen nicht mit kartellrechtlichen Fragen uns entgegenstellen müssen. Aber das ist ja auch ein Potenzial, das gegeben ist. Und man braucht jetzt nicht einfach so zu sagen, jetzt aber noch mal die Gatekeeper stärken.
Richtig, aber immerhin erkennt er die Eigenleistung und Eigendynamik von diesen Art, wie wir jetzt sagen, alten Medien Gatekeeper an. Das ist ja auch schon mal eine Errungenschaft. Ich würde trotzdem sagen, das Eingeständnis in eine Realität der Massenmedien hätte man auch in diesem Maße Jahrzehnte vorher machen können, indem man dann einfach Luhmann auch ein bisschen wohlwollender gelesen hätte. Dann will ich noch sagen, es ist ja ein globales Argument, so insgesamt immer. Habermas macht es ja nur mal ganz groß. Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht, dass von Samira das Buch Erzählen der Affen ja auch so ein globales Argument ist. Und vielleicht sollten wir weniger Habermas und mehr Samira lesen, wobei ich das Buch von denen noch nicht kenne.
Ich habe es jetzt liegen und werde es wahrscheinlich heute Abend beginnen. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Weil die ziehen ja anscheinend, deswegen ja die Affen auch seit den Teehäusern alles noch mal auf. Vielleicht fangen sie wirklich bei den Affen an.
Ich hoffe, die fangen sogar bei den Affen an und sehen es vor allem sehr global. Und das ist auch das für mich Entscheidende.
Das kann ich nicht im Kleinen und Kleinen argumentieren.
Es ist auf jeden Fall unterhaltsamer zu lesen. Das kann ich schon mal reingeschaut. Es ist schon unterhaltsamer.
Das ist der zentrale Geltungsanspruch in guter Kommunikation. Unterhaltsam muss es sein. Bleiben wir beim Thema, werden aber ganz lebensweltlich. Du weißt ja, Dirk Becker hat ja immer gesagt, was willst du Systemtheorie studieren? Mach einfach Facebook an und nimm Teil, dann weißt du, wie Netzwerke funktionieren. Aber was ist, wenn Facebook down ist? Wir beginnen mit einem Clip, in dem Shira Frankel auftritt. Wir kennen sie alle, denn sie hat zum einen schreibt sie für die New York Times und hat das Facebook Buch, was wir zuletzt gelesen haben, mitgeschrieben in Co-Authorenschaft, war also zugeschaltet. Und sie macht hier einen ganz interessanten Punkt, denn zuerst dachte ich auch, will Facebook jetzt ablenken von all den Problemen, mit denen sie einfach mal down sind, sie ist anderer Meinung.
Du kannst nicht wirklich von einem schlechteren Zeitpunkt denken, was Facebook für Leute ist, für Leute, die auf Google und Twitter gehen und dort hinsetzen, was mit Facebook falsch ist, oder was mit Facebook das Problem ist, weil sie mit Hunderten Artikeln, die in der letzten Woche geschrieben wurden, dass sie sich in.
Das ist natürlich ein schönes Krisen-Experiment für die Habermas-Idenk. Man will eigentlich zu den neuen Internet-Medien, die funktionieren aber gerade nicht, also fragt man, was ist eigentlich mit den neuen Internet-Medien oder was ist das Problem mit Facebook ganz konkret? Und dann kriegt man in den alten Medien die ganzen Dinge serviert, die einem so die Augen aufschlagen. Und man will da gar nicht mehr zurück zu Facebook. Na ja gut, Facebook war ja nur sechs Stunden down. Frances Haugen, wir kennen jetzt alle ihren Namen. Sie ist der Snowden für Facebook. Sie hat Aussagen im US-Kongress und war auch in England. Und hat da auch noch mal zweieinhalb Stunden. Sonst haben wir ja immer diese Kongressanhörung hier in voller Länge geguckt. Wir machen es heute ein bisschen anders. Wir kümmern uns um die Diskussion drum herum. Denn die Argumente, die da vorgetragen werden, kennen wir ja eigentlich. Durch unsere etwas ausführlicheren Thematisierungen. Und sie ist vorm Kongress. Und wir nehmen nur dieses eine, was dann wiederum bei PBS aufgegriffen wurde, als Zitat. Und ich würde sagen, völlig zu Recht. Denn hier kommt der ganze Anspruch von ihr da nieder. Und man muss echt sagen, das ist dann wie bei Snowden.
Angesichts einer Treppe von interne Unternehmendokumen hat der ehemalige Facebook-Kompetent, Francis Haugen, die Senatoren in die sozialen Medien gegründet.
Sie kommt, um den Politikern Informationen zu geben, sagt dann aber nicht, komm nicht hierher, um euch Informationen zu geben, sondern um euch zu sagen, ihr werdet jetzt gebraucht. Also wir brauchen jetzt hier Politik. Das ist natürlich super.
Denn Facebook wüsste, wie es geht, aber die haben andere Absichten.
Genau, die können es nicht, die wollen es nicht, ihr seid hier gebraucht. Und um mal die große Verlangsdarstellung zu stellen, also es wird in Europa total unterschätzt, was das gerade für Facebook hier bedeutet, dass sie gestern ihren Namen da geändert haben in Meta und so, das kam ja nicht von ungefähr, wir hören das auch gleich. Das sind alles lange, lange Debatten. In diesem Pivot Podcast reden eigentlich Sarah Kish, Sarah Swisher, Kara Swisher so rum und Scott Galloway nur darüber, wird er freiwillig seinen Posten räumen, Mark Zuckerberg oder wird er in Handstellen abgeführt. Das sind eigentlich die Erwartungen, die da jetzt so vorne herrschen. Und um mal darzustellen, als wir immer diese Debatten geguckt haben, war ja immer klar, die Demokraten kümmern sich und die Republikaner kümmern sich immer so im Ear-free-Speech-Ding und so und sind eigentlich wirklich nicht richtig drin im Thema. Das ist jetzt hier ein bisschen anders. Wir hören Dan Sullivan, ein republikanischen Senator, der im Gleichklang im Grunde mit Francis Horgan hier die Debatte absolviert.
Haben wir in den letzten zehn Jahren eine goldene Ähre der Teenager-Mental-Healthe gesehen?
Also große Einmütigkeit. Alle Werbeversprechen sind nicht nur falsch, sondern im Gegenteil.
Das sind die klinischen Symptome, von denen Habermas spricht.
Genau, also hier geht es ins Eingemachte. Und nicht nur sie war vor dem Kongress, sondern man hat dann verschiedene Anhörungen gemacht mit TikTok, Snapchat, YouTube auch, die YouTube-Chefin hör mal nachher noch. Und auch Facebook musste sich rechtfertigen. Natürlich kam eine dieser Standardantworten.
Facebooks Peach sagte, wir sind nicht mit ihrer Charakterisierung der vielen der Probleme, die sie übernommen hat. Es ist Zeit, Standardrules für das Internet zu beginnen.
Facebook sagt, es ist Zeit für Regulierungen, lasst uns gemeinsam Regulierungen und Standards entwickeln. Wir kennen alle das Gegenargument, aber weil Corrie Doktorow das so wunderbar auf den Punkt gebracht hat, in 20 Sekunden. Er ist hier im Podcast mit Jeff Jarvis, den wir alle kennen als den großen Lobbyisten für Google, Facebook und so weiter. Der dann immer sagt, ich verteidige nur das Internet. Lasst sie doch erstmal machen. Der Buchdruck wurde auch nicht gleich in der ersten Woche reguliert und so. Er macht sein Standardargument. Dann ist aber Jeff Jarvis und Corey da und fängt ihn wieder ein.
One thing we could do is, there's probably gonna be an antitrust settlement in Facebook's future. Or at least a chance for it.
Regulate us, says Facebook.
I mean, the Regulate Us, the Facebook version of Regulate Us is, please impose a bunch of rules that will cost us 1% of our annual turnover to comply with, but will be so expensive that no one can ever enter the market and compete with us, right?
Also wenn man es so auf den Punkt bringt, weiß auch Jeff Jarvis nicht mehr, was er dagegen sagen soll. Ja, die Ansehen von Facebook sind natürlich reguliert und so, dass es nur 1% Umsatzkost hat, aber alle anderen vom Markt fernhält, weil nur wir mit dem mitmachen können mit der Regulierung. Amy Klobuchar äußert sich hier zu Frances Horgan und sagt, ja, das ist schon so ein bisschen dieser Snowden-Moment.
So what are the next steps here and I'd love your overview of the hearing.
Und da ist sie direkt im Pivot Podcast zu Gast bei Kara Swisher.
So what are the next steps here and I'd love your overview of the hearings and what do you think the impact was? And that's what I'm hoping happens.
Ja, Facebook hatte ja schon mal so ein Problem, als sie in der Anhörung nach der 2016er Wahl die Fragen bekamen. Also sie haben politische Werbung geschaltet, ja, und sich dafür bezahlen, was ein ja, in russischen Rubel. Und dann so, ja, und sie haben das nicht weiter, nee. Und das ist ja hier auch so ein bisschen. Diese Instagram Sache verfängt halt unglaublich. Wir haben sie ja das letzten Monat auch besprochen. Also dieses Teenage-Girl-Ding und so, weil das auch alles so Töchter und Enkel von den Politikern und so weiter betrifft. Also das hat sie dann doch irgendwie so alle sehr mitgenommen. Und Amy Klobuchar hat so eine kleine Runde gedreht. Sie war zum Beispiel auch im Wall Street Journal bei so einer Konferenz auf der Bühne und hat dann auch noch mal diesen Moment herausgearbeitet. Und wir wissen ja, was sie meint, wenn sie sagt, 10 Jahre Arbeit. Sie hat es ja in ihr Antitrust Buch zum Beispiel mit einfließen lassen.
Das ist unser großes Jahr.
Ja, und das ist ja dieser neue Dreh. Wir haben es ja ausführlich besprochen. Es ist nicht mehr der Markt und dann großer Player A gegen großer Player B und der eine wirft dem anderen Monopol vor und es ist auch nicht nur die Kundenbeziehung zu, die Preisgestaltung ist nachteilig für den Kunden, weil jemand die Preise dominiert, sondern nein, es sind jetzt aus, also kompliziertere Gefüge, die da da sind. Facebook kostet ja nichts und ist trotzdem halt da einfach ein Marktplayer. Und sie dreht jetzt das Argument um und jetzt kommen wir auch zu diesem Habermas vor, er meinte ja, die sollen ja einfach Verantwortung übernehmen, also Haftung für das, was sie tun. Und bisher kennen wir das Kartellrecht und das Monopolrecht und alles, was sie unter Antitrust und sie will es ja auch neu nennen, Mitbewerbsrecht und so weiter, dass man sagt, wenn der Kunde über die Kosten, die eben auferlegt werden, Nachteile erfahren durch ein Monopol, dann ist es für ihn problematisch. Und sie hat jetzt diesen Dreh, der ist eigentlich gar nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert, aber dann doch innovativ zu sagen, wir bleiben nicht auf der sachlichen Ebene und sagen einfach Verantwortung, Haftung und so weiter, sondern wir nehmen trotzdem das Geld, aber nicht das Geld der Kunden als Ausgabe, sondern das Geld auf der Einnahmenseite, also den Profit der Unternehmen. Und in der Hinsicht kriegt sie nämlich ein ganz elegantes Argument hin, in dem sie sagt, die haften nicht für Inhalte, aber für die Profite, mit denen sie die Inhalte ausbeuten, also die Verwendung der Inhalte hinsichtlich des eigenen Gewinns.
Aber wie sähe das aus? Wie stellt man sich das vor?
Wir hören uns mal den Clip an und dann versteht man es. Ja, also die Amplification. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sich da einfach neoklassische Marktteilnehmer, alle haben die gleichen Rechte, das deliberative Modell der Konsensfindung, sondern nein, die greifen ja mit generativen Mechanismen ein und verstärken einige Inhalte und dimmen andere runter. Und generieren darüber Profit, haben dann als Kollateralschaden plötzlich hungernde Mädchen und stürmen auf die Bastille. Und da greifen sie ein. Sie sagen halt, die Inhalte sind ja nicht von sich aus so attraktiv, sondern sie werden so attraktiv gemacht, um ökonomisch ausgebeutet zu werden. Und genau das ist das Problem. Und dann will sie eben wissen, wo kommt denn jetzt der Profit her? Wie viel Profit macht eigentlich Instagram? Und wo genau setzt der denn an?
Das heißt aber, diese Unternehmen müssten ja, und vor allem Facebook müsste, genau das ja offenlegen.
Genau bilanzieren. Genau, das genau bilanzieren. Was da Sache ist. Und genau dem geht sie nach. Beispielsweise bei der Frage, U13-Kinder sind auf Instagram verboten. Also die App ist einfach nicht für U13-Kinder gemacht. Das hält aber Facebook offenbar nicht davon aus, Kinder, die dann trotzdem U13 da sind, denen Werbung anzuzeigen und trotzdem von ihnen zu profitieren. Sondern sie müssten eigentlich klar selegieren und sagen, oh, da haben wir gerade einen U13 rausgefunden. An dem dürfen wir jetzt nichts verdienen.
Genauso wie man früher, als es noch Videotheken gab, man nicht unter 18 da rein konnte. Und wenn man da reinging, dann wurde man auch ausgeschickt. Und dann durfte nicht der Verkäufer sagen, ach, jetzt wo du schon mal da bist, hier suche ich mal ein paar Filme aus.
Wir dürfen mit dir keinen Umsatz machen. Das ist die Regel. Und da fragt sie hier direkt nach.
Wir haben diese Information.
Sie kriegt keine Antwort auf die Frage, wo man schon sieht, aha, da denkt auch Facebook, da liegt der Pfefferbegraben. Also tänzeln wir mal da drum. Also das ist sozusagen die Anhörungsgeschichte bis hierhin. Da wird man dann mal sehen, inwieweit sie diesem Geldargument nachgeht. Aber ganz wichtig, nicht die Haftungsfrage stellen, denn oder sagen wir mal, bevor wir das hören, hier noch ein kleiner, weil sie gerade sagte, Phillybuster, ich habe im Senat auch immer Phillybuster Probleme und jetzt Phillybustern sie mich auch mit einer blöden Antwort. Das dreht sie so ein bisschen um. Sie ist bei The View zugeschaltet, bei ABC, dieser sonntaglichen Kaffeeklatschrunde und möchte einfach nicht aufhören zu reden.
Und jetzt kommen wir zurück zu den Dingen, die in diesem Gespräch über Immigration, Reform und Klimaschutz und andere Dinge gemacht haben.
Leola Port macht hier mal dieses ganz wichtige Argument, dass sich das Habermas dann doch ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segeln nimmt.
Interesting article in Techdirt about Section 230. And boy, that brings it home.
Und das würde im Prinzip auch für jeden Blogger dann gelten.
Deswegen, das ist ganz heikel, diese Verantwortungsübernahme, weil man weiß auch nicht, wo endet das dann, ja, beim Kabelleger, der einfach nur das Internet als Service zur Verfügung stellt. Also diese Verantwortung würde ich daraus nehmen, aber am Ende, und das ist ja das Problem, es ist diese Werbestrategie, die dahintersteht, dieses punktuelle Zuschneiden von Publikum und so weiter und so fort. Also wenn man das Geldargument im Sinne von Klobocar geregelt bekommt, hat man, glaube ich, schon relativ viel gewonnen. Dann kann man sich immer noch angucken, wie viel Verantwortung man noch nachbauen muss über Haftungen, aber dann ist schon viel. Gut, aber das müssen wir abwarten, wie das ist. Wir hören jetzt nochmal in diese Diskussion allgemein rein, wie es um Facebook insgesamt steht. Und da ist ja Scott Galloway wirklich einer, der da immer all in geht. Also diesen Pivot-Podcasting kann ich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr empfehlen. Jetzt hat sich Facebook umbenannt. Schon vor Tagen und Wochen war das natürlich klar, dass es dazu kommt. Nur das wird in Deutschland, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu verkürzt. Er hat sich umbenannt. Ne, es gibt jetzt ein neues Mantelunternehmen, Meta, und Facebook ist nur noch eins von vielen, so wie Alphabet und dann Google, YouTube und so weiter. Nur weil wir immer noch alle Facebook sagen, heißt das ja nicht. Das ist allerdings eine sehr große strukturelle Änderung für Mark Zuckerberg.
Aber ich denke, das ist eine schmale Strategie. Er will sich von Facebook aus wechseln.
Ja, das ist eine sehr gewitzte Strategie von Zuckerberg, denn ihm gehört der Mantel und dann sagt er, ja, hier wird jetzt jemand eingesetzt, also Charles Sandberg musste ja auch schon einige Polen aus dem Feuer nehmen und da wird er vielleicht noch jemand anderes jetzt finden oder sie macht's, das wird man sehen und er kann sich dann so schön da dezent zurückhalten und kann dann seine Spielereien machen, an denen er offenbar Freude gefunden hat. Das war jetzt auch wieder bei dieser Präsentation, dass er sich dann da zeigt, wie er dann dort konferiert als Comicmännchen und andere haben sich noch ein anderes Kostüm ausgesucht. Also das ist ja, wie kann man das meinen? Also ist das vielleicht schon diese, diese Neuheit, also ist das vielleicht symptomatisch vielleicht, was wir da bei Mark Zuckerberg sehen. Offenbar ist das ja jemand, der Probleme hat mit menschlicher Nähe. Also das ist ja ganz offensichtlich auch, wie er sich verhält bei diesen Anhörungen oder so. Das ist ja, erlaube mir mal diesen Ausdruck, nicht normal, sich so zu verhalten. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass das vielleicht aber symptomatisch ist. Also und zwar hat mir ein Freund ein Foto geschickt aus einem Berliner Café. Da war so ein Schälchen aufgestellt. Und da stand überschrieben da Tips, also Trinkgeld. Und folgendermaßen wurde dann Trinkgeld erklärt. They are like Hugs without the awkward body contact. Und ich hätte mir erstmal gedacht, gut, ich habe also mein ganzes Leben noch nie gedacht, ich gebe kein Trinkgeld, sondern umarme lieber jemanden. Aber dass man hier so awkward body contact schreibt, zeigt eigentlich schon sehr genau, wo man sich so hinbewegt. Nämlich weg von der menschlichen Nähe hin zu so einem Metaverse, in dem man dann nur noch als Figur auftritt, die aber nicht mehr berührt werden kann.
Ich meine, wovon erlöst uns das Smartphone? Nach dem Weg zu fragen, Information einzuholen, an der Kasse zu stehen. Machen wir alles mit dem Smartphone. Ja, in deren Sicht, ja, Mark Zuckerberg ist ein komischer Typ. Und ich hätte ehrlich gesagt, also wir haben ja letzten Monat dieses Meta-Ding, was er vorgestellt hat, auch sehr unter er. Das ist so. Da arbeiten die seit fünf Jahren dran. Das sieht immer noch scheiße aus. Jetzt ist das der letzte Rettungsanker. Also daran hängen die jetzt alles auf. Und wie macht man es? Klar, man gründet Meta. Dann hat man die CEO-Facebook-Posten frei. Also wenn der Kongress das nächste Mal ein Facebook-CEO sprechen will, das ist halt nicht mehr Mark Zuckerberg, sondern, und wie Scott Galloway das beschreibt, ist wieder mal typisch Scott Galloway.
Die linke Linie ist, dass Amerika jeden Tag mehr wie Amerika wird. Es ist ein unglaubliches Test, wie jemandes Wissen.
Er zahlt jetzt einfach 10 Millionen im Jahr, um dann diese ganzen Facebook-CEO-Sachen über sich ergehen zu lassen. Und Nick Leck und so. Das sind ja alles solche Leute, die da einfach jetzt in dieses scheiß Sandwich schon reinbeißen. Corey Doktorow sitzt jetzt da und wir haben ja im Salon diesen New York Times Text gelesen, wo nochmal diese Intransparenz von Facebook so zentral gesetzt wurde. Und das ist ja auch das größte Problem, dass sie einfach so intransparent sind. Weil wenn wir wüssten, was auf Facebook vor sich geht, dann würden wir auch anders damit umgehen. Und Corey Doktorow geht hier mal auf dieses Privacy-Argument ein. Also wenn wir wüssten, was Facebook mit uns macht, und nennt dann mal einen ganz interessanten Namen.
Und die Grundlage dafür, dass es keinen privaten Recht der Aktion hat, ist, dass sie korrekt beschlossen haben, dass, wenn es einen privaten Recht der Aktion gäbe, die Technik-Plattformen thermonukleare zu verhören würden. Er war ein Rechtsschüler aus Österreich, ging nach Stanford, kam zurück nach Europa und sagte, warte einen Sekunde, Facebook ist total verletzt europäischer Privatschlauch. Ich werde sie mir meine Daten geben und herausfinden, wie schlimm es ist.
Ja, Max Schrems hat kürzlich wieder mit Edward Snowden korrespondiert, also öffentlich.
Also hat er diese Bude da, Not of None of Your Business, NOIP, wo man auch unterstützend mithelfen kann, finanziell und auch sonst. Und deren Auftrag ist ja, also selbstgestellte Auftrag, die Gesetze, die da sind, anwenden, während so Epicenter Works und so weiter mehr so die Gesetze mitgestalten, die so in Brüssel entstehen, 60 Schrems hinden und sagt, wir wenden das jetzt einfach mal an. Und nicht nur nennt er hier Max Schrems, sondern er setzt ihn auch mal in so eine historische Parallele zu Lawrence Lessig und Microsoft damals.
Da ist ein Vorfall für das.
Wer wäre ein guter Specialmaster für Facebook?
Also, der Microsoft Specialmaster war ein Freund, den wir kennen und lieben, namens Lawrence Lessig. Ich meine, Max Schrems? Jemand würde wirklich weh tun. Wir haben endlich einen guten Austrian in unseren politischen Befehl gebeten. Nach dem ungerissen Strang des dismalen Austrians, mit von Heyek und Schwarzenegger, haben wir endlich einen wirklich guten Austrian. Ich denke, du kannst sagen, der Specialmaster war gut für die Gesellschaft, aber auch für Microsoft in der langen Zeit.
Ja, ich hab's ja schon häufiger angemerkt. Der Mund-Kartellrecht-Chef in Deutschland hat ja schon 2014 oder so gesagt, wir brauchen den Datenschutz mit hier im Kartellrecht. So und Max Schrems bietet sich ja eine gute Combo, wenn er jetzt einfach die Beziehung aus Unternehmen und Nutzer fürs Kartellrecht und dann Westhaker und so weiter aufwärmt, sodass die mal schön europäisch da nicht nur Gesetze anwenden, sondern auch mitgestalten. So wie Lawrence Lessig damals eingesetzt wurde, um bei Microsoft ein bisschen unterstützend tätig zu werden als Microsoft. Das kennen wir alle noch. Den eigenen Browser und so weiter, den Internet Explorer, immer mit installieren. Aber die Frage, darf man die Plattform und das Produkt so nebeneinander verkoppeln? Dann hieß es nein und große Strafe. Und Carl Dockdorf erzählt die Geschichte häufiger und kommt hier auch noch mal drauf zu sprechen, wie nachhaltig traumatisiert Microsoft durch dieses politische Verfahren damals war.
Und es ist auf YouTube, du solltest es jetzt sehen. Aber das Antifrash-Kurs endete 7 Jahre für die Android-Akkursion.
Also Facebook macht ja auch gerade traumatische Wochen durch, das muss man sagen, aber es ist halt noch nicht so konkret, was passiert jetzt und so, aber dass es da zur Sache geht, seht man ja schon. Und die Einigkeit ist so groß, dass nicht nur die Republikaner und die Demokraten zusammen, da einfach mit Francis Horgen wissen, worum es geht. Und Corey Doktorow hier schon das Argument gegen Jeff Chaves macht, der dann auch darauf einschwenkt, sondern am Ende dieses New York Times-Tings zum Thema Transparenz müsste Facebook nicht einfach radikal transparent werden, sodass er jeder einfach reinschauen kann. Da ist dann sogar Jeff Jarvis noch mit einverstanden.
Nur frage ich mich immer, wie das durchgesetzt werden soll. Also das kann ich natürlich einfordern, ich kann auch entsprechende Gesetze machen, aber Fakt ist ja auch, dass Facebook jetzt einfach viel zurückgehalten hat, wo man sagen kann, das ist eigentlich nicht rechtens, dass das zurückgehalten wird. Jetzt kann man natürlich die Gesetze verschärfen, dass es dreimal nicht rechtens ist. Aber die eine Sache ist, einzufordern, das und das wüssten wir gerne, da hätten wir gerne die Zahlen. Aber wie will man etwas einfordern, von dem man gar nicht weiß, dass es existiert?
Ja, und da könnte man ja, und da haben wir ja auch schon über Crowd Tangle kurz gesprochen, also dieses kleine Projekt von Universitäten, die so besondere Schnittstellen zu Facebook hatten, um da einfach mal nachzuschauen, was da da ist. Und da sieht man ja auch nur, und Cory Dockdorf kann sich nur darüber lustig machen, dass solche Projekte eben enden, dabei müsste man die jetzt so hochfahren.
So sagten sie, CrowdTangle sei kaputt.
Facebook hat gesagt, CrowdTangle funktioniert ja nicht, und dann stellte es sich heraus, ne, CrowdTangle hat rausgefunden, also die Uni. Die meistgeteilten Inhalte, Top Ten, waren Impf-Lügen. Das stimmte. Und Facebook wollte es noch nicht wahrhaben, und deswegen die API da gekippt. Aber man kann ja durchaus sagen, also ich gesetzlich werde das doch zurücklementieren, dass man sagt, ein berechtigtes Interesse der Öffentlichkeit formuliert als Forschungsfrage durchgeführt von Forschungsinstituten kann ein AGB nicht widersprechen. Sondern das ist dann einfach so geregelt. Wer auf dem Markt teilnehmen will, das ist Wiener, halten sie an, wir durchsuchen jetzt ihr Fahrgut-Transporter. Und dann muss man anhalten und kann hier einfach weiterfahren. Und so wäre das ja hier eigentlich auch. Corey Doktorow ist da in diesem Gespräch, und jetzt wird es so ein bisschen wahnsinnig. Wir hören uns mal, ohne dass ich vorher sage, an was er hier 40 Sekunden sagt.
Ich denke, dass Firmen nicht zu den Schwerpunkt der Schwerpunkte die Städte zu ihren Schwerpunktsteilern können. Aber ich denke, dass ich mit China anders bin, als ich denke, dass die Städte sich zu konstitutieren. Ich denke, dass die Städte demokratisch zu sich selbst erhoben werden.
Sehr, sehr gut. Denn Demokratie bedeutet ja, dass Macht aufgeteilt ist, bedeutet, dass sie verändert werden kann, dass sie nicht auf Dauer ist, usw. Und wenn man aber Konzernstrukturen schafft, die eigentlich auf Ewigkeit und Allmacht angelegt sind, dann stellt sich die Frage, wie das noch zusammenpassen kann. Und es passt natürlich nicht zusammen.
Ja, Mark Zuckerberg ist auf Lebenszeit anhand wie Xi Jinping. Und beide bestimmen das Leben der jeweiligen Bevölkerung in Amerika und in China. Und klar, er lacht selber ein bisschen darüber, aber warum nicht? So muss man es, also in dieser Monstruosität muss man sich es eigentlich mal vergegenwärtigen. Scott Galloway hat auch was zu China zu sagen.
Eine der Dinge, die sie klar registriert haben, ist, dass Big Tech die Regierung überlegt und die Nationale Interessen zu privaten Interessen verbreitet. China kommt in und hat diese Firmen mit einer Markteschaffung von 100 Billionen Dollar und sagt, sorry, du bist aus dem Geschäft.
Das haben wir ja auch schon gehört. Ich hatte das mitgebracht das letzte Mal, glaube ich, vom Doppelgänger-Podcast. Philipp Klöckner hat ja auch gesagt, die machen das ja, was das hier anbelangt, eigentlich sehr richtig. Beziehungsweise werden wir uns in zehn Jahren die Frage stellen, hätten wir nicht damals auch erkennen müssen.
China lernt vom schlechten Beispiel Amerika und wird es besser machen, auch wenn das hunderte Milliarden Vermögensvernichtung erstmal bedeutet. Und das ist natürlich schon mal ein hartes Statement. Naja, die Sachlage, die thematische Tonlage ist in Amerika auch so, dass die Kongressfrage Runde für TikTok, Snapchat und YouTube mit einer Triggerwarnung bei PBS gestartet wurde.
William Brangham hat unsere Unterrichtsweise, begonnen mit diesem Report.
Also das, was es nicht mehr gibt, wenn man bei TikTok ist, da haben wir mal im Salon kurz drüber gesprochen, glaube ich auch, wie schnell es geht, bis man dann in irgendeine Blase hineingerutscht ist und plötzlich bekommt man nur noch Inhalte zu, zum Beispiel Suizid angezeigt. 55 Minuten dauert das, glaube ich, oder 40 Minuten sogar. Und hier sind wir wieder bei diesem Habermas-Thema. Also Habermas sagt jetzt toll, dass es die Massenmedien gibt. Denn die machen genau das, was sie jetzt gerade hier macht, die Moderatorin zu sagen, Vorsicht, also das sind jetzt sensible Inhalte. Während Sloterdijk sagen würde, lass doch den Ernst neulter rein. Das ist doch auch alles ein bisschen Meinungslandschaft hier.
Ja, da war vorhin so ein bisschen scharf das Sloterdijk. Habe ich auch nicht ganz nachvollziehen können. Ja, aber im Grunde, ich meine, im Hintergrund ist ein Handy abgebildet, auf dem die Apps sind, die auf dem Telefon der Kinder so laufen. Und dann gibt es für die Eltern eine Triggerwarnung. Achtung, jetzt geht es mal richtig zur Sache. Und das ist natürlich betrüblich. Amy Klobuchar, auch in dieser Anhörung natürlich. Wir hören nur den PBS, also den kleinen O-Ton, den sie rausgeschnitten haben. Und hier geht es nochmal ums Geld. Ein Profit-Game, in dem das Schicksal der Kinder als Kollateralschaden mitgeschleift wird. Also da kann ja niemand einverstanden sein.
Wir hatten das jetzt mit der Natur, haben wir das ja genauso gemacht. Da haben wir gesagt, das ist halt der Kollateralschaden. Wir sehen es ja nicht. Genau, aber bei den Kindern sehen wir es direkt. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein sehr gutes Thema, mit dem man das oder beziehungsweise es ist sehr gut, dass darauf immer wieder zu Münzen, denn das Problem ist natürlich viel größer als jetzt zu fragen, bekommen junge Mädchen Essstörungen durch Instagram. Das ist eine wichtige Frage, aber die Frage an sich ist ja noch mal viel größer. Aber es damit zu machen, ist glaube ich ganz sinnvoll, wenn man politische Mehrheiten gewinnen will. Denn jeder hat Kinder oder erkennt Kinder und möchte Kinder beschützen.
Enkel vor allem.
Und deswegen ist es sehr, sehr sinnvoll, auf diese Weise jetzt das Ganze einzubetten. Denn sonst halte ich das auch wieder für eine Diskussion, die so sehr im kleinen Kreise bleibt. Ja, für Kartellrechner interessant, für Ökonomen interessant, aber die nicht darüber hinausgeht. Und das ist noch so der Punkt, wo man, glaube ich, etwas erreichen kann.
Ja, und da gibt es große Einigkeit. Und jetzt hören wir noch mal eine zweite republikanische Stimme. In dem Falle die Senatorin Marsha Blackburn. Die fragt nämlich eine ganz einfache Frage an die YouTube-Chefin Susan Wojtcik, oder wie sie heißt. Kann man mit ihren AGBs und ihren Community-Guidelines Suizidvideos verbieten oder nicht? Kann sie nicht genau sagen. Kann sie nur irgendwo sich nachliefern. Wir wollen aber hier noch eine positive Sache nennen. In Europa und Deutschland haben wir ja keine große sozusagen Consumer-Elektronik, was diese Software-Schmiederei angeht. Aber es gab diesen Monat den AI Act des Europaparlamentes. Das Europaparlament ermächtigt sich nämlich jetzt selbst immer schon durch Beschlüsse, kommende Gesetzgebungen, die natürlich nur aus der EU-Kommission geben darf, einzuhägen. Und da haben sie jetzt einfach schon mal ihre Vorstellungen, wie so ein Gesetz aussehen könnte, das Leitplanken zum Umgang mit künstlicher Intelligenz und so weiter schon mal eingehägt. Waren da wohl auch sehr mutig. Und wir hören mal kurz im Netzpolitik-Podcast, wie das Europaparlament über Gesichtserkennung als Spezialunterthema zum Fall denkt. Ging jetzt so nicht ganz in den Beschluss ein, aber die sind dann doch recht meinungsfreudig dort.
Erst vor einigen Monaten gab es eine Abstimmung, wo das Parlament gesagt hat, es soll ein Moratorium geben auf Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum, aber es sich eben nicht recht durchringen konnte, zu dieser Sache komplett die Absage zu teilen. Was wir jetzt sehen, ist, dass das Parlament immer stärker in die Richtung geht, aus ethischen Gründen, Gesichtserkennung eine völlige Absage zu teilen. Das ist quasi die Debatte, die wir dann auch haben werden, mit der eigentlichen Verordnung, wo das Parlament in einigen Monaten seine Position festlegen wird.
Wir haben ja hier vor Monaten auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Da haben wir auch gesagt, das kann man auch mal ächten. So wie eine Landmine. Und das Oberparlament ist auch so fast der Meinung.
Schafft man vielleicht auch eine Sensibilität für, denn das Gesicht spielt eine wichtige Rolle jetzt, wo wir es so lange verdecken mussten unter der Maske. Wurde auch noch mal von konservativer Seite gesagt, ja, aber das Gesicht ist doch ganz entscheidend für uns, wie wir miteinander umgehen und und und. Also ich glaube, auch dieses Thema kann man noch mal ganz gut aufladen.
Also mal gucken, wie weit die Debatte da geht. Scott Galloway hat mehrere Vermutungen. Zum einen, irgendwer bei Facebook hat so einen Handschellen abgeführt, dass es alle mal sehen. Und dann auch wirklich zur persönlichen Verantwortung gezogen. Könnte natürlich gleich der Eigentümer sein, warum nicht? Und es wird auch für YouTube nochmal brenzlig, denn so wie Facebook Instagram mit jungen Mädchen umgegangen ist, geht ja YouTube mit jungen Männern um. Das haben wir ja in Sinzig auf der Bühne schon besprochen. Das ganze Rapid-Hole und InSales und QAnon-Ding und so weiter und so fort. Und beide, Carousal Fisher und Scott Galloway, sind in der Erwartung, dass der 6. Januar noch mal eine ganz große Rolle für Silicon Valley spielt, wenn nämlich klar wird. Und das werde ich am Sonntag mit Thomas auch besprechen, dass es doch sehr viel Zusammenarbeit gab zwischen Kongressabgeordneten und dem Weißen Haus, inklusive des Stabschefs Mark Meadows von Donald Trump, mit denjenigen, die zumindest die Demo mitorganisiert haben, die ja dann hochgestürmt ist auf den Kapitolsberg, um dann da wirklich einzubrechen und vermittelt über die Silicon Valley Technologien, nur einfach an Facebook.
Insofern gut, dass Habermas das hier erwähnt in seinem Aufsatz.
Da blubbert nach einem.
Also zumindest den richtigen Riecher, dass er genau darauf verweist. Also er spart ja sonst mit aktuellen, tagesaktuellen Verweisen, aber das macht er nochmal ganz deutlich.
Also 6. Januar ist da ganz wichtig.
Nun sind wir schon spät in der Zeit, deshalb würde ich sagen, wir machen nicht nochmal ein großes Fass auf, nochmal ein eigenes Thema. Das verschieben wir, was ich noch vorhatte, aber ich möchte doch zwei Clips jetzt zum Abschluss noch spielen. Und zwar Horst Seehofer ist ja auch der scheidende Innenminister, gibt aber immer noch gerne mal eine Pressekonferenz. Und wir haben jetzt hier gesehen, nicht nur Demokraten, sondern auch Republikaner zeigen Kompetenz in Sachen Plattformregulierung und so. Ganz bemerkenswert. Und jetzt nochmal deutsche Wirklichkeit, meine Damen und Herren. Es ist eine Bundespressekonferenz, es geht um Sicherheit, IT, bla bla bla. Und Seehofer wird aber jetzt noch mal grundsätzlich, ich muss sagen, ich habe es dann in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit gehört. Jetzt hören wir es in einfacher. Also man kann darin jetzt noch mal richtig baden.
Ich kann mich immer nur wundern, wenn Politikerinnen und Politiker in der Öffentlichkeit ständig die Qualität der Digitalisierung in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland problematisieren. Also das ist ein Gebiet, ich wusste nie, dass ich mal in einem wesentlichen Bereich zuständig werde als Politiker dafür. Was mich seit 40 Jahren interessiert, vom Commodore 64 beginnend und Amiga, nicht Amigo, sondern Amiga, das war einer mit einer Doppelstruktur von zwei Betriebssystemen und ich werde jetzt in der Pension die Programmiersprache C++ mir aneignen und wir reden pausenlos. Wissen Sie, wie das in der Praxis läuft?
So, also Digitalisierung ist eigentlich gar kein Problem, denn das würde eigentlich gut laufen. Das führt dann weiter und weiter aus, schon davor und auch nochmal danach. Aber jetzt die Frage, wie läuft es denn in der Praxis? Wir haben jetzt ja gemerkt, mit der Praxis ist das so eine Sache, wenn die Politik sich nicht dafür interessiert, wie zum Beispiel diese Plattformen arbeiten, was sie da so zulassen an Fake News und und und diese ganzen anderen Fragen. Auch wer verdient eigentlich dann an den Apps und wer kann da abschöpfen? Wenn man sich gar nicht die Frage stellt, was macht eigentlich so eine Smartphonesucht mit jungen Menschen? Wie verändert das die eigene Wahrnehmung und so? Dann kommt man einfach zu so einem Schluss, da müssen wir uns auch gar nicht mit beschäftigen.
Die Menschen nutzen in der Digitalisierung das, was sie für nützlich halten. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass der Deutsche Bundestag sich zu irgendeiner Stunde mal mit der Anwendung von Smartphones, von Tablets und von Laptops beschäftigt hat, sondern das haben die Leute sich gekauft, wenn sie damit einen Nutzen verbunden gesehen haben. Also die Politik hat seit eh und je die Frage, was nutzen die Menschen bei der Digitalisierung oder die Wirtschaft oder der Handwerker, so gut wie nicht beeinflusst. Die Leute haben das angewandt, gekauft, genutzt, wenn sie für sich persönlich darin einen Nutzen sahen. Dann kommt die Politik und glaubt, sie ist der Vormund und muss jetzt die Leute führen.
Nein, das überlassen wir mal alles im Markt und man kauft einfach auch so digitale Geräte wie das Küchegerät und man kriegt ja auch nicht gesagt, wie man den Eierkocher bedient und deswegen ist es egal. Und genauso sei das auch an Schulen. Da bräuchte man jetzt nicht ewig Kultusministerkonferenzen und so. Man braucht für die Kinder die Laptops und dann nutzen die die auch, sagt er.
Ich denke da so an Klöckner. Die Leute essen, was ihnen schmeckt.
Genau.
Damit müssen wir uns gar nicht befassen. Ob das dann das Klima schädigt oder den Körper und wir alle mit 50 sterben überzuckert und so. Nee, die Leute essen, was ihnen schmeckt.
Die Union ist wirklich die Entpolitisierungspartei. Man kann es nicht anders sagen.
Aber wir haben ihn jetzt verabschiedet, ne? Horst Seehofer ist damit verabschiedet. Wir werden ihn nie wieder hören sehen.
Das war das letzte Mal, aber das ist mir durch Zufall aufgekommen, als ich mal noch lineares Fernseher schaute und dort wurde diese Pressekonferenz übertragen und dann dachte ich Moment, was sagt er dann gerade und deswegen noch diese beiden Clips jetzt zum Abschied für Horst Seehofer und wir verabschieden uns damit auch. Aber wir blicken noch auf den Salon. Wir sprechen über ein Buch, das du vorgeschlagen hast, auf das ich auch sehr gespannt bin. Harald Wälzer hat einen Nachruf auf sich selbst geschrieben und wir sind gespannt, was er sagt. Ich hatte schon ein eigenartiges Interview von ihm gesehen bei Kulturzeit, wo er sagt, wir müssen jetzt mal langsamer machen und so weiter. Ich glaube, er macht Dekadentologie. Ich habe auch ein bisschen den Verdacht, also wir werden sicherlich darüber zu diskutieren haben. Ich werde ein Buch vorstellen, das mich sehr interessiert und zwar Bob Iger, der Disney-Chef, der jetzt raus ist, hat ein Buch geschrieben, das ist aber schon einige Monate draußen, aber man hat es überhaupt nicht rezipiert, das hat aber auch auf deutscher Schienen, über seine Zeit bei Disney und wie er diesen Konzern gesteuert hat, wie das lief mit dem Ankauf von Star Wars, Lucasfilm, von Marvel, von Pixar und so weiter. Ich habe schon reingelesen und es ist sehr, sehr bemerkenswert, weil es hier mal nicht darum geht, eigentlich wollten wir immer nur die Menschen alle glücklich machen, sondern hier geht es auch mal um harte Zahlen und wie verhandelt wird. Das will ich vorstellen und es gibt ein Buch, ein neues über Karl Lagerfeld, das besprechen wir aber nur am Rande, es ist ein bisschen mehr ein Bilderbuch, aber nicht ganz uninteressant. Es ist von einem Weggefährten, der sich dann um 2000 von ihm losmachte, bzw. dann verstoßen wurde, der aber sehr viel erzählen kann über Lagerfelds Warnhäuser einzurichten, auszustatten und ja, da blicken wir noch drauf. Und noch, das kann ich auch schon ankündigen, ein Artikel über Demenz und Japan. Nur mal so viel, auch das ist ganz erstaunlich, was man da so erfahren kann.
Viele Beropperter und so?
Nee, ich verrat's mal noch nicht.
Okay, sehr gut. Es gibt wohl eine Biografie von G, geschrieben von AUST. Wir sind gespannt, ich werd mal reinschauen. Ansonsten hat hier, und ich trag mal nur aus meiner Liste von Optionen vor, Thomas Ruttig, eine erste Bilanz nach zwei Monaten Taliban-Herrschaft in Afghanistan geschrieben. Und Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey machen sich Gedanken über sozialen Wandel, Sozialcharakter und Verschwörungsdenken in der spätmoderne, immer sehr hochtrabend, aber bei den Autoren kommt vielleicht noch was bei rum. Und so in die Richtung. Außerdem kann man sagen, der Salon läuft ganz wunderbar. Es sind weniger als zehn Prozent der Leute, die sich anmeldeten und jemals wieder abgemeldet haben. Also wir haben eine hohe Treue.
Das spricht für uns.
Genau, sehr gut.
Oder für unser Publikum gleichermaßen.
Wir sind ja nur die Anbieter.
Wir sind die Anbieter. Gut, wir wollen jetzt nicht wieder in die Habermas-Debatte. Das werden wir fortsetzen auf anderen Wegen. Aber erst einmal einen schönen Monat und bis zum Salon alles Gute.
Haut rein, bis denn.